foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
what's up
[Music]
guys
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
three minute all right let's do it okay
A little London system
all right wait oh nice development this
ain't bad he thinking he thinking Queen
D2 okay what is that your move
I mean it's cute you know it's a little
part you got more of them you got more
there it is
they actually played no you played good
though you play much better than I could
than I thought right great game brother
thanks Ethan thank you man
hey everyone GM Daniel nerdinski here we
asked the chess.com Community to show us
their best games from the cgc qualifiers
and we're here to highlight some of the
exciting chess that are awesome
community members cooked up in these
competitive cgc games so here we have
Bigfoot with the white pieces chess.com
producer and good friend of the site and
he carries out a lovely combination he
starts by pushing the pawn up to B4 the
threat is to put more pressure on
Black's Queen side with V5
black moves the bishop up to stop that
but now bang Bishop takes D5 from a
clear blue sky strikes a lovely
sacrifice and a combination of the point
is that after he takes D5 E6 all of a
sudden there's an exposed attack on
Black's Queen and if Black's Queen moves
away and after e takes D7 Queen takes D7
Knight C5 is a fork against the queen
and the bishop so black was forced to
improvise 95 was a good move but now
Bigfoot calmly takes the pawn on F7
Queen takes F7 D takes E5
and as a result of the combination white
emerges with an extra pawn and an
excellent position which Bigfoot
converted very very confidently started
it off with Bishop H6 to trade off the
Bishops the game only lasted another 15
moves or so this has been GM Daniel
nariditsky sharing another amazing
Community highlight from the chess.com
Global Championship qualifiers
we are here at the chest.com global
championship in Belgrade with Grand
Master nihal sarin who is tied 2-2 after
day one the levy Rosman on the live
commentary was saying that Anish plays
poorly against Magnus when Magnus plays
the perks does that factor in did you
study anisha's weakness against the
perks not exactly first game I went into
his prep and got crushed so I just tried
to get some interesting position which
is not in his prep does risky choice but
it worked out brilliantly are you happy
with the 2-2 result after day one at the
start I would have been but after having
a good chance to win three games today
I'm not so happy but it could have been
worse of course and final question in
your first match you actually had a
laptop here and you were sometimes
looking at some chess but today no
laptop no device was there a reason that
you uh just wanted to be left to your
own thoughts for today's games anyway
during the games you're using a lot of
brains so I thought we should get some
rest at least between
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Hotel Toronto there is plenty on the
line each of the four remaining players
face elimination only two will move on
for a shot at two hundred thousand
dollars it's day two of the semifinals
at the chess.com Global championship and
it starts right now
yes my sister was born in Vancouver but
as wonderful as Andrea and Vancouver are
it's pretty tough not to fall in love
with the city of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
largest city in Canada the people here
have been playing chess and clubs in
universities and in public parks for
well over a century
and now this wonderful place plays host
to the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks four of the
world's best players have survived to
continue their quest for the queen size
share of the one million dollar prize
pool ah okay they're not they're
pre-moving I guess there was a reason
Knight F3 doesn't work a draw is agreed
by repetition what a game
my friends you're in the right place
it's time for the cgc finals Toronto
Canada officially has it all just like
my sister and who wrote this garbage
foreign
as we head inside the one Hotel Toronto
we'll ask someone to take out the
garbage what has not been trash though
is the quality of the rapid chest we
have seen this week and there is much
more to come
welcome to the game play haul I am here
once again with Levy Canty and Donya as
we get set for today's semi-final
matchups we will soon be joined by
Robert Hess and Fabiano caruana as well
to call today's matches fellas by the
end of today we'll know who's playing
for the championship match how excited
are we here to be here today how
exciting has Toronto been for you Levy
it's been great the food's been amazing
and yesterday we had some squat chests
we had some push-up chests against you
against fobby so I'm having a great time
looking forward to these matches today
are you a little sore today uh you know
uh not not so much it's all easy for you
it's nothing man you know you want to do
some push-ups right now Danny
listen I'm boring I'm not a partier I
don't do push-ups but I judge a city by
the quality of its food and the food has
been incredible I had some awesome
Persian food the other day I'm loving
Toronto
we're all having a great time here in
Toronto and we're going to get set for
today's semi-final matches let's dive
into the two semis that we have taking a
look at our bracket once again you see
the two Americans at the top we are
entering game fives Nakamura and so are
knotted up at two games a piece they got
there by four draws but it got more
intense throughout the day the bottom
half we also have a match that is tied
at two games a piece between Anish giri
and nihal sarin some decisive blows
traded there as well as a couple draws
here we have the championship that will
go down on Sunday and Monday we will
ultimately be crowning our first Global
Champion that evening
guys when we look at the bracket what
stands out to you at this point both
matches are tied so much at stake Levy
what do you got I think both matches are
playing out exactly how we thought they
would Hikaru versus Wesley is a very
high level opening and strategic battle
that's why we had four draws yesterday
nihal Saran and Anish giri are basically
doing the equivalent of punching each
other constantly knocking each other
down and that's why that one is tied two
to two yeah yeah that was a great
summary and one of the magical things
about Chess is that you could have two
matches that have the same exact score
maybe some even some of the same results
but the storyline and the Arc of these
matches could not have been more
different I just love that variety that
we're getting yeah same scores uh
different ways of getting there of
course uh like uh Soren Vince barn and
then you know Geary don't get weary
right and then we got knocking Wesley
right Naka oshakia and West going Flex
that's just how it is right these guys
have been doing good good and it's tied
up even matched so of course I wonder
with both matches tied two games a piece
if we asked all four players and and
they had to take a lie detector test how
do they see themselves in the Armageddon
that could be coming right do they
really see themselves the favorite or do
they want to finish things here in
regulation right what would they say if
they they were taking a true serum but
all right before we dig into these
matches we begin with a closer look at
Anish Geary earlier this week Nemo sat
down with the star from the Netherlands
who set his sights on extending his trip
in Toronto
[Music]
I thought you know if I come all the way
from Europe it's a long flight I might
as well try to stick around and I hope
to make it a memorable stay I am here
with Anish Curie I will be interrogating
him a little bit how would you rate your
play in 2022 I think it was sort of an
average year but I I think still there
are some big events especially this one
also maybe we'll drop it in blitz so I
think it's not the time yet to you know
to count the
what do they say count with chickens and
they count the eggs in the basket or
something to do with chickens and eggs I
think but yeah not not the time yet to
count them where would you personally
rank rapid chess amongst protest formats
back in the day the classical chairs had
much more weight to it I think it's got
sort of shift to then now like all these
events is also online and also wrap them
Blitz are really important what are your
own internal expectations for competing
this week in the cgc in Toronto I was
really happy to qualify for this event
usually I get you know the privileged
truth I get invited but here you have to
qualify and I'm really happy to make it
will you be trying to take advantage of
Toronto while you're here yeah I'll uh
I'll be staying here in fact until the
end of the tournament no matter what
happens so I hope I will not have the
time thank you Anish
it'll be good to have a niche here no
matter what happens of course but he
would like to still be playing at the
end of this matchup we're tied at two
games a piece as we can see and just
like the box score reads it started with
a win for a niche sorry bounced back
then a couple of crazy draws all right
guys a lot to unpack here but before we
dig in let's quickly review our picks
now Levy you weren't with us yesterday
but let's review and tell everybody who
did you pick honestly yes it's time
who'd you take so first of all thank you
for not having me on the pregame
yesterday I came you know to a store
like my shoes you know I wanted to pack
I had Anish giri taking this match uh
I'm also four for four on my picks I
just want to just tell that to uh the
camera right there and so I wasn't going
to go away from a niche the problem with
this match though is it's been
topsy-turvy his biggest strength is
getting a smooth position out of the
opening nihal has that strength also and
if you leave both players in an
uncomfortable position then I'm gonna
take nihal but I believe in a niche
today it's still it's basically a best
of four going into the Armageddon so I'm
sticking with him yep I also took a
niche everyone saw me Pekingese
yesterday not just because he was here
and gives a good hug I literally
believed that he is just just a slight
Edge and I think his experience is going
to pay off the longer this match goes on
absolutely I'm going with Gary once
again of course I love my guy and uh
he's very prepared one of the best
prepared in the world and of course when
time is there too as well he has time
had all that time in between today and
yesterday to actually prepare I think
I'm gonna still go with gear here Donya
you're the only guy sitting here who
didn't take Gary don't worry he's not in
the room so tell us really why tell us
the inside scoop oh well first of all I
mentioned that Anish plays best with a
chip on his shoulder but I'm also just
on the knee-haul train based on how he's
played online in the last couple of
months and yeah Levy said this match was
very topsy-turvate has been missed
uncharacteristic missed opportunities by
nehal we're so accustomed to him playing
ridiculously clean chess and
capitalizing on his opportunities if he
manages to capitalize on the next
opportunity he gets I think he's gonna
have a great chance to win the match I
think this next game game five I have a
feeling that this game is going to
decide the match for whatever okay wow
that's a that's a big call out game five
gonna decide it but okay our picks from
day one aside how do we see this match
going down John you just said he thinks
game five is huge the X's and O's on
paper Levy what do you think is going to
happen here well what happens if game
five is a
drawer oh I see it oh okay you think
someone's gonna win and somebody's gonna
take it after that okay no that that I
mean that's a fair point yeah finish
comes out striking and everything goes
well then yeah maybe he just takes it
all the way down it really just feels
like a niche has to like strike once and
hold on for dear life right but how
strategy is going to be a little bit
different like he could maybe try to
build on a lead or I don't exactly know
what nihal's path might be but for a
niche I know that's got to be the path
yeah and like there's the reason I'm I'm
predicting a decisive result is because
in fact these last two games have ended
in draws or Miracles it was like one
side was gonna win or the other side is
gonna win
um and you know the opening choices have
been very flamboyant I think both
players are just going to step on the
gas pedal we're gonna have two cars
going after each other and uh you know I
just don't see that kind of game ending
in a draw for the third time in a row
you know I would give a niche the slight
Edge to start the day as well because we
know he is better in the opening stage
he's so well prepared he's had a night
to think about it review maybe what went
wrong where Nihao was kind of slipping
away from him in the first stage I think
he's going to bring some solid prep and
start off on the right foot absolutely I
think the prep is uh is in the pudding
and putting's in the prep you know what
I mean like that's the first time you
ever heard that but right of course it's
Geary right you know Gary is a prep
monster I mean I even uh I thought it
says child support courses I have all of
them in fact and the preparation that
goes into that is ridiculous but of
course um obviously he's having some
problems with starring in the
complicated positions where the tactics
obviously jump off there as you made a
point there Levy where he's uh in the
sharp type positions you see sarin
actually kind of edging out there I kind
of see that too as well but Geary I mean
I think he's going to get the prep he
needs you know in the first game here
has shown he has some nerves right yeah
he's human he can mess things up so yeah
we'll see you know it's funny I think we
we've all established that we feel like
if Anish gets the win in the opening he
maybe wins the match but the longer it
gets into the scrambles the more we all
like in the house so let's see who gets
the better of them speaking of who's
going to get the better of the other we
know the Americans have a long history
so let's turn to the other semi-final
this one of course between Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley so Nemo spent some
time on Monday with Wesley who talked
about his high expectations this week at
the cgc finals
I'm very excited I mean I have to fight
for my spot because there are always
other players other younger players but
I like I like the game give your bestie
what happens hey I just want to play
some good chess
so Wesley are you excited to be here
this week yeah definitely first it's
good to
be all the people here in chess.com and
I'm very excited because it's the
biggest online chess tournament what are
your own internal expectations for
competing this week I really look
forward
tournament format okay yeah it's
interesting because you know you don't
know when you're going home as long as
you don't lose too many games and you
still got a chance how is preparing for
a rapid tournament like cgc different
from preparing for large over-the-board
events six years ago most of the
tournaments were classical but this year
we're really moving in online also
faster time controls and speeches so you
gotta be very good with be very good
with the mouth and also practice makes
perfect thank you so much Wesley it's
been a pleasure having you
good stuff again there with Nemo and
here's where this match sits everyone
just like the other it's knotted up at
two games a piece but four draws no
victories traded by the players but the
games did get more exciting and you felt
more tension throughout so we're going
to talk about what that tells us heading
into day two but before we do once again
let's take a quick review and remind
everybody of what our picks were in this
match between Nakamura and Wesley so and
Levy you weren't here with us but who
did you have in this one yeah I just
want to preface this by saying that if I
had to choose between Wesley and maybe
anybody else in the field I would likely
go with Wesley so he's just an
incredible chess player you're just
making me have to choose between him and
probably the guy that's playing the best
rapid chess out of anybody in the world
right now so I have to go with Hikaru I
think it's a great take and I'm gonna
emphasize that I probably also would
consider Wesley the favorite at this
point against anyone else in the field
but he's going up against icaro he just
won the fisherman and World Championship
in Reykjavik and I see Naka as the guy
here that's right Naka is the guy I mean
Karu Nakamura is the World Champ right
now for a reason playing some of the
best tests you've ever seen right now
title Tuesday's winning all of them all
the time right it's kind of annoying
bully at school right I like why do you
got to do this right I mean
can somebody else have some fun you know
what I mean right dude I I totally
co-signed your point in Levy's point
about Hikaru just having that proven
track record I think when both players
are at the peak of their forms they're
very evenly matched I mean we saw that
yesterday they went back and forth the
games were super even all things held
equal but again Hikaru was just so
clutch he's clutch in those critical
moments yeah Wesley though he spent a
couple hours last night and this morning
playing Blitz on chess.com he's taking
this super seriously I love it and I
think we're gonna see more like
Incredibly Close high quality games
today Wesley has been non-stop he don't
stop on chess.com right now with blitz
but all right we've talked about our
predictions let's get into the footwork
the X's and O's between these two
heavyweight Fighters what do we see
happening here as the match plays out
and who would you take if it gets all
the way to Armageddon Levy yes it gets
closer to that final Armageddon game
it's definitely going to be in Wesley's
favor because it just get the variance
just skyrockets I think Wesley has one
of two paths to Victory he has to use
what he did in game four yesterday get
that squeeze from the opening and kind
of convert it obviously he was unable to
position was quite complicated or he's
got to go down to that Armageddon and
just hope for the best and hikaru's
gotta win one of these scrambles he
almost won a 130 move end game yesterday
that's the way he's got to do it he's
got to bleed that clock down and he is
just he's just incredible in those
scrambles so that's what I think can't
do you you agree that if we get to
Armageddon so is happier than Hikaru uh
not at all okay 100 disagree but of
course I know I love Levy I even watches
YouTube videos and put a little hearts
in the comments yeah absolutely but at
the same time I highly disagree I love
my guy Hikaru I do know that he's an
extremely strong and at any time format
and then with Wesley here I think he's
just got to be really aggressive right
now especially King's Indian he has
everything in his uh in his repertoire I
think that he needs to get a little bit
risky just a little bit you know just a
little bit of risk and he's probably one
of the best players in the world that
can give you a little bit of risk and
still be good and still be able to
calculate out of the calculation over
everything he's a calculator right yeah
you know human calculator at that ti-80
Nakamura right so we're going to keep it
at that with Naco yeah I'm kind of
ambivalent like on the one hand I agree
that the variance Rises you know if a
team makes it to the fourth quarter
anything can happen on the other hand
let's not forget that Armageddon has no
increment and like Hikaru and no
increment play I mean it's absolutely
terrifying you can get flagged when
you're down to six minutes in an equal
end game so from a purely like objective
perspective I think Hikaru is still the
favorite in an Armageddon but from like
a variance perspective and from Anything
Can Happen perspective yeah Wesley
definitely wants to get this down to
like one final game and I think it might
depend on what game 8 tells us if they
get to Armageddon and maybe we should
ask someone who's been Armageddon before
hey Anish how you doing buddy you
enjoying the show
do you need a hug to break the tie or
you got this
okay
we're gonna hold out Anish says the key
is not to get a hug too early you don't
want to cash in too early count the
chickens and they've had yeah
well Chad told me yesterday if you drew
I wasn't allowed to give you a hug so
they kind of want you to win one on your
own
okay all right all right well Anish
listening in and all right that's gonna
do it for us here we will see you later
chat of course no matter how long it
takes today we're going to be here all
the way to see who punches their tickets
to the cgc championship but to get
things started once again we say hello
to Robert Hess and Fabiano caruana to
call today's action
hi Danny bye Danny but welcome Fabiano
once again to the set this is your
United States chess champion and Fabi we
had a really exciting day won the
semifinals but the players find
themselves neck and neck yeah it's very
close in both of them I would say that
they both have some positive and
negative emotions uh both matches were
very exciting but we see a tie in both
of them we do it is two to two in both
of these matches but Fabi we got there
in different ways so Anish giri nihal
Saran they traded victories in the first
two then two draws Wesley so nicar
Nakamura all knotted up at two with four
draws between them but why don't we
start with the matchup between Anish
giri and nihal sarin that will be the
first game to start today you picked
nihal sarin to win you sticking with
that pick I'm sticking with nihal I
think both players have something to be
happy and unhappy with for Anish it's
he's happy that he saved some lost
positions and that the match is still
taught because it could have gone a lot
worse for him but nihal has some other
things in his favor when he's avoided
anisha's preparation things have gone
his way he's actually been able to
outplay on his is a more experienced
player and traditionally been a stronger
player but once he's getting to those
unusual opening positions he's actually
out playing him which is definitely
something in his favor I think there
might have been some opening day nerves
in the semisphere niche Curry but I'm
sticking with my pick I believe he will
take down nihal starting the chat agrees
with me on this one I know that's
shocking but here we are and Fabi in the
other matchup between Hikaru Nakamura
and Wesley so we can't even really use
the word other that's like a big time
matchup between two heavyweights you
picked Hikaru in that match you stick in
there after what you saw in day one yeah
I think this is a match which could
easily have been a final but we see
these guys duking out in the semi-final
I think that this match is as close to
50 50 as you can get and especially
after we see him the first day was so
balanced I'm still giving Hikaru the
slight nod especially if we see an
Armageddon where his massive experience
in short time controls and those you
know final few seconds that that final
flurry might prove an important factor
okay I mean I understand your pick but
I'm still gonna go with Wesley so I
think he has the psychological Ploy of
just avoiding a car at all costs he's
got his head over you know hand over his
eyes he's not looking at car's way so
he's gonna look to win this match and
head to the finals the chat though they
agree with you five man on Hikaru
Nakamura fan favorite a Content creating
machine and well he's just a boss he won
the fish a random World Championship as
well so as we get ready for our matches
let's remind everyone of the format we
had four games played yesterday but
unlike the previous rounds here in the
cgc Fabiano eight game matches do you
think the players with eight games
played in the quarters now we're at four
games in to the semis maybe some
exhaustion yeah now we're back to normal
business which is these four game
matches where the cost of one loss or
one win is so high they're going to try
to stay a bit cautious but once we get
nerves coming into play we might see
some crazy stuff happen I'm especially
hoping that we'll see an Armageddon
because that's the most exciting thing
that you can see all the chess fans want
that I think we want to see that as well
well these two players maybe one of them
would prefer not to see Armageddon if
that means a match Victory we have nihal
sarin playing from Belgrade Serbia Anish
gear here in Toronto and as we head into
game one or excuse me game five but game
one of today we see the head to head
here Anish gearing 10 years the senior
of nihal sarin you said yesterday Fabi
that the fact that they hadn't really
played before was a knee Hall's favor
now they just had four games yesterday
and now a form would say maybe a niche
has some experience and he can use that
to his Advantage I think that Niha will
actually be happy because we saw in the
first game he ran into his preparation
and now he knows he has to avoid that he
even mentioned that in his interview
that once he he played the Pierce
defense once he gets into those super
weird positions he's he's actually ready
and able to outplay him okay well we are
about to have liftoff here Anish giri
gets the white piece he plays E4 and
Knight C6 I actually thought we would
not get this move but he's avoiding
Theory at all costs and Fabi it
objectively is not the best line for
black it gives white the center the
advantage in the early stages but you
like the choice it sounds like yeah I
think he's gonna get a game I mean it
might be a slightly worse position for
black I mean it almost certainly is a
slightly worse position for black but
it's still playable it's nothing too bad
and also I'm sure that nihal has studied
this with very strong engines so he
knows probably a little bit more about
the position position than Anish who
it's an unusual opening he might have
seen it before but probably not in great
detail but I like the way Anish gear is
playing he put his Bishop on H6 trying
to offer an exchange over here on the G7
square and now with move H4 we see his
intentions let's eventually play the
move H5 open up the H5 with this Rook
sitting here on H1 and that's how you
attack the black king but Fabi I mean
the early stages now nihal is the first
one really spending a little bit of time
here you said he looked in this in more
depth than Anish and yet a niche is
blitzing out his moves yeah Anisha is in
preparation it looks like I mean this
very quick H4 long Castle these are high
responsibility moves so you're not just
going to make them without at least a
little bit of thought or if you're in
preparation which seems to be the case
nihal also playing quickly
um okay so I think that we're very
likely going to see at some point an H5
Pawn sacrifice like this is the idea
this this square is super well covered
by black but you still stack that pawn
and you try to open the H file okay so
why don't we go down that line H5 looks
like a viable option even here there are
three black pieces staring at age five
but it's not easy to take with any piece
the whole point is that let's say you
take with the bishop 185 after Bishop G7
King G7 if that bishop ever moves the
queen goes to H6 you can not allow that
if you are nihal sarin but where to from
here because black does have everything
covered well I think there's two ideas
one is to you have to move the knight
from F3 there's two ways to do it I
think either you move Bishop E2 you move
the Knight you try to dislodge that
Bishop so as you said you get Queen H6
the other one is to First unpin the
Knight with rookie one then you play
Knight D4 or the Knight goes somewhere
and then F3 G4 you in fact just try to
win that Bishop not even dislodge it uh
so this is very dangerous because
although black is a pawn it's not a very
consequential Pawn in this position it's
a Side Pawn but it actually opened up
why it's Rook on H1 for uh what could it
potentially be a devastating attack okay
and Anish gear he you know played step
one with on H4 he has not quite gone for
step two he is calculating here but I
like what you said there that it's an
inconsequential pawn and in fact when
you have fewer pawns you have more open
files and that Rook on H1 that was the
entire point of playing H4 to open this
file against the black king but let's
not take out the equation the white king
it's over here on C1 but the last moves
with C6 and Knight to D7 at some point
cd5 Rook C8 Queen A5 and perhaps the
white king can come under Fire as well
yeah one of the black's typical ideas is
after playing Rook C8 Queen A5 and
opening the C5 with cxd5 is to sacrifice
things change on C3 potentially ruining
White's Pawn structure and also uh
dislodging the knight from C3 in fact
just removing it so you can play Queen
takes A2 so very often white will play
make a preparatory defensive move which
is to play King to B1 and that might
happen at any moment but that shows that
even though white is attacking he might
also have time to play something which
is a bit defensive prophylactic showing
that he's not just thinking about the
attack he's also trying to deal with
Black's threats and Anish Curry does
play the move H5 so he realizes that it
now is the time I believe he was
calculating not because he was out of
preparation or sort of out of the theme
of the position but he was at a specific
prep would you say that's the case yeah
he might be out of specific prep but he
definitely knows something about the
position in terms of ideas so
you might not know every move because
both sides have a plethora of different
options they can you know play Rook CA
first queen A5 first rookie one First
bishop B2 first but if you know the
ideas it'll it'll guide you in the right
direction so that's why he sacks upon he
knows that at some point he should do
this and now we'll see the interesting
moment for me the most natural move is
Bishop to E2 but I'm not sure it's the
correct move because I think it's even
more dangerous for black if white goes
up with the idea of rookie one move the
knight from F3 F3 G4 because that would
just win a piece if white got all that
in so black has to think about how to
either create his own counter play
before that happens or or to somehow
stop it which isn't so easy so I think
nihal will start to
uh try his own play on the on the queen
side with Queen A5 Roxy it as you
mentioned and trying some sort of attack
even sacrificing the bishop 185 at some
moment yeah and maybe there is an
opportunity to take on F3 at some point
I know it looks scary just to allow this
age file to open up because the bishop
is the only thing stopping that Queen
from joining on H6 but that doesn't lead
to Checkmate right away that's the one
bit of good news for black well you're
up a pawn that's the first bit the
second bit is that it's not Checkmate
even if the file opens up so nihal he's
playing quite quickly he's playing risky
chest we just did see the swap on G7 and
now is the big question Bobby this will
determine how the trajectory of this
game goes will we see rookie one Knight
D4 F3 G4 trap that Bishop 185 like you
were indicating before or will he play a
quieter move like Bishop E2 or even King
to B1 I think rookie one is likely it
does feel very natural and if black
takes on F3 that's just too risky white
will make probably make the intermediate
Queen to H6 check King will probably go
back to G8 because AJ feels even a bit
more risky than G8 although maybe it's a
better Square G takes F3 will happen and
you know white has ideas of Bishop to H3
and also E5 and 94 you just sack
everything but you need to dislodge at
knight from F6 because once that Knight
goes H7 goes and that's Checkmate well
look at the game continuation E5 was
anisha's choice so he's starting it
early he is playing this from E5 which
is a very committal choice and I'm
wondering if he has sacrifices on his
mind the Knight on F6 is attached to the
Knight on D7 that may seem unimportant
but if the d-pawn takes an E5 and then
black a White's d-pawn excuse me goes
out the way we have two pieces staring
down the D file at this Knight on D7 and
maybe in conjunction with the Rook takes
H5 or upon G4 there's all sorts of
tactics in the air this is super
interesting so I think first of all
black has a big Choice here Knight takes
E5 or D takes E5 the problem with Knight
takes C5 is that white will take back
probably pontex will happen because I
don't think you can play Bishop takes D1
I don't think you can can take that Rook
because Queen H6 will come and then
Knight E4 will come and that looks very
dangerous that looks like Checkmate in
fact because he as we said before you
dislodge at night it's already it's game
over and in fact they're
yeah that already that just looks dead
lost yeah so maybe D takes E5 is the
better move for black
and I'm wondering if he wants a
deflection sacrifice here D takes C6
first of course you want to open that D
file that was the whole point of E5 and
now after B takes if Rook takes H5 black
can't take with the Knight because the
Knight on D7 is hanging so it's a
deflection black is forcibly GH and
white sacrificed a ton of material but
black structure is extremely compromised
now there's Queen to G5 followed by
Knight takes C5 potentially maybe even
Knight takes E5 first because if you
take back there's Queen G5 check Knight
G6 is forced Rook takes d8 we get some
sort of weird material balance it's it's
almost close to even material black is
up slightly material but it's such an
unusual material balance that it's very
hard to evaluate this position I wonder
if this is what Anish is trying to go
for yes and Niall Stern is thinking
because at this position Black's Pawn
structure all over the place so even
though as you said two Rooks often more
valuable than a queen if pawns are
dropping then the queen is going to pick
them off so this looks like a possible
variation we might in fact see this E5
is a very committed decision by Niche
Geary he's already down one Pawn he's
offering up a second but I think that
tactical sequence that you just pointed
out is very likely to occur because
Knight takes E5 looks way way too risky
for black you know what I think I think
this is preparation
I'm not 100 sure but E5 is a rather
unusual move either he calculated this
whole line and evaluated the ensuing
position with the two Rooks against the
queen and then evaluating that that
position is very tough because it
doesn't look clear-cut like Queen
against two Rooks is such a difficult
material balance it's always it always
is based on like these factors that you
can't fully predict so I'm wondering if
maybe he knows something about this line
or maybe he knows the idea because E5 is
an unusual choice to my mind well this
is preparation then that just goes to
show nihal saran's opening choices
already suspicious because not a main
line it's offbeat not putting your Pawns
in the center and then he played it once
yesterday so I feel like this was a
risky Choice by nihal and Anish I mean
he is a prep wizard as James Canty was
saying earlier you know the prep is in
the pudding this feels like a problem
for niho yeah maybe nihal felt a bit
surrounded in the openings like wherever
he runs to Anish knows what to do and
will be ready with some preparation for
him I wonder if that were the case if
that was the case well we'll leave Neil
All Star intuities I spent a lot of time
here the second matchup the one between
Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so is about
to begin and in that matchup we've seen
the two players choose openings that are
very similar they're head-to-head stats
also knotted up so Bobby what is going
to separate these two you know it might
come down to the wire I wouldn't be
surprised at all if we see a norm again
because they're so evenly matched and
they both seem to be trying to avoid
risk I wonder if they're they just think
that the cost of a mistake is too high
that once they lose a game it'll be very
difficult to come to come back in part
because the openings are so solid that
maybe they think it's very difficult to
find some sort of weakness in the
opening repertoire of the other guy so
they just don't want to lose a game and
that leads to a degree of safety and
Wesley so actually has the lead in
classical chess between these two and
that's what everyone's been saying sort
of like in the quicker time patrols
that's a car Nakamura and he's playing
D4 early so a scotch game from Hikaru
does that surprise you you know I was
going to say I love this choice but then
Hikaru played Knight D2 I was hoping
that he would play 5 and we lead we go
to the craziest positions in chess the
the scotch is so so wild that you know
you play it you you accept that you may
not have any control over the game and
you're just you're just throwing caution
to the wins Knight D2 is a bit more of a
circumspect Choice E5 is okay you're
advancing your Pawn but you're trying to
gain time and that pawn may become a
weakness while Knight D2 okay black
people play D5 will trade Pawns in the
center white has a slightly better
structure black has good development
it's a very level position but we'll see
what hikar has in mind for sure he he
has prepared this and has some sort of
small idea to try to take Wesley out of
book the idea of this whole opening is
Hikaru thinks okay it's not so common
Wesley won't be super familiar with it
right and the issue I guess with it for
me cars we're saying this well that may
be true the choices aren't that
difficult it's not like anything is
under attack in Black's position he's
ready to Castle but a car going for B3
and a fin Kettle Bishop the evaluation
Bar says slight Edge to black but I
don't think that's the important thing
is somebody who's prepared at the
highest level for so many years
sometimes you make an opening choice
that the computer frowns on a little bit
but if your opponent isn't ready for it
that could be the best decision I
suspect that this position is very very
close to equal despite what the computer
claims it's probably more or less
completely completely level and what
Hikari was saying is I'm just ready to
play a game and it's an equal position
but we're making moves mistakes happen
and you know what he might have found
some inspiration in that third game
yesterday where even though he was a
completely level end game he found very
very serious winning chances in that
game and Wesley was under pressure and I
think that Hikaru is a wonderful endgame
player that's one of his main strengths
because the end game calculation plays a
huge role that's where your calculation
abilities shine and Hikaru is a great
calculator so as an endgame player I
think he's very confident very
comfortable and we see here a trade of a
lot of pieces if we see a trade of
Queens we're already talking about an
endgame for sure unless A5 maybe white
will play A4 to stop Blackman but a very
different type of game in this one
compared to the game between Anish giri
and nihal sarin and look at the position
the right side of your screen if it
looks familiar to you it it's because it
is knee All Star has not moved after
Gary pushed that pawn to E5 and you see
him on screen he is staring at this
board because he knows he may be
Checkmate in a few moves if he does not
find the accurate continuation so two
very different games here and Fabi we
started calculating some of these lines
with Pawn takes E5 or Knight takes E5
but the fact that he hasn't moved yet he
understands that if he does not find the
right choice right in this specific
position he will just get blown off the
board yeah here he recognizes and we
already mentioned this that this is a
super critical Choice black has only two
moves that are have any logic to them D
takes E5 or Knight takes C5 but both are
not only difficult to calculate but
difficult to evaluate in the ensuing
position and I'm wondering a bit about
Knight takes C5 maybe we could delve
into that line why we'll play Knight
takes E5 we already showed why Bishop
takes D1 loses the game on the spot so
black is forced to play D takes E5 now
white plays F3 we already showed that
idea of the bishop 185 is trapped but
black and socket C takes d 5 G4 maybe D4
I I don't know what this position is I
mean G takes H5 I don't think works
because just simply D takes C3 and I
don't think there's any attack on the
queen on the king side happening so
white has to move the knights somewhere
that's a tough choice where to go with
the Knight black has a tremendous Pawn
Center two pawns at the moment but
in in fact it's uh three pawns at the
moment can't even count it's so many
pawns but who knows what happens I mean
black has a bunch of Pawns white is
winning a piece both sides are kind of
attacking
very difficult to evaluate well that's
why Neil sarin maybe he couldn't
evaluate that one he goes for D takes E5
and after Pawn takes e66 pawns he's Rook
takes H5 nihal is back on the clock so
he must have seen it a few moves ago
after E5 he knew this was coming but he
hasn't moved yet is he really thinking
about Knight takes H5 on Queen takes D7
that would give white two minor pieces
for the sacrifice Rook that would be
terrible for black I don't even think
it's a material balance but the ensuing
position Black's pawns are dropping so
you might have two pawns at the moment
for uh two pawns up for black but you're
going to lose them and then you're just
going to be down a bunch of material
because a7's weak C6 is weak E7 is weak
E5 is weak everything is a weakness so I
think GTX H5 is simply a forced move so
why I suspect he'll play it so what is
he doing because G takes H5 is obvious
why is he spending time here he's
already has just about half the time
that Anish giri does so what is going on
what's going through his mind well it's
easy for us you know we're we're in the
comfort of our seats or in the comfort
of our homes and we can you know without
any panic we can talk about this
position and discuss if two Rooks are
better or queen is better I mean he
actually has to take these very
responsible decisions he understands
that g takes H5 it could be okay it
could also be losing you have to go
through all these calculations so he's
just making sure that he's not losing on
the spot after gh5 we mentioned Knight
takes E5 leads to that position of two
works against queen I'm wondering about
Queen G5 immediately as well G takes H5
Queen G5
King h8 only move Knight takes E5 now
black can't take on E5 of course because
then you drop the knight uh after white
takes a queen black I think has to play
Queen C7
Knight takes D7 Knight takes D7
and I think black is okay it's kind of
scary there's Queen takes E7 like
there's a lot of stuff you still have to
calculate but maybe once you see this
queen F4 intermediate check you start to
feel like okay I broke the pin and
suddenly I'm happy I'm up a lot of
material so this is the kind of stuff
that is probably going through nihal's
mind right now it's a really important
variation here because even this isn't
so clear Black's pawns are terrible
Black's hitting not completely safe but
the extra material should be good if
this were to happen so instead he has
not moved yet after Rook takes H5 he
does in fact play G takes and for a
niche Knight takes E5 he's playing
instantly and yeah this is at this point
this much has been calculated but I'm
starting to agree with you more and more
that Anish had this prepared like he was
remembering the exact sequences of
preparation but he likely had this
position on his computer at some point
it's possible he knew it I I would say
that's likely although he did spend a
bit of time so maybe he was trying to
recall or maybe he's just super
confident today maybe he's in the form
of his life and all these calculations
and all this decision making just comes
in very naturally sometimes you get in
what we call that state of flow right
and Sports we usually refer to that when
a player or an athlete just everything
comes naturally you don't have to you
don't dwell on your decisions you don't
second guess yourself maybe that's what
he's feeling right now and queen C5
attacking a lot of Pawns but Rook D6
does defend them
defense C6 covers E7 if that Knight on
G6 ever wherever to move I like B3
I like this move it looks like what are
you doing I mean you should be doing
something more concrete but King safety
is important King B2 King is super
secure in that spot yeah it is the pawns
are moving because he probably feels
that he can pick off those pawns at some
point so he might as well throw his a
pawn up the board that might become a
passer and a new Queen and what I like
the most about what a niche is doing is
the clock he is putting pressure on
Nielsen on the board as you said there
were a couple situations there where if
Neil didn't find the accurate response
he might have just lost and now he's
here with an unclear position the
evaluation bar is saying slightly
preferable for white neither player
knows that but I'm guessing the niche in
this position with that active Queen he
feels like he has the better chances
well you say no player knows that maybe
Anish does that it is possible that he
knows he is somewhat better here but if
you had no knowledge about this position
beforehand you would think this is just
a mess I have no idea what's going on
because black isn't material on the
other hand black can't easily move
pieces like that Rook on A8 you'd love
to get that into a game but then you
drop A7 and once you drop A7 that a pawn
is just a monster it just rolls down the
board and it the knights move like
tonight on G6 then suddenly there's
Queen G5 in the equation then I don't
have six has nowhere to go because it's
restricted by Knight on C3 so black is a
bit stuck while white has very natural
improving moves King to B2 A5 A6 I think
King B2 next move very likely I mean
Bishop C4 is also a very logical option
but King B2 it's like a no-brainer you
make that move because you stop rookie
one check and you ask black okay you
played rookie six what's next like
what's your improving move I'm gonna
play A5 Bishop a six Bishop B7 ideas and
and what are you going to do to stop me
you just name like 12 different ideas
for white and I don't see one for black
so hear me out for a second can black at
some point say I might just lose this
game if I don't start going after
White's pawns on the Kings I don't think
you get there in time especially because
from C6 the queen defends G2 but I'm out
of idea so there are two options for
black either you just throw away your
pawns and get activity or you sit and
defend passively and nihal plays A5
keeping the pawn defended which of those
two options you think niho in time
trouble is going to go for I like to
move A5
because the you just didn't want to make
sure that White's Pawn would get to A6
because once it's there if you ever drop
A7 that is a pass Pawn that is ready to
promote
oh yeah and here we see with the
opponent A5 over here like this I mean
it's stuck the pawns are stuck here I
think the one problematic piece Bobby is
this Knight on C3 it's not as good as it
can be I see the score F5 so is there an
opportunity to reroute this Knight and
just Venture up toward the black king I
think that's definitely an option the
Knight on F5 is super scary for black
because it's it's attacking the black
king also attacking E7 attacking H4 a
lot of potential threats there but I
wonder if Knight D1 would also
potentially allow 94 because you're also
allowing Black's Knight access but then
maybe there's Queen D4 check and the 94
doesn't do very much in particular
so 91 is definitely an option the other
movie which comes to mind to me is
Bishop C4 but then I think black has a
nice little idea
okay let me hear it actually I think
black is just forced to go Rook D6
scratch that what was your idea I just
want to show how even the uh C1 that
black would have rookie one check King
b295. ah which is like controlling
everything but it's not checked now so
that's why he played King to B2 and now
Queen C6 would just win a pawn makes
sense so Bishop C4 is very tempting but
maybe your idea of Knight D1 because
also the Knight on E3 maybe not F5 but
also C4 is an idea oh let's go after the
queen that a pawn is such a big weakness
and once you win that pawn it's it's a
desperate situation for black for sure I
just don't see plans for black and you
are correct of course that the Knight on
C3 limits the Knight on F6 but even if
that Knight got to E4 as you point out
you can just slide your queen back give
a check improve your own pieces bring
this Bishop from F1 so Niche I think
he's doing the right thing here he is
spending his time he is calculating is
there a way to win a pawn if not how do
I improve my pieces and meanwhile in the
other game between Wesley so and ikaru
Nakamura I mean those two players have a
very different type of position where
they are slowly improving their pieces
so equal material in the game between
Hikaru and Wesley but I like Wesley's
position once again with the black
pieces I feel like Wesley is not facing
much difficulties I feel like it's
slightly easier for Hikaru to play this
because he always has he has a bit more
pressure on Black's position the pawn D5
is a bit of a loose pawn and white
always has the option of Bishop takes F6
it would remove a defender of the pawn
D5 and then maybe that pawn would fall
off on the other hand black might at
some point play C4 doesn't probably
doesn't work so well now play C4 and
just liquidate all the pawns bc4 and if
black were able to play DC4 A4 Falls and
you just liquidated everything the
problem is of course if C4 now bc4 DC4
there's Queen takes D7 Knight D7 rookie
7.
so after bc4 maybe black can play Rook
takes A4 it might equalize maybe Queen
takes A4 because you attack that Rook on
D1 so this is definitely an option yeah
and it's just one of these decisions you
don't play too quickly and Wesley does
not I think he's one of the best players
in the world at this a lot of us we say
okay let me just trade everything off
but you miscalculate one little thing
and then suddenly a car gets the
advantage and that's how he wins
positions like this instead Wesley just
brings his Queen to B7 now c4 is not
just available it's strong because the
bishop B2 is loose so he's creating
threats of his own he's protecting
everything in his position and when I
said Wesley has nothing to fear with the
black pieces I mean I feel like he's
just equal here he at the opening wasn't
scary for him he handled it perfectly it
looks like the only thing that could
have gone wrong was he's a bit lower in
time but the position is still very
stable that maybe that time Factor isn't
even isn't even such a big one here like
you have to stop C4 now and there's a
few ways you can try to do it one is
Queen to F3 okay
that stops C4 in its tracks because of
Knight takes C4 right not Pawn takes
because then you might drop the bishop
on B2 but Knight takes C4 and black
can't do this because of the uh the
little discovered attack on the queen
there
but Queen F3 it also doesn't contain a
threat so this move it's a prophylactic
move but does it actually do anything
it's not clear the other option is white
can grab just grab F6 right now Bishop
takes F6 Bishop F6 and Knight to F3
but then I don't know if C4 just
equalizing on the spot
yeah just trade everything off but I
actually don't think it does in this
case because bc4 DC4 Queen C4
oh oh actually there was a Checkmate
even better than Queen's 4 Queen to d8
you nasty nasty man the 48.
take take and Rook to E8 finally and
that's Checkmate I don't think I can sit
next to you anymore that would be a
nasty way to lose the game but Wesley
will of course not fall for that hey you
say of course but crazier things have
happened here in the cgc but no that's
important thing to point out that
Black's King and whites as well does not
have love does not have an escape Square
so if you can get rid of The Rook on the
first or last rank then there could be a
Checkmate so that's a very direct
sequence that easy to blunder if you're
not really calculating and as a player
they dive into all the details so Bishop
F6 is definitely possible I think black
at some point play Rook B6 just to put
more pressure here C4 at some point will
be Wesley's plan but he should not rush
it I think that's what we've proven that
Wesley has this idea but he can't
execute it right away well he's a very
good concrete player he calculates very
well so if something like Bishop takes
up six and Knight F3 happens he'll
probably just calculate something very
concrete Rook to B6 maybe Rook to E6
something which if you take D5 I take B3
and we simplify into a drawn position
that's very likely to happen that's what
hikar was trying to avoid because of
course
the white pieces are a small advantage
and you want to try to make the most of
it so he doesn't want to Simply let this
go into a draw without any fight it's
not a tragedy of course if that happens
for ikaru but it's still something you'd
rather avoid you'd rather put some
pressure especially with the time
Advantage but that keeps dwindling as
well yeah no it feels like a car wants
to play on but he's not seeing anything
that leads to even an interesting choice
right that's what you want to do is give
your opponent difficult options and they
hopefully if you're playing for win pick
the wrong one but Wesley time and time
again he proves to be just too solid his
opening repertoire is similar descar's
it's probably uncomfortable for both
players and I'm not seeing anything here
to speak of so I think we can leave
these two players the car sits in a deep
think we will pull up the game between
Anish giri and nihal sarin once more
because that one has a totally different
dynamic as a niche has a queen Neil has
those Rooks and very importantly is the
coordination of White's pieces is their
Fabi and for Neil with black that Rook
on A8 it's stuck being passive depend
ending A5 well what nihal is doing now
is basically I don't see an idea so I'm
just going to make moves that don't
spoil my position H6 it doesn't really
do much maybe the idea is to play Knight
F4 and not allow Queen G5 that's the
only thing I can think of but more so
just I don't know what to do and I I
love you oh okay so he stops Knight F4
but I was gonna say I loved your idea of
Knight D1 E3 and potentially Knight to
F5 that looks so scary but I also
understand Knight to E2 it's so natural
because not only do you stop Knight F4
but you prepare Knight to D4 this looks
so good for a niche I don't see moves
that's the biggest problem is even when
I see a single move for black there are
no ideas your whole idea is stopping
White's plans but there are too many
because Bishop C4 can hit you at any
moment here Knight D4 already hits The
Rook hits the pawn hits Knight F5 check
as an available choice so I'm just not
seeing anything here for nihal and I
feel like with one minute and 13 seconds
counting down it feels almost hopeless
it's a desperate situation but it's not
hopeless and we know that nihal is a
player who's great in bad positions and
other time pressure which is exactly
what he has now and I like to move 95.
one point is Bishop 5 looks like it's
winning material because if you move
that Rook you lose the Knight but Knight
E to D7 drops back attacks the queen and
also attacks the Knight only two so I
can still play Queen C4 but then you're
starting to go back so this wouldn't be
in anisha's favor that's what's
happening oh that's what ice is going
for yes his Queen is going on a journey
from C5 C4 to D3 but good calculation by
you and great calculation by nihal
because he found that instantly I feel
like Anish might have let part of the
advantage slip it looked a lot more
dangerous black it looked like black
might even just lose tactically at some
point but now I feel like black is out
of tactical danger still pawns are weak
your pieces are a bit disconnected The
Rook again we mentioned that before it's
just out of Play It has to be because it
had to defend that upon A5 for so long
but you're playing without one of your
most important pieces
still it's better for black than it was
a few moves before and we see mihal he's
low on time bad position it doesn't
matter so much because he still finds
those defensive resources I think a big
idea for like a C5 C4 you need to create
some threat against the white position
you mentioned earlier the King on B2
shielded nicely he brings his Knight to
D5 maybe over to B4 but I'm already
looking at Knight D4 hitting C6 again
trying to go to F5 with check hitting
all the Pawns in Black's position so I
mean Neil's fighting he's really doing a
good job but after Knight takes c65 he's
going Knight to B4 trying to trade off
those Knights this is a remarkable idea
because I thought his idea was an id4
Knight to B4 both attacking the queen
and defending C6 simply giving that pawn
up and I don't really see like why
you're giving it up except you just
didn't think you could uh save that pawn
so you're just making moves at this
point just trying to survive but I mean
something went wrong like I don't know
about this whole Knight D5 E6 just
sacking the pawn for nothing idea no it
looks like uh it needs to be very happy
Queen default great centralization
pinning the 9 out of six it also
threatens upon H4 it looks like finally
at long last Anish gear is picking off
the pawns now knee-haw down to 40
seconds Fabi he's not even seeing moves
that's the biggest problem he can play
Rook A6 a one move threat attacks
tonight the Knight just jumps away to
the square like E5 or you play Queen C4
while attacking and defending one moves
at a time for knee hill that's not a
plan and now he's down on 25 seconds the
problem for black is white has no
weaknesses none black might be fun on
material but what do you attack I mean
G2 is kind of this tiniest bit of
weakness because it has to be defended
by a piece which is very passive and
that's probably the only thing that's
keeping black alive now that the bismon
H3 is sort of stuck there but besides
that there are no weaknesses no targets
while black A5 is a target H4 is a
target the king is weak it doesn't have
pawns around it as much as the white
king does which has like that perfect
Phalanx of Pawns that you that you love
to see when when you're you know playing
a game because you know you're secure
you have that King safety and things are
just going wrong he's gonna lose that A5
Pawn very very soon he's also just gonna
lose piece here because C4 hits the
Knight on D5 The Rook on B6 is loose and
have rooked before there's Knight D3 and
you're now your rook's under attack and
kicked out from the place where pins I
think that this is game over right here
and nihal sarin is about to lose more
material yeah this is over there's no
way to say that piece and no matter how
good of a Defender you are you can't
save this Knight Knight to D3
is I don't know his Knight to C6 also an
option
there looks like there looks like a few
ways to dislodge that rook and win
either an exchange or a knight or some
sort of material but what I love about
Anish giri is he's spending time right
here Neil has 5.9 seconds but he knows
the position is winning for white if he
plays it accurately so why win on the
clock when you can win on the board and
maybe there's something even more
precise but Knight D3 should do the
trick this Knight can go to C6 as you
point I can go to F3 it attacks Rooks
from both sides of the board H4 is loose
he knows his position is good and he
does play Knight C6 knee-haw down to
four seconds three seconds two seconds
we'll even get a move off at this point
he does he plays E5 Fabi but I believe
the queen just runs away and then two
pieces are under attack that should be
that yeah now black is losing any rook
and dropping all his pawns this is
pretty much game over unless some sort
of tragic mistake happens but I don't
even think he'll want to take that Rook
on B4 he might just want to go for the
Checkmate I see Knight to d8 here and
there's no way to defend F7 and you
don't even care about the Rook you don't
care about the king side the queen side
just upon an F7 because it leads either
to Checkmate the Knight on F6 falling
some sort of massive attack and again
black has no counter play for it whites
King has never been in danger this
entire game I love you calling out my
tunnel vision there I'm just I see
material I take material but Knight d8
just ends the game on the spot you
cannot protect F7 then your king is in
oh he plays it what a move and what a
spot by You Queen takes F7 check should
be lights out Knight takes F7 actually
is great as well hitting the Rook
setting up discover check against this
King and Neal with 3.1 seconds left this
is just as long as you don't blunder a
queen you have this game in the bag
there's you're spoiled for Choice white
every move that white plays which
doesn't blunder things wins now he's
taking all the material this is it I
mean
he's taking G5 followed by A5 and black
has nothing to show for the material
loss and apparently that there was a
checkmate at 10 I don't really fault a
niche for not finding it but Queen takes
A5 how many extra pawns does a player
need his three of them in Knight E4
Queen takes before is not a free rook
there's Knight D3 check maybe that's
good enough but you know he doesn't want
to get material I think you can go for
that but why I mean you can play Queen
to d8 check probably followed by a
Checkmate King to A3 just got the king
out of potential checks as well
yeah this doesn't look like there's much
hope especially since Ani still has an
abundance of time on his clock well
Anisha just playing with Precision every
single move Queen D7 check might just
pick up this and then E4 because if the
King goes to f8 or F6 Queen F5 is check
and where else is your king going to G8
I don't think so instead he Sprints the
pawn towards the other side one second
left for Neil sarin will he even get the
next couple moves off he does we know
he's a bullet beast at least he's not
running out of time but that's the only
thing that you can say in his favor in
this game he is actually starting to
create some threats with 92 but they
don't lead to a Checkmate two nights
alone won't Checkmate the lone King so
he can play A7 here Knight each Knight
to E2 check is met by King to D2 the
king can escape via those dark squares
that can just like slide across the
knights or controlling some squares but
not quite enough and yeah this is uh
this is game over this was a perfect
game by Anish this was a beautiful
Victory and it goes to show that maybe
you shouldn't deviate as early as move
one because when you play an opening
like one Knight C6 you get yourself in
trouble from the very start and for now
now Anish giri takes the lead once more
you see game one you see game five he is
an early riser he wins the first game of
the day and Nielsen has proven he can
come back what does he need to do
differently I think this game is even
more important than the first game of
the first day for them because now we're
getting closer to the Finish Line the
weight of these victories matters even
more and yeah Niha will have to strike
back immediately I don't think that he
can afford a draw with white in any of
these games and he's just hoping to get
to an Armageddon now
and nihil did play a perfect game too
yesterday but the game that's going on
right now is Wesley so and akara
Nakamura and if we're being frank not
much of an interesting game right now we
have three pawns per side two uh Rooks
each a minor piece and both sides are
gonna have a piece on the first rank so
I would actually say and I don't know if
you agree with me on this that white
should be a little bit better here just
because the coordination but as Wesley
is ready to bring his King up to G7 and
Rook to F7 his pieces are nice and tight
and there really is no way to make
inroads well you know Knights are tricky
pieces so you never know but between
players of this caliber yeah this is a
draw as long as he doesn't blood or
night Fork like Rook to F7 will happen
and then Knight to F4 but you don't
blunder Knight E6 you play like say Rook
to A6 something like that
you're not going to lose this game and
this is going to be a draw and it's the
same sort of game that we've seen the
past few days
uh the the past few games yeah not the
past few days sorry uh where it's
relatively evenly matched and neither
side was able to get very much in this
match we've seen very few chances by
either player Hikaru got small chance
game three game four Wesley got some
chances but it was never very close to a
victory by any of these players so far
yeah and you have experience playing at
the highest level in a world
championship match where 12 games were
drawn some of them were just solid and
maybe not the most interesting others
were back and forth Affairs so what does
Wesley with the yps and next game what
does he need to do because right now he
just needs to hold what does he need to
do in game six to make Hikaru
uncomfortable well it depends what his
match strategy is if he if he's happy to
go to an Armageddon or keep it very
close and make it a nerves game keep it
until the last tight until the last
seconds then he can keep doing what he's
doing which is plain solid quiet
positions if he thinks that I want to to
you know get a lead in this match right
away then he's gonna have to take some
serious chances and I suspect he's going
to have to make a different first move
than one E4 because they keep going for
one E4 but why are they testing them in
other openings I mean if I were Wesley I
would think maybe the catalog would be a
good choice well E4 Best Buy test so it
is said and unfortunately in this match
neither player could get separation
you're right though maybe they need to
choose different openings and you kind
of asked a rhetorical question but I'll
dive into it uh Wesley so does he feel
comfortable going Armageddon does he
think he can just make all these draws
play Armageddon you think he believes
that's his best chance or will he need
to take a risk with two whites in the
remaining three games I think he's ready
for Armageddon but I don't know if
that's what he wants uh the thing about
Armageddon is it's very between players
of this strength it's it's just a 50 50
game by the way he actually sacrificed a
pawn here I just noticed
version from the Armageddon question but
no but this is important because Rook
takes D6 is check and it removes the
guard of the Rook on C7 so that leads to
an extra Pawn but Fabi that's a
theoretical draw three against two yeah
that's that's a draw but hikar will go
for it and try to press a little bit you
know you have that I guess that small
moral Edge like I was the one pressing
this game I'm a pawn up in the end game
does that matter at all
not too much but it's it's a nice
feeling I I can't lose this and I can
press you a little bit I'm just
wondering I meant that question
sincerely because uh sometimes you need
to win those little battles even if the
game ends in a draw Justice make
yourself feel more confident because
Hikaru is burning one of his white
pieces games so he's gonna have black
in-game six he's a white game seven
black game eight so that should be a
slight Advantage for Wesley when you
think that there's a first move
Advantage but these two players just
cannot separate from one another in fact
I feel like the player with the black
pieces has often had the slightly better
chances in this match yeah that shows us
the strength in their black repertoires
repertoires and their inability to find
good ideas against the Berlin which is
not a fault of theirs it simply shows
how good the Berlin is I mean nobody has
ideas against the Berlin but they keep
trying in this game it was a sort of
offbeat scotch that he tried but to
elaborate on your Armageddon question I
think this is a good game for Wesley
he's very happy about this the first
game of the of the new day it's a bit
nervy and you're thinking well my
opponent has my a full night to prepare
and maybe he's coming up with something
very dangerous like we saw Anish with
with the god tier preparation today but
Wesley's happy he made a solid draw and
so maybe he's he's going to try to avoid
that armaged and try to get some chances
in his uh in the next game and and his
remaining white game after that I'm just
happy that you've been influenced by you
know social media culture me with a god
tier reference who am I sitting next to
Fabi but in this position the key for
black is keeping this king off the
fourth rank because if that King can go
up the board and go after this lone Pawn
then there will be some chances for
white so the reason why Fabi and I are
you know saying this one for sure is
going to be a drug because Wesley too
strong and has too much time if he had
maybe eight seconds remaining he
probably still would hold it but that
would be a bit dicey we'll just show how
black can lose us for example King to E3
and you don't play Rook to A4 but you
play Rook to A5
yeah at any moment after King death four
this is starting to get very dangerous
because if you allow King to G5 that's
already it right that's game over
because you're getting Rook F6 Rook F5
winning a pawn and two pawns will in a
rook end game will win for sure and
that's why Wesley he chased The Rook
around put his rook in the fourth rank
but Hikaru making a bit of progress here
if that King goes up to F4 that's going
to be scary but look at Wesley puts his
Rook on A6 that way king of four is
meant by King F6 and the white king
can't get in and the white Rook as soon
as it leaves the fourth rank the black
Rook would check the King off of f4
that's really important stuff and
Wesley's showing great defensive
instincts yeah with these guys you're
not going to trick them in these types
of end games they've seen this before
there are some rook and two against rook
and one and games which are a bit tricky
for example if Black's F Pawn removed to
the E file for example the E6 that's a
tricky one because then white has a past
pawn and I've seen people strong Grand
Masters lose that In classical games for
example the game uh sorry to call out
Mickey Adams on this one but Mickey
Adams against Yanni palmyashi 2017
London chess classic
Nepali actually won that with the pawn
up two against one you rarely see uh
Grandmasters win those end games but
sometimes they're very tricky how dare
you call Mickey M's the nicest person in
the Chess World yeah the great chess
player yeah of course and here we are
talking about one of his defeats rather
than one of his many many wins but right
now it's just nothing happening a car
would love to get his King up to G5 but
as soon as the King goes to H3 Rook h8
check the pawn on F5 keeps the king uh
out of G4 and will push it back so the
King goes to F7 I think some people
would want to bring the king forward for
black but he moved the king forward
you're actually walking away from your
Pawn now the question is is he car
trying to get back to 15 minutes
and will he still made Wesley in this
game he might try because
I know hikara likes to still meet his
opponents it's like a small moral
Victory but it's not easy to still mate
here I mean you'll have to trade Rooks
trade pawns and and uh go to a King and
pawn ending
or we might just see a draw maybe they
want to preserve their their energy for
the remaining games all right be honest
if we were playing this game and I had
the black pieces and would you offer me
a draw you'd make me suffer
I want to say I'd make you suffer but
I'd probably just offer a draw oh my
gosh I'm making myself suffer too I
don't want to play this position it's
boring well look at hikara's face here
he's uh you know he doesn't seem
thrilled he wants to get a victory I
mean he is fueled by positions with
calculation with tactics he's not
getting them Wesley so has just been way
too solid and now we're in this end game
where there's an extra Pawn but
unfortunately and this is why it's not
going to be a win for a cargo because
you're often taught when ahead material
trade down the black king will stay in
front of the pawn and King and pawn
versus King if the king is blocking the
pawn that is a known draw and the only
way you can create a pass Pawn is by
trading on G4 and look at Hikaru we
might see exactly this if you take on F5
Rook A5 check so I think we are going to
see exactly this and take on F5 and they
will show you how King and pawn versus
King in this position is a draw so we
will see a stalemate Hikaru is going all
the way
and yeah if black doesn't know that you
play King f8 you lose the game after
after King D5 but of course
all strong players know this and we see
still made in a draw and akaro took off
his headset before the game concluded
because both players knew it was a drama
Wesley so yeah a little smile on his
face he is still tied with Hikaru
Nakamura and look at this Fabi Half
Point Half Point Half Point Half Point
Half Point they are drawing every single
game we could have sort of predicted
this these guys are so evenly matched
they're so strong and so hard to beat
and even though they're trying and
sometimes gain some small chances
overall very difficult to find a weak
spot in their repertoire they're they're
feeling each other at out but yeah it's
it's tough and if I were in their
position I'd also feel like how do I
break down this opening repertoire the
Berlin is just so good I think at some
point we'll have to see them play
something besides E4 they will because
the other match we've seen that from the
players offbeat openings in the one
between a niche giri and nihal sarin so
we see the scores for both matches now
Anish Geary gets that big win in the
fifth game and Bobby I mean as we look
here nihal sarin he's the one I was on
the clock he needs to find something I
just feel like is it today or is it
yesterday because we're seeing exact
repeat of yesterday's first round
and just a perfect game by Anish and a
solid drop between Hikaru and between
Wesley and Niha will have to strike back
maybe he'll do a repeat of the second
game yesterday but it's it the onus is
on him now the owner certainly is on him
and his preparation while it's quite
good he has his repertoire that set he
needs to find something like what Anish
giri did in this game because what a
marvelous display of preparation and
then even stronger technique perhaps but
in this moment Fabi when the move H4 was
played you were saying this has to be
preparation it felt like it he was
taking some time so I was questioning it
but E5 played so quickly that was either
incredibly impressive calculation and
evaluation skills or it was preparation
I suspect he knew something about the
position I mean trading off Bishops in
E5 here this is another Pawn sacrifice
the whole point is that the First Pawn
of sacrifice opened up the H file for an
eventual Queen H6 and with E5 we were
talking about during the game Knight
takes E5 you may think you're piling up
pressure on a pin piece but no it's not
an absolute pin the night can still go
if you take you lose the game very
quickly with the Knight coming into E4
distracting the knight from F6 so
instead the pawn capture on E5 and Fabi
we got this forcing sequence Rook takes
H5 Knight takes E5 looks like a free
Knight but not all pieces are free and
once we got here it felt like anisha's
built up the pressure and never relented
yeah not only everything was impressive
about this game the opening stage from
Anish the way that he kept the pressure
on the clock making moves that were
useful but also didn't take a huge
amount of calculation like B3 King B2 A4
just building on the pressure very
impressive practical skills and once he
got a winning position converted
flawlessly he did he brought his Bishop
around to the H3 Square eventually it
looked weird but it protected the only
possible weak point Knight D4 threatened
Knight F5 and Knight takes C6 and with
that double attack E6 stops one of them
but down goes the pawn and Fabi from
here it was pretty simple but I loved
this moment too because after Queen A7
Knight F4 I would have grabbed this rook
and try to win the game here but he
still was was calculating and digging
into the position well certainly Knight
takes before would have been a good
would move and most likely winning in
the long run as well but when you see a
good move look for a better one and
Knight to d8 is just clinically
finishing the game off there's no hope
after that and that's the most
depressing thing when your opponent
makes a move that leaves you with no
hope yeah well in this one all pawns for
white no hope for black a win for Anish
giri but that settles round five here at
the chess.com Global championship and
with that we are going to send it back
to Danny and the Fellas
indeed thank you Robert quite the
clinical performance opening prep and
then the put away by Anish giri but
we're here to say hello again and break
things down from the chairs we have of
course International Master Levy Rosman
Gotham chess Danny wrench right here
feeding Master James Canty and Grand
Master Daniel noraditski on the end so
let's dive in fellas we also need to
check in with the scores remind
everybody of where we sit it is now a
three games to two lead for Anish Geary
we predicted it we said with a knight
and some prep would a niece show his
experience indeed he did but Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley so nobody is
blinking no one wants to budge an inch
guys they are deadlocked at two and a
half games apiece what can we say about
this matchup right now guys Levy let's
start with you right are these guys just
going to agree to play the Berlin till
we get to Armageddon or is somebody
going to switch things up yeah the most
fascinating thing to me here is the lack
of urgency it seems and to quote the
great Max Kellerman and what he said you
need one game all right the aliens got
the death being pointed at the chest
world you need one guy to take one game
to win it I got Nakamura in the
Armageddon yeah give me Eagle without
give me nothing more I guess that
there's really no urgency because he
thinks whatever happens is gonna go down
to Armageddon and I'm the favorite well
apparently he wants to prove candy right
candy said he would be the favorite
number again regardless of how Wesley
feels you're sticking with it I'm
sticking with it I mean of course every
game has been a draw here every game I'm
like what is it all right we can go to
sleep for like 15 minutes right because
it's been like that but it's a it's been
a grind every single game here as uh the
time gets faster though when the
Armageddon comes up I'm gonna take
Hikaru there also I think he should take
this is just a little bit of it yeah
just a little bit right because it's
been uh no risk taking it all in these
games really I honestly can't wait to
see like who whether we'll see either
player take a risk will we see a
sicilian because let's be clear the
opening repertoire of both of these
players is that I mean it's not that
they're not capable of playing a
different opening it's just that both of
them are by far more comfortable playing
e45 than any other opening and both of
them feel that the other player is
incredibly good at punishing dubious
lines and punishing a wrist so I don't
think we'll see the knee-haul opening
played by Hikaru or Wesley and you know
I just think both of them are like okay
I'm fine with their arm again let's
let's let the Armageddon decide but you
kept talking about a different opening
and I want to bring the audience into a
conversation that we keep having out
there in the room where we're all
gathered as fans and watching on on the
monitor we're all talking about will
Hikaru go to his vintage Knight F3 B3
these systems he knows so well you know
he can beat the best players in the
world in it so Donya let's go back
around this way why isn't Hikaru mixing
it up a little bit well that kind of
Beats me I mean I predicted that opening
I think think before game two or game
four I forget and I was pretty confident
that Hikaru would play Knight F3 I think
the only rational explanation is that he
just fears deep preparation by Wesley
because the Knight of three B3 stuff
it's really really good if black isn't
prepared but black has several paths to
complete equality and you know I just
think Hikaru fears that he might even
get a slightly worse position out of
that opening but I I am surprised I I
really was confident that we'll see uh
Knight F3 but by he carves a good way to
mitigate the risk but get a playable
position yeah he's got he's got a
opportunity right to play Knight F3 E3
B3 whatever it's going to be honestly I
just think he has some respect for
Wesley's opening repertoire that's
really what it is and he's like if I
gotta go down and play a white game in
an Armageddon maybe that's when I busted
out because he's gonna have no increment
and he's gonna have to completely fend
on his own he doesn't have that plus two
but yeah it's really a mystery anytime
these guys play it's totally it just
blows your mind like isn't one of them
bored
is it respect for Wesley I think that's
a great point or is Naka saving 903 B3
if they get to Armageddon that's an
interesting twist that this whole
conversation made me think of it all
right speaking of whether it is just
respect for Wesley Canty you spent some
time with the man you caught up with him
uh earlier this week I did that's right
Wesley and I got to hang out a little
bit and he may have told me a secret or
two
we have a big Wesley aka Big flexley
here look at him all right man I got
some questions for you so I've always
wanted to ask you we fresh offered a
Fisher random how do we Castle Dewey
Castle can we Castle in check or or not
what's going on
yeah that's uh
I guess depends on what room but if you
look at the feeding and I got to feed
the handbook they say your king can't
move if it's uh attacked okay right okay
I just wanted to be sure I've actually
done that myself you know board chest
there so a little joke there from the
Fisher random favorite openings and why
I guess this E4 E5 Queen H5 stuff okay
all right I don't give the secrets away
again Wesley go away come on pre-game
rituals do they send the music okay
genre do you usually like oldies okay
all these nice yeah how old 50s 60s yeah
like seven days wow
the carpenter okay I'm not familiar you
probably are BG's okay the BG fifth
grade yeah they're definitely yeah I
also like uh Eminem I think okay
yeah of course yeah I'm from Detroit
right yeah yeah I definitely love The
Lumineers we appreciate you on that
thank you of course congratulations on
all your success and good luck in the
tournament
foreign
[Music]
that was incredible we went from
Carpenters to Bee Gees to Eminem in the
middle we lost ourselves you know we
need to just also just vibing dude is
one of the kindest coolest customers in
the Chess World and uh your thoughts on
his taste in music Levy
uh eclectic to borrow a word for my
esteemed colleague I don't know if it
passes your bar though it most certainly
does eclectic eclectic musical taste
Danny no I'm just Florida at Levy's
choice of word there but I I mean
Wesley's just such a nice guy I had the
honor of sitting next to him at our uh
pre-tournament group dinner and and he's
so genuine you know he's not just
smiling because he has to he just loves
life he laughs a lot
um he's got a great sense of humor and I
love talking chess with him so big
Wesley fan for sure Kitty should I be
calling you out that you didn't know the
Carpenters though you know what hey man
um I am born in 2000. you know no I'm
old so I I knew the Carpenters but okay
when he said E4 E5 Queen H5 were you
surprised about that was pretty fun I
was actually surprised and I was like
aha that's why you know what I need to
do that right so my next Norm tournament
I'm going to play e45 Queen H5 and then
look at him real hard U.S Masters in
Charlotte I hope you see you play it I'm
gonna hold you to it all right okay hold
up oh geez of the American Swiss Circle
remember that Hikaru used to play E4 E5
Queen H5 again to win the World open
okay back in the day but all right
before we take a break a quick reminder
again from our sponsor Brave means
private Brown housing you know it it
means so much more by default Brave
blocks ads and trackers on every page
and videos you visit even on YouTube no
ads means up to three times faster page
loads faster streaming and faster
playback it also means 35 percent longer
battery life while saving on mobile data
and internet bandwidth it's for Android
iOS and desktop get the best browser for
gamers streamers and creators switch in
60 seconds all you got to do go to
brave.com chess all right well much more
to come from day two of the cgc
semifinals game five is in the books
game six right around the corner
twitch subscribers we have plenty of
exclusive content don't go anywhere
throw us that Prime right now and we
will see you during the break don't miss
it
[Music]
foreign
do you get recognized on the street if I
come to Manhattan and walk around for an
hour I'll probably get recognized yeah
it's pretty crazy okay well we're gonna
we're gonna find that out right now hi
sir uh for a dollar do you know who this
is I don't know I'm gonna get some
musician okay okay pretty good yes he is
an artist okay he's an artist who plays
a game what game would he play the game
of Kings
nope don't know it okay hi sir do you
know who this is for a dollar negative
negative okay cool good talk though
you know who I am for a dog oh my god
dude this is yeah of course love it okay
dude what I think two dollars serious
yeah hey do you know who this is for a
dollar yes who is it dude that's Levy
yeah totally Rosman that's right there
you go for ten dollars you know who I am
okay
I am the chess.com guy but do you know
who this is
a dollar for knowing who I was for a
dollar do you know who this is
Jake
dude it's Jake no it's close though keep
guessing Tommy actor actor all right
okay yeah yeah what type of acting
um comedy comedy okay yep really yeah
not really but I was like magician oh
yeah that's the third magician we've got
so thank you this is great it's the
shirt it's the shirt right it's got to
be the shirt okay hi for a dollar do you
know who this is
look closely it's a chess player that's
right what who is he Levy you want a
dollar
okay thanks man good job he got it and
let me tell you new you were acting
disinterested but I saw you I see the
chest in you
we are here at the chess.com Global
championship in Belgrade with Grand
Master nihal sarin who is tied 2-2 after
day one the levy Rosman on the live
commentary was saying that Anish plays
poorly against Magnus when Magnus plays
the perks does that factor in did you
study anisha's weakness against the
perks not exactly first game I went into
his prep and got crushed so I just tried
to get some interesting position which
is not in his prep does risky choice but
it worked out brilliantly are you happy
with the 2-2 result after day one at the
start I would have been but after having
a good chance to win three games today
I'm not so happy but it could have been
worse of course and final question in
your first match you actually had a
laptop here and you were sometimes
looking at some chess but today no
laptop no device was there a reason that
you uh just wanted to be left your own
thoughts for today's games anyway during
the games you're using a lot of brains
so I thought we should get some rest at
least between
Alex you told me if I came to Belgrade
I'd get a game in like five seconds I've
been sitting here forever
oh what's that oh peshka pressure
getting to see you down there you got to
speak up when you won a game okay let's
get peshka some phone books here Alex
and then we'll get a game in the bar
thank you
foreign
welcome back to Toronto and day two of
the cgc semifinals Anish giri getting
ready at his setup to face nihal sarin
in game six back in the spring we had
thousands of you participate in our cgc
bracket challenge here's how you pick
these semi-final matchups if you had
them in your bracket many of you had a
car Moving on but less than one percent
of you even picked the Geary Sauron
match and welcome back to all of you
here in the semifinals I am Grand Master
Robert Hess alongside me is Grandmaster
U.S chess champion Fabiana carwana Fabi
we know the scores through game five
it's two and a half two and a half in
hikar versus Wesley Anish giriato a 3-2
lead so we keep talking about nihal
needs to get this game six he needs to
find an opening that suits the style he
needs a repeat of yesterday and I think
I saw Ani she looked a little bit
nervous I think he realizes how
important it is if he gets a draw here
he is a huge favorite in this match if
mihil makes a comeback I would still put
that slight slight favor to knee Hall
but still this first game is of course
an amazing
game for Anish I mean in the match
especially coming close to the end this
is exactly what he needed and you called
it nearly a perfect game from Anish gear
versus neosarin that will be our first
match going forward in round six Wesley
so in a car staggered by 10 minutes and
you see Anish seated there getting some
water nihal seated in Belgrade Serbia so
uh Anish has yet to face an opponent
face to face here and I think he's happy
about that because he can just play the
board
yeah he's happy with the chess right now
but still I think he realizes the
importance of this he's going to have to
hold solidly he can't have a repeat of
yesterday we're in the second game he
was just soundly outplayed and Nihao
sarn as we look at our rapid insights
has played about double the games as
Anish giri in Rapid chess but they're
both equally accurate and niho the nod
for Wild games but also he plays a
larger percentage of end game sloppy
maybe that's a good thing the amount of
wild game is because this is exactly
what he needs now he needs some wild
games he needs to get chances and he
even if it leads to a loss he needs to
go out swinging because you can't just
go to some equalish positions and let
Anis draw it out he needs to take his
chances so what you're saying is here
and now nihal son has to play for a win
this game is super important this is
almost a must win I would say okay and
you heard it from Fabiano caruana's
mouth to the chessboard D4 played from
nihal CERN and let's see what we're
gonna get here because on move two a
niche hasn't moved yet look at that he's
thinking I'm moving too funny what does
that indicate well knee-hawk can do
anything and he shows it in this game he
played a line which has recently become
somewhat popular but still a very rare
line
and I noticed this line played I've seen
it for the first time played in a game
Neiman against Ray Robson from the U.S
Championship which was concluded
recently and this line is a surprise but
of course black is okay and in that game
Ray Robinson actually ended up winning
with the black pieces so Bishop 4 shows
I just want to fight it's it's sort of
an extension of his strategy yesterday
he's willing to get an equal position
all the pieces on the board in that game
we saw Knight takes D5 Bishop G3 C5
played
I believe the game continued with E4
Knight F6 and E5 and and there was some
kind of crazy position happened
eventually Ray Robson got the better of
Hans Neiman but maybe this is what uh
this is what Neil is hoping for and he
probably has some prep in mind I think
we'll see Knight takes D5 if he takes D5
that nihal is very happy to get a sort
of Carlsbad structure well we did see
Knight takes D5 and that's the
Temptation was the bishop and F4 the
Knight was attacking that Bishop there
the bishop Retreats the G3 so we have
this hybrid of like a like a tarash and
like a a London system and
um well excuse me everybody we are
having some technical
difficulties here and so as we bring the
game back on screen it was like a hybrid
opening from nihal sarin like this
bishop F4 you said it's rare he's trying
to catch Anish giri out of preparation
and we we see something similar to what
you were just describing between Hans
name actually this is exactly what
happened in the game I had confused it
he didn't play E5 immediately because
then black could have put the Knight on
e4 attacking the bishop on G3 he played
Knight D2 sacrificing a pawn and it
looks like black just won a Central Pawn
but the pawn on E5
is extremely good in creating some sort
of like
break in the center so black queen side
pieces can't get to the king side which
means that white is setting up for King
side attack Bishop to D3 Castle it's a
slow attack but it could potentially get
very dangerous if Black's King is on the
king side and the minor piece is an iron
C6 99d5 Bishop on C8 can't get access to
that part of the board while white
pieces are all aiming in that direction
so white is saying okay I don't care
about the pawn so much right now it's a
pass Pawn but it's also not going
quickly anywhere and I'm just hoping
that in the long term I can create an
attack and yeah I think this is a great
opening Choice from D Hall he took some
inspiration from recent games of course
these young players not only young
players but especially them they keep up
to date with all the trends so he saw
this as a trend and he analyzed it and
he knew that he could get a fight in
this way it's exactly what he needs yeah
I think it's the perfect opening Choice
as you said because the pawn sacrifice
but the intentions are clear and what
Neil did not have in game one was a plan
here you just name like five different
moves with a clear intention Bishop D3
Knight E4 Castle all this stuff playing
against the black kings side where the Q
a is likely to go and so let's talk
about from a niche's perspective moves
that come to mind for me of course
Bishop E7 that's just one move but in
terms of a plan at some point I would
think about playing a move like F6 just
to get rid of this thorn in the center I
think that's oh wow he plays Knight to
E7 that's a big surprise I think that
what you said was the most natural to
play Bishop B7 short castle and at some
point maybe not F6 but F5 because if F6
you don't really threaten fp5 but if F5
you block the bishop off so you kind of
force white to capture on passant but I
think he goes for something entirely
different he's not developing his pieces
and what do we tell to people who are
just learning chess first rule develop
your pieces Anish is breaking the rules
but of course as a super Grand Master he
knows when you can break them and when
you can't and maybe this is a case when
you can't but on the other hand I would
think playing how many moves has nine
made Knight G8 F6 D5 E7 F5 four moves in
the opening with one piece that's a lot
of time wasted before you've even
castled and gotten your pieces out but
that's how that works so you become a
super Grand Master cross 2700 and then
you can do whatever you want so just
something to Aspire to for me well you
can break the rules and then if it's bad
people can criticize you for it but if
it's good you look like a genius so
maybe that's what Anish is going for but
here I don't know because the iron F5 is
not entirely secure like
it might take the bishop on G3 but I'm
not even sure if you want to do that
because then you're spending five moves
just to trade off a piece but if white
plays Bishop's F4 G4 is on the cards at
some point and you know if white were
given the choice to play like H4 H5 G4
well we see G4 on the board yeah I think
now Knight H4 is a force move but Nitro
makes a lot of sense because now white
cannot let that knight jump into G2 with
check and a fork of its own and I feel
like this doesn't look that dangerous
for black something went a little bit
wrong I think maybe G4 was premature
from nihal sarin because this bishop on
F4 is kind of in your own way I guess
Knight F3 just continued kicking away
Black's pieces but after Knight F3
Bishop E7 I feel like trades are good
for black in this position when you have
less space you want fewer pieces on the
board trades are certainly good for
black but he did take five moves to
trade off that Knight that's a lot and
now he's gonna have to lose another
Tempo with that Bishop because the
bishop went E7 H4 and after Knight F3
it's probably going to go back to E7
where it doesn't have to immediately or
in fact it does because maybe G5 is a
threat but in any case it's not going to
do anything on H4 so 93 Bishop seven
black has spent a lot of time white has
developed all his pieces G4 is
potentially weakness but it's hard to
say I once had a game against lebonaroni
from the Canada's tournament in this
exact structure I from a different
opening entirely but I had the extra
Pawn on D4 and he just went G4 he
unprovoked he didn't even attack a piece
with it all he wanted to do was expand
and attack on the king side
and I still would prefer White's
position because although you traded off
that night it was a pretty good night on
D5 it was controlling a lot of squares
you took a lot of time to do that and
still white has this first of all
blockade the bishop D3 is such a
beautiful piece it can't get harassed by
Knight to B4 it just stays there and
potentially looking over to kingside if
black were ever to Castle and I would
say Knight to F3 bishop t7 and either
Castle short Castle or queen to E2 or
even some sort of H4 stuff is all in the
cards
black has to develop the bishop 1 C8
that's the most important thing B6
Bishop B7 at some point you're gonna
need to do it but it's not so easy
because then the Knight on C6 is a bit
loose I think I know what Anisha can do
he's gonna play Knight E7 again at some
point and try to bring that Knight
around but Knight F3 is step one I would
say the one downside for nihal is he
doesn't have the second Knight to go to
E4 Knight E4 is such a good piece aiming
towards D6 but also staring towards the
king side with G5 so with fewer pieces
it feels like the attack doesn't rage on
quite as uh powerfully and so I I mean
I'm surprised that Anish hasn't played
Bishop E7 right away is G5 not just a
threat to win a piece maybe he's
thinking about G5 because at least it
needs some time but then you're
destroying your entire structure I don't
know that that that is a very gutsy move
to make so I suspect Bishop t7 but he
doesn't want to waste all his time like
at some point you start to feel a bit
bad I'm moving the same pieces over and
over again and neglecting my development
and my king safety and let's make a few
moves Bishop to E7 still very likely
let's say white word Castle short
and block where the castle short too now
for example a nice move is Queen to E2
and if blackboards had tried to develop
his Queen side we see the difficulty B6
just loses on the spot Queen to E4 you
attack denied on C6 also threaten Meg on
H7 and then lose Knight drops off so it
shows how black can develop so easily
his pieces are sort of stumbling over
each other and that pawn D4 it's an
extra pass Pawn but it's actually
getting in the way it stops potential
nice D4 trades trading off the knights
because as you mentioned black would
love to trade off some pieces so not so
easy for black to develop here I think
we might see Castle we might see H4 and
then if H4 Niha will say oh I don't need
to Castle I can just play King to F1
right I walk my king to safety and then
I use the Rook on H1 as a support for
the battering ram H4 H5 expanding and
attacking on the king side and I think
it's clear that if white plays H4
Blackwell not Castle I know players are
taught by their coaches gets your king
to safety so Castle but that's keyword
safety the king will not be safe not
necessarily if it Castle so I think the
black king will stay in the center for a
while but that then begs the question
what's the plan how are we going to
develop you mentioned this bishop on C8
if it goes to D7 not exactly helping on
the position you'd prefer to play B6
Bishop B7 or sometimes A5 B6 Bishop A6
to trade that very very pesky Bishop on
D3 yeah I think that question of safety
is a big one
and when I see Black's position I would
think the safest Blake Place Black's
King could be is obviously not on the
king's eye as you mentioned all white
pieces are aiming on that side of the
board the safest place is for example
black plays Bishop to D7 Queen to B6
long castle and puts that King on a
tucked away in the corner it's very safe
there but that plant takes a lot of time
and white can also consider aggressive
intentions on the queen side for example
B4 and not only is that an aggressive
move maybe B5 but it's also very
restricting move it restricts Black's
knight from C6 so it can go to A5
restricts Black's Pawn expansion like A5
potentially just gaining space white has
the space Advantage it's strange to say
that because black has a pawn D4 wise
upon D5 looks the same but space
Advantage is not just about the amount
of space you've taken on the board but
how much access your pieces have to that
space white pieces have a lot of access
because bishop and D3 is firing on both
sides and blacks Bishop on C8 is stuck
on its initial square and very difficult
to get into the action I agree it kind
of looks like a French defense and will
speaking of openings the first moves
will be underway shortly in the matchup
between Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura
and these two juggernauts have drawn all
five games and probably the insights
between these two you look at it both
extremely accurate both have about the
same percentage of wild games and end
games slightly more for Hikaru Nakamura
but it feels pretty even across the
board yeah I think we mentioned Hikaru
is a great endgame player so I'm not so
surprised to see that statistic that
Hikaru has that super high accuracy in
that game and we have to say that
accuracy is doubly impressive because
end games often lead to time trouble and
have that accuracy when you're down to
seconds that's a very hard skill to hone
so Hikaru as a nine game player uh
definitely one of the best but Wesley no
slouch in that category or in fact in
any category it is just a match of
evenly paired players and Wesley he gets
the white piece and immediately puts his
hand over his head again I really
believe this is part of the strategy I
would love to hear from him about that
but he just doesn't want to look over at
ikaru and he's playing this Italian game
and hikarpas A6 rather than what we've
seen from him often with his Pawn going
to A5 well the funny thing about this is
that sometimes the pawn goes to A6 and
then later goes to A5 black uses a Tempo
to lock the queen side up because
White's plan is very often expansion we
even saw it yesterday white plays B4 and
tries to start pushing the pawns getting
some space advantage on the queen side
but it looks like we're seeing a repeat
of yesterday this is the most solid line
that black can play it's in fact the
line that I prepared for the candidates
tournament and also the line that Hikaru
plays himself very very often so I took
some inspiration in looking at Italian
lines from a car's repertoire because
it's so stable but Wesley did get his
chances yesterday I still think I'm
still a bit surprised these guys are
always going for E4 E5 structures where
it's really hard to break your opponent
down but Wesley got good chances in the
final game yesterday so maybe he thinks
this is where I'll have the best chances
today it almost feels a bit stubborn and
maybe you can talk about this is because
at the highest level you want to prove
that your preparation was worth it that
your line is good do you think that's
part of it or is this truly what they
believe is the best and that's why
they're not deviating from repeating
their lines I think that they're looking
for even the tiniest place where you can
get just a tiny Advantage because they
know that once you get that tiny Edge
you can increase the pressure especially
in these quick time format games
it's doubly like when you're it's a
classical time control you can sit and
think and find the best defense but when
you're low on time the pressure and the
stress of it is increased and it's very
easy to once you get a worse position
for that to spiral out of control we see
a bit of a different structure compared
to yesterday and this Rook B1 Rook A1
idea it's very funny looking to the
uninitiated but it's actually a very
typical and theoretical line but I think
rooked B8 is not supposed to be the way
because you're supposed to get that
Knight away from C6 you're supposed to
at some point play Knight t7 and Rook B8
stops idea in its tracks for black
because then a takes B5 and Rook A7
would win the bishop A4 Blackboard to
ever recapture on B5 yeah I almost want
to do an instant replay of that little
maneuver there because it's a really
good point by you that Rook B1 it may
seem like white was going to play B5 and
have an open file for The Rook but then
black plays B5 and The Rook just
shuffles right back over and I like to
say this the side that controls the pawn
breaks is off on the side with the
advantage and because white can
determine a takes B5 opening of a file
whereas B takes A4 doesn't open a file
this problem before is safe and sound
here and the square and after Rook takes
A4 you've just created a problem for
yourself so I really like that move uh
Rook back to A1 and now we see the
Knight come to F1 Fabi it looks like
standard plans Knight trying to go to F5
very standard play and yeah you're
absolutely correct what controls the
levers on the queen side he's the one
who can decide when he wants to take on
B5 whatever is advantageous or he can
just keep that tension as long as he
wants he's the one who controls it
because black can never play B takes A4
on the other hand it's not easy to find
another plan besides at some point
playing the a6b5 because if white were
to play A5 here black provoked that move
saying okay I gave you a Tempo but I
dropped the bishop back to A7 and now
you no longer have that pressure on the
queen side and the structure again we
point to the Bishops whites Ponder a bit
more on dark squares on the queen side
than whites so if white were to play A5
and someday in the end game we might see
those A5 B4 C3 that pawn chain become
vulnerable because black has a dark
Square bishop and white also has a dark
Square Bishop so white can't attack
Black's Queen side bombs but black can
attack whites good point a pawn chain
only as strong as his base Pawn but what
continues to catch mines how different
these two matchups are we have a locked
up position only one minor piece traded
and then on the court of my eye I saw a
rook on H5 for Anish Geary so it seems
like between Wesley and icaro they're
just trying to find little plants here
trying to get the tiniest advantages
there and for Anish giri and nielsar
most of their games just feel like it's
a free-for-all and I think we should
dive right back in because now black
cannot Castle it's illegal for Anish
giri's King to get over there because
the Rook on H5 but even just the last
few moves have been difficult for him
he's down the clock he went A5 and then
he went H5 so playing on both flanks
yeah something went very raw piranish I
mean let's just think about what he did
in this game so far he moved one night
five times he moved one Bishop three
times together two square like go to
once and then he played flank pawns A5
and a tribe his King is still in the
center after 20 moves your King has to
be somewhere else besides shuffling and
over you know still in the center being
barreled down by Rook on G1 there are
Knight G5 ideas in the air then Knight
to H7 potentially I don't know if it
works concretely here but that King is
in Mortal danger for a long time I'm
even wondering can white just Castle
along and then double the Rooks on the G
file it's an option maybe castling long
you think oh my my king might be in a
bit of a vulnerable spot so I don't want
to do that on the other hand Black's
King is equally vulnerable if not more
so and
I'm kind of inspired because as someone
who struggled to break down anisha's
repertoire with the white pieces time
and time again for so many years and
nihal is just finding chances in every
game he plays some in innocuous looking
sideline and we do see he castled he
shows his aggressive intentions but he
plays some innocuous sideline and then
after 20 moves he's borderline winning
against one of the best prepared players
in the world it's unbelievable stuff and
white has so many different plans King
to B1 just to get the king safe and
sound Bishop E4 go out for this D4 pawn
and you might not even need Bishop E4
don't forget this Rook on H5 is loose
over here so there could be a time for a
night sacrifice to get this Rook it
won't work immediately but I think Anish
has to play G6 and I'm scared to make
that move I'm already looking at even
Rook sacrifices on that square I don't
know if it's good but that's one of my
first thoughts can I just give away some
of my pieces for your pawns that Shield
your King well I'm thinking G6 that's
just asking for Bishop takes G6 I mean
in a bowler game you do without thinking
bam at this time control maybe you think
think about it but still that looks so
dangerous here I mean Rook to G1 and
Bishop H6 is coming how many pieces are
actually defending Black's King you The
Rook on H5 isn't really defending kind
of the bishop 187 sure but all the
queenside pieces Rook on eight Knight on
C6 Bishop on theater cut off from from
the game because of this Pawn E5 it's
like a Dem it's not letting the water
out all of Black's pieces are stuck on
the queen side so this is a super strong
attack maybe it's not winning maybe
black has a defense because he has a
piece after all but still this looks so
dangerous I don't know if I would
be able to play G6 it's just it's such a
a risky move well he played Queen D5 the
king slid over to B1 and G6 still may be
met by the sacrifice on the Square so if
not for G6 your Rook really is loose
over here Bishop E4 is a new possibility
because your queen moved up towards the
center so you're gonna attack it go out
for the D4 Pawn Knight G5 as you
mentioned seems to be a good plan why
not just Rook G4 Rook G1 go after G7 I
think concretely why does threatening
Bishop B4 followed by Knight xd4 that
Rook on H5 is loose and the Queen on D5
where is it going it's getting kicked
around the board I don't even know why
it went to D5 because the only idea was
to go to A2 but now that white stopped
that threat the queen on D5 will just
start to get bullied by white minor
pieces so I think we're already talking
about a quick knockout in this game I
mean Anish will have to find some sort
of miraculous defense to survive and I
don't know I would if I were in his
shoes I would think
let's already get ready for the next
game try to think of my strategy about
how to come back with the white pieces
because yeah this is a complete disaster
for Anish well I'm getting your shoes
not literally I'm not gonna bother you
over the table over here but you said
there's a smooth F5 earlier and with
Bishop E4 being such a huge threat I
feel like F5 is an option for black I
know it's risky it makes G7 look even
looser and you can just double up your
Rooks but at least it complicates the
position a bit Yeah I think you
absolutely have to it has its pluses and
downsides in this case the plus I think
is that it doesn't lose on the spot
which is what black really wants at the
moment the downside is after uh e takes
F on passant Bishop takes up okay black
is very happy the bishop one F6 is
actually guarding G7 and black has ID of
E5 which is good the downside G5 is
suddenly a Outpost for all of White's
pieces Knight G5 Bishop G5 all these
moves are coming I like Bishop G5
because you don't hang H4 for the moment
and you also remove that defender on F6
and let's say Bishop takes G5 I'm
thinking Knight takes G5 or even rookie
65 both of those moves are crushing to
me I mean Rook H4 here but is there
Bishop to E4 followed by Queen to F3 is
there Knight to H7
you'll have to start calculating but at
some point
things will fall apart for black yeah
this is brutal looks like a very
straightforward attack the black king
does not have many pieces helping it out
so I'm with you Fabi that Rook F5 was
played wow I said the F5 Square it's
almost like one of those Mouse lips when
you're trying to grab the pawn but you
already touched the rook and so the Rook
comes over but I have to say I like that
decision because the point everybody we
might see a queen sacrifice if Bishop
takes F5 he takes F5 Here Comes This
Bishop to E6 suddenly we see a plan
maybe Queen E4 check if you need to
trade Queens in fact the evaluation Bar
says black is better thanks to this
attack and if you play Bishop E4 this is
the queen sec I was about to highlight
is Rook F4 takes takes you've two minor
pieces and a pawn for the queen this is
anything but clear you know I do like
this decision practically and if our
knee-haul I wouldn't take anything you
can take a queen you can take a rook
you'd think oh I should take something
but I would have actually thought Rook
to G4 just a fan it's it's kind of funny
to just ignore all of Black's pieces
that you can take and he doesn't go for
it Bishop before he is probably the
correct move and
also the most logical one but I like
Rook G4 just saying I don't care about
your pieces I want your king what do you
think about this sacrifice though you
get two Bishops and this D4 Pawn for the
queen and all of a sudden this bishop
can come to life do you think that black
has real chances I would be so happy if
I were in his shoes to at least get some
activity because you know Rook F4 Bishop
D5 ed5 I'm looking at Bishop five ideas
I'm even looking at somewhere Knight B4
once the King goes to the a file because
if that a file opens we're looking at
potential checkmates
objectively of course white is much
better probably winning practically
black has the activity the bishop CA we
were saying that was a bishop that was
stuck the whole game and now it's come
to life and yeah at least you think you
see the hope you see the prospects for
your opponent to make mistakes and
that's the most important thing when you
have a bad position I think that anishq
has to go for it and he should do so
quickly and I still just can't get this
out of my head I look at this game I
look at the game between akara Nakamura
and Wesley so and as we see side by side
they could not be any more different
these matches could not be more
different Niche gear has won two games
neon has won one the other matchup is
five draws and if you just look at the
screen on the right hand side it is
another locked position two nights per
side just a pawn and a couple minor
pieces traded it's not the Lively
position we see on the left and I feel
like for Anish giri who's now dropping
to 3 minutes and 20 seconds Fabi as he
continues to spend that time is he going
to sacrifice his Queen he has to I mean
there are situations when you want to do
something when you're happy with your
situation and there are situations where
you just have to do it because it's your
only chance and that's exactly what I'm
thinking that Anish has to do I mean he
might realize that this is probably lost
in fact I'm sure he does but he's
probably already realized that he was a
disparate situation this is where I
think Hikaru would shine just take your
practical chance so you're saying that
Hikaru and Anish just switch places
because the niche you know he often
shines himself in these positions that
don't seem like they have the clearest
plans but he can maneuver around he's a
very a pragmatic player but he's not
using his time wisely I believe I know
he wants to play Rook takes F4 you as a
chess player you don't want to sit and
have no plans he does go Queen B3 he
must have evaluated or seen some exact
sequence that eliminated Rook takes A4
from his calculus he probably saw
something or maybe he just couldn't
bring himself to make a move that even
though it has practical chances he
probably thinks this is objectively lost
he is a very classical player but this
is not classical chess and Rapid chess
time is an important factor threats to
your opponent are an important factor
putting pressure making your opponent
think
you know me how think I'm gonna blunder
because there's pieces around my king
active minor pieces Bishop to F5 coming
Knight to B4 coming you need to get in
your opponent's head a bit Queen to B3
not a very threatening move white has a
wide variety of choices
maybe simply Bishop to G5
I mean the bishop is hanging and you
want to trade off white uh Black's last
remaining Defender the bishop 187 is a
very good defensive piece of course and
the problem after Bishop G5 for black is
you want to play Bishop takes A3
but then Rook to D3 happens
and you don't win upon A3 you end up
losing a piece instead right so it's
like a tactical solution does not exist
here for Niche and nihals down to six
minutes on the right hand side we see
that Wesley says Knight is on F5 and it
was not captured I feel like he is
making progress in that game it's not a
sharp position but with that Rook on D3
on the right hand side of your screen
there that Rook can slide overs the G
file staring at the black king and
Hikaru does need to be careful yeah this
reminds me a little bit of a game that
uh Wesley played recently we were
playing in the uh chess Olympia together
this summer
and he was playing against uh Vivid
Gujarati and he had a very similar type
of position it was some pressure
and he was increasing it increasing and
eventually it ended the draw but he's
definitely good at increasing the
pressure in these types of positions the
structure is symmetrical completely
symmetrical almost except for the A4
versus A6 pawns which we might actually
see a trade right at some point and
complete uh symmetry but the knights are
the important factor and the this Knight
B3 move is quite nice it's based on a
tactical point which was if black were
to take on e4 okay we could show this
variation here in the Wesley so versus
the car Nakamura game you're saying that
if the Knight took on e4 go ahead then
Rook takes d8 comes oh opening up the
queen to the second something captures
on d8 Queen takes E4 and white has the
advantage of two pieces Against The Rook
with the Knight coming to C5 especially
beautiful Knights and a winning position
so Wesley is using small tactics to
improve his position in ways trying to
get a more active Knight on B3
now it's an interesting moment Hikaru
can change the structure but maybe he
doesn't want to because after C takes E6
at night on B7 gets permanently shut out
of the game
and if you take with the Knight on D6 in
comes the Knight to C5 attacking the A6
Pawn so process of elimination May mean
queen takes D6 but then you'll have Rook
D1 with Tempo so all captured had these
slight drawbacks but materials even Pawn
structure all on the same files the
Knight on B7 is just the Kryptonite
against this Knight on B3 because
they're you know the 93 goes to A5 or C5
the Knight on B7 covers both of those
squares so I feel like a couple accurate
moves here from Hikaru Nakamura and then
the advantage that Wesley had a few
moves ago it's gone but I just want to
point out how just look at the
practicality that Hikaru approaches
these decisions with after Rook text D6
he had a choice of many recaptures and a
lot of people would you know think try
to find the perfect recapture right or
eliminate Knight takes D6 or eliminate C
takes E6 in a few seconds he played
Queen D6 I don't think he calculated it
at all the consequences of Rook D1
attacking the queen he just knew I need
to keep time on the clock this is
probably the right decision let's not
overthink it let's just make practical
moves and we talk about the difference
the tiny differences between great
players as all these players are and
very often it comes to Tiny practical
decisions it might look like it's not an
important thing but it could make the
difference in these types of games where
it's just so high pressure fast time
control and you know once you get low on
time that difference between let's say
two minutes and one minutes one minute
it gets felt and the difference between
spending 30 seconds on a move or a
minute on move it gets felt as well for
sure and the reason why I think white
doesn't have an advantage anymore is now
A4 is hanging and that's why I pushed
the pawn but that closes down the queen
side so this Rook eventually would like
to go to date and trade pieces not now
if you play Rook date too soon thinking
I get rid of The Rook on the open file
I'll just make a draw no this Knight
will come to C5 after just a swap of
pieces the Knight goes back to d8 White
is too active and that's going to be bad
news for black so I feel like just you
need to be accurate here maybe Rook C8
and pawn C5 this Pawn is a backward Pawn
that could be a way to get rid of one of
your weaknesses Rook seed is a slightly
unnatural move because normally you
don't put Rooks behind pawns that
haven't moved yet you want to put them
on open files and especially if your
opponent has a work on open file you
want to trade them but it does have a
very clear idea to play C5 probably a
good a very good move and I think Wesley
might have to be in the future a little
bit careful to make sure he doesn't
overextend he's still the one pressing
for an advantage
but if at some point Blackboard to get
Rook C8 and C5
the A5 product could be a strength or a
weakness
having said I also don't see a huge
problem with Rook to d8
because after trade and Knight C5 Queen
D6
maybe black is just ready to trade off
tonight with Knight E6 next
but it could lead to some yeah some sort
of end games like Queen to D3
taking everything and black is not in
time to get the Moose he wants he wants
96 and F6 because white has two threats
Knight C5 and Knight E5 and this
actually looks a lot like a 99 game we
already saw in this match but here black
is losing the pawn so and most likely
the game great so you want to trade
everything you can't get away with it we
did see actually move Rook C8 by Hikaru
and after Rook D5 we saw a swap of
knights on the C5 Square so black can
take the d file White's Rook very active
hitting E5 hitting C6 maybe C4 next but
the material even the position even both
sides have their small plus and minus
they agreed on the draw this game is
over a sixth consecutive draw so both
players they you know they're smiling
because what else can they do as they
cannot separate themselves from one
another yeah these guys are just so
evenly matched it's uh it's actually
quite amazing to watch how they're not
finding a way to make inroads into the
opponent's weak spots I mean they keep
trying keep trying to find some small
ways to get a slightly better position
but even if they do usually the defense
is up to par that that they can't really
make much of it and in this game it's
just a completely different story in the
nihal siren against Anish giri match
they're trading blows in every game for
sure and we can almost pre-move the
result between those two just drawing
every game but here between nihal tsar
and Indonesia it's a big moment for the
Indian teenager because while Wesley so
in a car Nakamura finished game six
nihal needs to win game six to get to
that three to three score and there was
just a huge moment in this game because
after Queen B3 the White Knight dropped
back to D2 where it attacks the queen on
B3 but after D3 Bishop takes D3 Knight
D4 now you take my queen I take yours
the point everyone is that the bishop on
F4 is loose so Knight B3 92 Bishop two
thank you for a piece well thank you
because now we're even and black is
gonna survive this game in fact is
better so that's why nihal plays Queen
E3 and Fabi Queen A4 was anisha's choice
he's hanging on by a thread here
I wouldn't even say he's hanging on
because if white were simply to play
Bishop takes F5 it's probably just
winning position based on the material
count Knight takes a five Queen to E4
tried to trade off a few more pieces and
make it into a technical end game it
might even be that he has better ways D
hell plays this is just crushing this
move is so good it's threatening Knight
and threatening Knight B6 and it's
forcing Black's hand to play Bishop C5
and Bishops here then Bishop takes F5 is
available because the Knight can't
capture back and I wouldn't be surprised
if there's a rook takes G7 and a bishop
H6 things like that I mean and each gear
has been hunted on all sides of the
board and this is what I love about
nihal sarin's chest is he has a great
position maybe bishop takes a five take
materials winning he seems to calculate
and find the proper finesse well he he
has a calculator a great one of that and
this is the his style that regardless of
what you think the logical choices you
know you take a rook he just looks for
the better one and he uses pure
calculation to do so so yeah Bishop C5
will almost certainly happen here
because the only other option is
resignation from anish's point of view
and he probably doesn't want to resign
just yet and then we may see Bishop
takes a five followed by Queen C4 as you
mentioned white is up a clear exchange
and look at those pieces on the queen
side it's not just about the material
the bishop won't see it it just never
got into the game no neither of these
pieces have in under 20 seconds is Anish
giri you know he doesn't really want to
play the position but he goes Knight to
C2 and after Bishop takes C2 then the
Knight can be captured on C4 but at that
point Fabi you can successfully take on
F5 drop a clean exchange and then it
feels like mop up Duty from there but I
don't think you want to because once you
take on F5 you do allow black at least
the Hope Bishop B6 and some counter play
on the king side uh sorry that is on the
queen side if you don't take the Rook on
a five you just leave it there you could
always take it it's not going to go back
anytime soon you can make other moves
you can make oh my god oh but that
that's clinical I think that's actually
Checkmate isn't it like how do you avoid
Checkmate in this position that's so
nasty that that's a brilliant move if
we'll just show if G takes H6 it's
Checkmate three and the King runs away
but this is getting just more and more
upsetting if you're in Niche gear he
took a one game lead and immediately he
gets destroyed by nihal sarin and that's
game yeah he didn't want to look at this
position anymore look he didn't develop
any pieces
his King is still an E8 it actually
moved but it had to move back the only
Act of pieces his Queen which got kind
of bounced around by White's pieces
overall nihal brilliant game and the
same sort of story it's like a repeat of
yesterday from both matches it is we see
that Anish Gary won game five the first
game of today's action and nihal sarin I
mean the guy is unfazed I say guys
teenager it's like he's been there
before and he was there yesterday but
that's incredible stuff from somebody
who does not have the experience of his
opponent well we said that this game
might be a must win from not purely a
must win but from nihao's point of view
he might feel like he needs to come back
right away and he did so and I feel like
this is a big psychological Edge to
knee-haul even though it's the same
match score Anish is not behind by any
means but nihal is the one who's coming
back and now he's critical last two
games I feel like nihal will have an
edge knee All-Star and ties up the score
and as Fabiano caruan himself says he
should have the advantage but it's 3-3
three in both matchups two completely
different matches here so Fabi you say
nihal has the edge what about the one
between a car knock him or Wesley so is
it still evangakaro I feel like it's
unchanged from the start of the day
these guys are just unable to break
through and I would even put a high
probability on Armageddon at this point
I don't know if we'll see all draws to
get there I mean when have you actually
seen a match all draws doesn't happen
very often and especially in such a long
matches eight games but they just can't
find the weakness in their opponent
unlike this matchup where it feels like
every game could be decisive and we saw
in this position Fabi where White had a
pawn sacrifice we see the extra opponent
D4 for black but here was the start of
an assault with the move H4 and it felt
like Neil never took his foot off the
gas pedal I think this is where things
started to go really wrong Pirates I
already didn't like Knight to E7 just
wasting time we said you shouldn't move
the same piece so many times in the
opening whether you're a beginner or a
top chess player as on each is you can't
break the fundamental rules of Chess and
but things start to go even more wrong
because you can't open up the position
where your opponent is attacking this is
also a fundamental mistake White's the
one who has the aggressive attacking
pieces on the kick side Black's not
supposed to start Play there while he
plays H5 which was a mistake because the
Rook comes out to H5 the G file is open
thank you very much and finally another
great decision here from Neil sarin yeah
long Castle great he saw that the king
is going to be safe on B1 and White's
pieces are all aimed at Black's King on
the king side and Black's pieces can't
get there the bishop and see it is cut
off from the game and I don't see six
Rook on A8 all cut off by this beautiful
Pawn on E5 and white can just double on
the G file Ani started some extremely
desperate play which we even liked if he
had sacked the queen but he didn't
follow through fully and even if he had
objectively we have to say white would
be in a winning position well Rook takes
F4 Bishop takes D5 he takes out was that
Queen sacrifice and I'm guessing the
niche is kicking himself because he had
no chance after not going for this line
but here Fabi guess what has the
objective great position probably
winning with proper play but at least
black finally at long last has a plan at
least he would have had some fun here he
would have had some active moves and and
Niha would be at least on the defense
defensive side for a little bit he would
have had to soak up that compensation
and then eventually use his material
advantage but in the game it was much
easier so how would you have continued
here for white I would think that you
might want to get the king off the a
file but I like the Moon Knight to G5
because it stops Bishop G4 black will
give a check on F5 and then the king
moves to the a file probably to A2 to
stop Knight B4 because if Knight before
now you can take and hide that King on
B3 and now it's way too much material
right of course it looks like Checkmate
but King B foremost you're hiding behind
enemy pieces almost Checkmate but not
quite so probably still winning for
black but at least you have some fun you
can I think that Anish looked at this he
didn't see a way to continue the attack
but sometimes you just have to
you know take a leap of faith and say
okay I'm losing but maybe my opponent
will make mistakes and I'll get some
chances in a messy game while the way he
did it he was hoping that at least he's
keeping even material it wasn't the case
and it didn't matter because nehal is a
perfect calculator right and here I mean
there's another moment actually after
Knight D2 we didn't get into it during
the live game but Queen takes D1 he
could have given up his Queen once again
and after say queen takes you and Rook
takes F4 you now have a rook of minor
pieces and a pawn that's a Alaska
compensation for the queen and it's not
exactly game over just yet this would
have also been a decent chance maybe
it's still losing for black but you just
have to do this I mean at some point it
doesn't you don't think about the
valuation you just think what's my best
chance and that's what nihal is great at
that's what Anish didn't do so well in
this game
but overall we have to say a very very
good victory from nehal yeah we tune in
with D3 and just that final move Knight
C4 the Knight protects the Rook you can
capture with your less valuable piece
but Knight C4 is actually the best move
according to the engine so precise play
from nihal son and here wants more
Bishop H6 Bobby it would led to
Checkmate if he took on H6 you know it
was funny that Rook on F5 that was
hanging for like a dozen moves never got
captured he was he was trying to bait
him like take my rook and then I'll at
least get my Bishop in the game but
nehal said no I don't care about your
Rook all I care about is the king and
this was just checkmate
if G takes H6 white is going for the
kill immediately Anish played one last
desperate move but I don't even think he
had any idea that you know I can still
save this game it was just out of the
nurse show okay I'll make one last move
Rook takes G7 the attack is crashing
through and he resigns it almost looks
like black made no moves in this game
and nihaustion got everything he wanted
that's how dominant of a display of
tactical awareness and just initiating
attack nihal sarm played an excellent
game of chess yeah look at how all of
White's pieces
played in this game all of them had a
role there was not a single useless
piece while anisha's pieces a lot of
them just stayed on their initial
squares I mean my goodness it just felt
like Anish giri had this matchup he won
the first game of today's action in
round five so the ball's back in
anisha's score he'll get white what does
he need to do what's how's he gonna
shape it up first he needs to just
forget about this game because this was
a painful game for him especially coming
off of a win and thinking I'm in the
lead again I'm a big favor to win this
match against my younger opponent but
this was just a crushing Victory and he
just needs to forget about it I think
Anish is a player who does that very
well you know he he has strong
psychology he's been in these situations
before where you know you win a game you
lose a game you're in these tough
matches that are back and forth so he
has experience on his side maybe that
will help him psychologically but nihal
at the moment has the momentum okay you
heard it from coach Fabiano lasso over
here excuse me mispronouncing your new
last name but Danny we're gonna send it
back to you and the fellows thanks guys
wow so much to unpack Deja Vu here we
say again uh the only victories in the
semi-finals have come for the white
pieces and only in the Sauron Geary
match so all right let's remind
everybody of who we are here sitting on
the chairs right in front of the global
Chess Championship set we've got
International Master Levy Rosman the man
Gotham chess feed a master James Canty
you know him as GM Canty Grand Master
Daniel noraditski some call him Dania
some call them other things that we
won't talk about I am Danny wrench and I
am pumped to be here let's dive into the
scores
remind you of where we sit we are still
deadlocked at three games a piece it
looks like not much is changing but once
again we have very different roads in
which we've arrived here nihal Sauron
guys bouncing back
getting the dub again despite his more
experienced opponent showing up with
great opening prep putting the youngster
on his heels delivering the first win of
the day nihal sarin says I'm all right I
got you I'm cool calm and collected
right back at you yeah so the storyline
is repeating itself like it did
yesterday the first game when each Geary
says what's up I'm the man I'm gonna win
this game one exact same thing nihal
sarin shows up to game two and
demolishes nothing faces him
demolishes right like and it wasn't
close so now the fascinating thing is
they've played six games right in four
of these games nihal has had the upper
hand and he just had the upper hand in
the first game of both days he's got to
completely flip the script and he has
very limited time to do that you know
yesterday
Geary got away with a couple games in
the back and the back end of this match
right he he was under pressure by Sauron
after a similar Victory where Nihao
turned around right
I don't think Gary's going to get away
with that again if he gets in bad
positions once more in games and he hit
him with a mean one I mean right hook
there and he collapsed and it's that was
a scary one in fact you know if I'm in
this corner I'm like hey bro he can hit
heart he hits you very hard so he needs
to like you know recalibrate take a deep
breath breathe and come back out here
with a better mindset maybe a better
even opening prep as well done at the
end of the day yesterday Robert made a
uh made a comment about anisha's hair
that he was truly disheveled right is
this going to be another game that
throws him off his balance and dishevels
in each Geary listen this was a crucial
game from the score perspective
obviously but it was also sort of a
narrative shift in game because the
narrative that started to enter my head
after game five the first game today was
okay nehal misses these two huge
opportunities yesterday and then Anish
delivers on the opportunity and you
start talking okay now he's gonna draw
with black and he's gonna win the match
boom everything just changed nehal
destroys him demolishes him as Levy said
now the narrative shifts again and now
it's all about nehal coming back twice
now from a one-point deficit that he
keeps doing it and the ball
psychologically is definitely in a niche
Geary's Court he needs more good
preparation of the white pieces in the
next game by the way he said game five
which would shape the match right but
let's look into that here we go
I was feeling like a prophet now I'm
feeling more like a fool but well maybe
it did change the match it just woke up
nihal and yeah guys I met Lee Hall with
lose and then he would win the next game
and then
they call you the prophet right so I
mean if he is the prophet maybe he saw
it all but going back to the X's and O's
that Bobby was talking about there the
the one moment maybe a niche had at
least to have some fun yeah was that
interesting Queen stack that could have
could have turned the balance at least
from a practical point of view you
buying any of that no no I mean yes
anything for Bianna karawana uh is
selling I am buying absolutely but I I
think he just sort of was surrendered to
the fact that the game was over and I
mean nihal by the way showing up with an
opening surprise in a Mainline kind of
position on the third move right he's
doing it with white he's doing with the
black very deliberately trying to take a
niche out of his comfort zone actually
when game five started yeah and I saw
that nihal repeated the same e496 Nim
switch appeared setup that he did
yesterday I was actually really mad I
thought it was a terrible terrible
decision because you're giving Anish
giri like the entire night essentially
to prepare against that and he shows up
and just what even was that he played
like The Reincarnation of Mikhail Salas
what I said to you right but it was I
don't know it was a crazy decision from
nihal and then he just said I had to
shut up that's why you're commentating
and I'm playing and he Strikes Back in
game six so I mean these guys sign a
contract to entertain like all of us
they're throwing for Content waiting for
content on command yeah I 100 agree I
thought I was like the dumbest thing
ever like you know how Gary preps
why would you play the same thing that
you know the unorthodox he's going to
look at that he looked at it and he
crushed him I found the E5 H4 I mean he
was up time and everything then of
course through the little curveball at
him D4 C4 Bishop F4 he like what is this
and as soon as you throw him off it's
just that's what nihal needs to keep
doing so Gary has to be prepped for
little bit more things you got to check
the the opening file was more for uh for
Sauron effect so but what impressed me
so much about nihal's preparation in
this last game that that Knight D2 moved
Bishop F4 these are not computer
recommendations everybody can plug a
position into stockfish let it sit
overnight and pair at the top move not
everybody can have that Keen sense of
what position is going to be hard to
play from a human standpoint yeah the
computer was even arguably giving a tiny
Edge for black after that pawn sack but
nihal understood that this is a
ridiculously difficult position to
handle especially in a rapid game is
that astute sense impresses me so much
especially given uh nihal's relative
inexperience and youth he he played that
like a champ yeah it's interesting
because from a prep perspective both
have their plans in terms of prep a
niches is much more I want to get him in
a main line and show him what I've
cooked up at home everything you just
described about nihao's approach is is
also gets a lot of credit from a prep
perspective it's a very deliberate
approach when you're trying to avoid
main lines and I hear people talk about
Magnus in that sense a lot too that he
didn't get enough credit early on when
people were talking about his opponents
being better prepared how well prepared
you have to be to avoid your opponent's
prep and to get positions that you're
still happy to play nihal does it again
on command winning game six and wowzers
okay we have another match going on
again the match delivering the decisive
blows has gotten all of our Focus here
so far at halftime but let's switch
gears and head on over to Wesley so and
Hikaru Nakamura guys I I have no idea
what to make of this match right now I
don't know who's feeling better who
wants armor again more they both seem to
have made up their mind that we're going
to get a bunch of draws Bobby asked a
question Levy he said who draws all of
their matches and just gets to what time
as he was saying it Donnie and I were
looking at each other like you remember
playing Magnus Carlsen right right right
are we gonna get eight draws here I
don't know the more the more I'm
thinking about it and the smaller the
window of time is kind of growing yeah I
it seems like it makes sense that we
will go to an Armageddon maybe they both
just think that they're going to fare
better there I mean I made this joke to
you before or maybe after we went to
break what happens if they submit equal
Wagers are we just gonna sit here for
eight hours or whatever you know yeah I
don't know to just give them boxing
gloves just figure it out that way I'm
really not sure but I think with white
Wesley at the last couple of games with
that Italian yeah it's got a little
spice on there he's got a little
seasoning on the position and I mean
yesterday he had a great position but
ultimately he carves tactical
defensiveness which is a very underrated
skill in defensive tactics uh was the
one pulling through and helping him hold
the Half Point Johnny I want to throw
over to you because one thing that just
popped in my mind was one thing that was
different about game six was they didn't
even pretend that they were frustrated
you saw them both agree to withdraw
still with the queen and the Rooks on
the board were you surprised by how
quickly that game ended giving us some
more breakdown time here but they just
agreed and both players seem frustrated
with what was going not yeah I mean I
think they're not necessarily happy that
neither of them is is getting that many
chances they're also getting more
nervous as the match is going on so you
can see those Jitters coming out on the
surface but I think if we see E4 E5 in
the last two games I think we're gonna
see two draws if either side decides to
deviate whether it's a car with one
Knight F3 or Wesley with something like
a sicilian I think the former is more
likely than the latter I think if Hikaru
plays E4 Wesley plays E5 if hikara plays
Knight F3 we'll get a more exciting game
but at this point both players that
Armageddon game is already sitting in
their minds and that's causing the
butterflies in the stomach to start up
again match strategy Canty you think
Hikaru just wants to get to Armageddon
and then finally break out his title
Tuesday special night every B3 or we're
gonna see the guy break the Berlin you
know doing the face race because that's
what he was doing the facial so we're
reading the face like he's ready for
Armageddon yeah definitely ready for
Armageddon here I think of course as we
said if he deviates then it's probably
gonna be a win from somebody but if we
see e45 it's gonna be Army getting and I
think he car was taking that long I
actually I'm going to throw just a huge
curveball I think if either one of them
is going to deviate it's obviously going
to be Hikaru okay can I get an agreement
and if you're going to deviate in this
match you got to do it on move one and
you got to do it with white you can't go
for a sicilian I don't know he did the
fortnite scotch right he's already
technically deviated but that was like a
mini deviation yeah but the one thing is
if they reach over again we definitely
won't see a Berlin because black would
have such a huge Legend I think you're
going to deviate with C4 yeah because I
think C4 the English is the best way to
create something on the board now
whether they'll still try to play a
Queen's Gambit declined or I mean C4 E5
the reverse Sicilian is the most
imbalanced opening that we have right
now in top level chess there's a million
different move orders that are all
flexible that's what I think is going to
happen if one of them has to do
something differently but will it happen
in the Armageddon or in game eight or in
game seven I think it'll probably happen
in that Armageddon it's a good it's a
good guess it was a curveball C4 was not
what I was expecting but if I had to
guess I'm gonna upset Canty here and say
I actually think we're gonna get two
more E4 games and I think we are going
to have eight draws headed into
Armageddon so don't beat him up for that
candy maybe you should threaten them and
say if you play the Berlin one more time
I'm out of here and then you know who
knows what would change all right in
addition to watching what's gonna happen
next our players have been having fun
with Nemo and Canty all week on Monday
Nemo put our cgc players to a little
10-second puzzle challenge that we had
cooked up you may be surprised by the
results
welcome to Toronto welcome to the cgc
all right your 10 seconds is up
Bishop D2 is that correct
it is not Bishop D2 so it's obviously F2
and then Queen G2 Knight H training Rook
F1
oh okay so you're and there's also
workup takes G2 the same thing are you
ready for the second one yeah
unfortunately Bishop D2 doesn't work
because of Rook to G3 oh G3 so queen of
three first yes okay Queen of the
reverse there we go okay I would stay
with queen of three in the first move
and after him
and uh aligned and the Beautiful One
yeah yeah you're you're nailing this one
are you ready for the last one
I guess this little kid Queen G6
ah
rookie eight check we should take V8
Queen G6 yeah yeah finally yeah I got
one correct all right one more like ten
more okay I need to redeem myself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you want more you can go to chess.com
puzzles I got your premium membership
buddy but Jokes Aside they were they
were digging deep there on some of those
puzzles down there those were not easy
it took us a long time to get the
database in a position with some puzzles
that could really challenge super GMS
but those were tough I love that and I
thought it was just a competitive chess
players are but in the most Wholesome
Way imagine like you give them a puzzle
doesn't matter if they're skydiving if
they've just woken up you're just you
enter solving mode and you have to get
it right like it just becomes a
competition instantly yeah
Levy that make you want to jump back
into some some more puzzle streams uh
well so just to break it down for the
audience the first puzzle that they saw
was a force mating sequence in the sense
that like black was giving check check
check check mate and it had like a
couple of very interesting ideas where
the first move is this Pawn walking
through danger a bunch of different ways
but that second one if anybody wants to
rewind that footage and go see that
second one was borderline impossible
because you have to sack the queen and
the checkmating idea by white is a quiet
move you play a setup move that's what
we call like a chess study very rare out
in the wild in a normal chess game
usually that first one is much more
common just chop everything down and
then win but that second one was just so
Savage I was trying to sit here and like
oh I'm gonna get it too I'm gonna no you
put up some mean puzzle Rush scores
though on your stream from time to time
no my puzzle rating arise uh my power
level is over nine thousand but my
puzzle rating is at 3 500 right whoa
yeah it's only 3 500 yeah 3 500 The
Puzzle Battle Championship coming back
in January for all you puzzle Silvers
who puzzles solve who love that can't
wait can't you're gonna throw your I'm
gonna see the ring for that I'm gonna be
there yeah I know I got some GM's I got
you know Creek or me and him was close
the last time so I got to beat him Donya
is like disgusting with it it's pretty
you don't invite him
like the the timed mode I like the time
mode because I'm really only good at the
first like minute because I'm trying to
get 30 in a minute but then once we hit
uh puzzles number 40 and onwards it's
honor Ray Robson and you know gymnast
and all the guys who can actually solve
you my survival is at 72 though pretty
nice yeah yeah I heard Fabiano talking
about giving some puzzles to students
out there do you use puzzles at all when
you I know now you're now you're a
content creator so you're teaching the
world but was were puzzles a big part of
your repertoire as a coach yeah I mean
the more practical ones like Checkmate
in three or just combinations but
actually in general I would avoid uh
checkmating one specifically sometimes
it's just good to know like when to win
material and I mean the hardest one to
solve by the way in terms of a tactics
puzzle is whether there's a tactic or
not so sometimes I would set up
positions for students and go is there a
tactic here because when you go click on
puzzles you you already know there's
going to be puzzles but sometimes if
your coach said something else and goes
is there one at all you're like that's
one of the hardest challenges right you
don't have a bird on your shoulder in
real chess so yeah if you don't actually
know if there's a tactic makes a puzzle
a lot harder but all right before we
take our break a quick reminder again
that the SCC is back with 14 Superstars
confirmed the main event begins Monday
November 21st with participants
including as you see Magnus Carlson
arjunior a guy see Hikaru Nakamura Yanda
Palmer she Fabiana carwana he's here
he's playing there will be two more
qualifiers earning their way into the
tournament as well with 100K on the line
you don't want to miss the most exciting
speed Chess Championship we've ever had
type SCC in the chat use the command to
get more info all right much more to
come from day two of the cgc semifinals
as we push towards game seven maybe even
Armageddon matches who knows all right
in each of these semi-final matches
there's so much ahead twitch subscribers
we have plenty exclusive content don't
miss it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
we have a big Wesley aka Big Flex Lee
here look at him all right man I got
some questions for you so I've always
wanted to ask you we fresh off of the
Fisher random
how do we Castle Dewey Castle can we
Castle in check or or not what's going
on
yeah that's uh
I guess depends on what room but if you
look at the feeding and I got to feed
the handbook they figure King can move
if it's attacked ah okay right okay I
just wanted to be sure I've actually
done that myself you know the board
chest there so a little joke there from
the Fisher random favorite openings and
why I guess this
he usually like oldies okay all these
nice yeah how old 50s 60s yeah like 70s
70s nice that's interesting the
carpenter okay I'm not familiar of
course you probably are BG's okay the BG
fifth grade yeah they're definitely yeah
I also like uh Eminem I think okay
yeah of course yeah I'm from Detroit
right yeah so yeah I definitely love the
lemonade we appreciate you thank you of
course congratulations on all your
success and good luck in the tournament
[Music]
thank you
check out chess.com's newest mobile
release for Android and iOS now with
game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
be your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what are you doing there
nobody puts Danny in the corner
come over here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes my sister was born in Vancouver but
as wonderful as Andrea and Vancouver are
it's pretty tough not to fall in love
with the city of Toronto
natural beauty a balance inside Toronto
and pretty close by
largest city in Canada the people here
have been playing chess and clubs in
universities and in public parks for
well over a century
and now this wonderful place plays host
to the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks four of the
world's best players have survived to
continue their quest for the queen size
share of the one million dollar prize
pool ah okay they're not they're free
moving I guess there was a reason Knight
F3 doesn't work a draw is agreed by
repetition what a game
my friends you're in the right place
it's time for the cgc finals Toronto
Canada officially has it all just like
my sister and who wrote this garbage
foreign
that I can see around Toronto welcome
back to the cgc semi-finals inside we go
to the gameplay Hall that's the cgc
championship trophy which will be
awarded on Monday evening also to be
awarded the 200 000 first place prize
here's what we have given out thus far
rajaba sebyen Duda and on Drake and have
taken home a calm and cool 25
000 prize all right welcome and hello
for the first time today I'm Grandmaster
Daniel nerdinski covering games seven
and eight of these exciting semi-final
matches alongside me today Grandmaster
Amman Hamilton Amman so excited to be
commentating with you how excited are
you for these decisive two final games
of the semis well Danny I'm so excited
for these games excited to be coming
rotating alongside you I feel like they
they kept us away they wanted to save
the best for last oh they absolutely did
and they knew who was commentating the
last two games we will also have an
exciting guest dropping by pretty soon
but we'll get to that later right now we
need to get to the scores through game
six what you see in front of you the
match is both deadlocked at three points
at peace Geary and nihal sarin Wesley so
versus Hikaru Nakamura the stage could
not possibly be set for a more exciting
finale you couldn't script this any
better and you couldn't script the
anishagiri nihal siren match any better
they have gone back and fourth nihal
winning On Demand with the white pieces
twice now to level up the score as we
see Anish giri a dissatisfied Anish giri
on camera Amman he can't be happy well
Danny these matches have been going so
opposite of one another and that's
what's so exciting is that we have a
match that's level 3-3 that has been
neck and neck chess played at its finest
basically to Perfection you can't even
find the blemishes or mistakes that
these players are making when you look
at the other matches Whoever has the
white pieces seems to be getting the
wins so we have the same uh scores Danya
but very different matches and you
mentioned no blemishes nihal siren and
no blemishes in that previous game and
definitely no blemishes on his way to
the cgc semi-finals at only 18 years old
I'm on nihal sarin is just amazing we
can't repeat it enough I mean his resume
is impeccable it is and the thing about
nihal is he's such a young player but he
plays as if he's been through this all
before he plays with maturity and
experience and you you wouldn't expect
someone so young to have that quality
yet no you would not but now he has the
black pieces the game is underway the
openings have been all over the place
and finally we have we go back to home
base are we sure this isn't the Hikaru
so metromon yeah wait a minute I was
just talking about how you know that was
the match that was going neck and neck
same openings E4 E5 I think uh I think
we have the wrong match maybe yeah two
shape-shifters that we have here we have
a main line Italian Night pd2 by Anish
there's C3 I mean this is as standard as
it gets I wonder if nihal might have
expected E4 I mean that is what Anish
has been playing this match but nihal
straying from his D6 experiment hey I'm
on it worked once it failed the second
time that's right now he says let's go
back to something more conventional I
like this Choice by Neil sarin yeah he's
learned from his mistakes and the other
thing is you know it does a number on
you know your nervous system playing
these these insane games every single
round I mean it's finally time for an
e45 this is the first time I'm going to
say this in commentary but you know what
these guys deserve it I'll tolerate an
E4 E5 you know slower game Daniel the
first and the last now in the Hikaru
match as well as in the Italian as a
whole we have seen this B4 and A4 be all
the rage everybody's playing it now
Niche giving this a little bit of
thought the traditional way of playing
this line is to drop the bishop back to
B3 and concentrate on playing on the
king side rookie one Knight F1 Knight G3
standard fare but a niche going for the
modern approach there is that a form
move we see from everybody these days
yeah you'll often see players throw this
A4 out before B4 and before before
before before are you sure it's before
before okay and then continue you'll see
them go after before as well with maybe
the movie four to A5 and uh you know
this is just the Classic space gaining
mechanism on the queen side but as you
mentioned Knight F1 to G3 sometimes we
see the same thing from black it's like
hey great idea I'll do the same thing
you know a different way 97 Knight G6
and I think we might see both players
going for this similar construction yeah
and and the Early Middle game in the
Italian is often a a part of the game
where the players just sort of assemble
their pieces and their pawns on the
right side of the board you know the
puzzle pieces move around both sides
move their Knights a lot of sort of
Preparatory moves H3 H6 we see as well
Rook E8 and the first really committal
developing move that we see uh from
either side is either Bishop B3 or
Bishop E6 that's really the only
developing move I'm on that actually
quote unquote threatens to change up the
pawn structure or make a substantive
change to the position that it's the
only thing that actually does something
yeah that's what you're trying to say it
threatens to do something whoa you need
to take a step back here yeah because
you know you see moves like Bishop to A7
that was previously played I feel like
the stronger player you are the the more
ahead of time you put your Bishop on A7
like three yeah it's like I'm putting
that Bishop there before even the
concept of the idea of B4 before it even
played into your mind before would even
plays c three into four A4 and there we
see H6 by black Nicole kind of taking
his time in the opening obviously he
knows these types of positions very very
well but there are so many movers in the
Italian that you have to make sure that
your head is screwed on straight and
there we go Bishop B6 and a trade of
light squared Bishops I'm on that's a
big transformation it is we we have to
really wonder you know did they look at
the hikaranakamura and Wesley so match
because I think we may have seen this
exact position Daniel we might see
Knight to C4 Bishop to E3 you know if If
You're Gonna Play Bishop D6 it might be
time for me to challenge that Bishop on
A7 and White's going for the you know
Queen side expansion but as you can see
very level here and in these love level
positions you always feel like white has
that small small Edge but is it enough
yeah the engine always gives like 0.3 or
0.4 which is why these top GMS are kind
of addicted to the Italian yeah another
big decision that has to be made by
black this time is whether to push D5
now you might say well Black's already
played D6 but because the position is so
quiet you can often afford investing
more Tempe that you could then you can
invest in let's say a night ORF so black
can play this with a closed Center in
Rook aea 97 Knight G6 you pointed that
maneuver out if you want to play with a
little bit more of an edge you could
definitely consider playing D5 here and
in the next few moves and there's that
97 move like the Knight does need to
sort of get out of the way there's Pawn
B4 to B5 to consider and you never want
to be in a situation where you have to
calculate a move that hits your knight
in the middle of a calculation you want
to just get that out ahead of time
similar to that Bishop A7 move yeah
right and it's just you have nothing to
worry about now you can maybe even throw
in C6 if you want to play that D5 move
you can use a pawn to support it
conversely we saw Wesley so throw in the
move C3 C4 which yes it creates a big
weakness on D4 but Black Knights are not
really well equipped to exploit that
square you're not exactly going to go
all the way back to C6 and remember
white can play the move Bishop E3 on
demand he might even play it in this
very position he might play Knight G3
but you're right this this c65 idea is
definitely very very common standard
fare for black or black could Again Play
D5 without playing C6 it's often a
matter of taste the engine doesn't
really discern between these moves these
positions like four or five moves
sometimes that lead to approximately the
same evaluation yeah and even if you see
that evaluation bar you know differs
slightly between mood to move whoa point
four to point five out of the question
yeah look at your favorite player and
say oh and how can they possibly play
this move it's like no you pointed it
out it is just a matter of preference at
some point it's like how do you want to
handle the position what kind of
position are you looking for we see B5
here a little bit against the move C4
from white but also just annexing a
little bit of space for black yeah and
and there was a ticking clock on this
move because white very well could have
gotten that space permanently by pushing
his own Pawn to B5 you don't need to
play B5 and attack the Knight on C6
right that's a good Standalone move we
see an each keeping the tension moving
The Rook back to A1 and with black
Strokes now disconnected a takes B5 what
was once a liability becomes a potential
benefit for white if we consider a
random move by black after a b a b all
of a sudden white plays Bishop E3 and
there's trouble Brewing on the queen
side it's not that you lose the bishop
but if you play C6 when is the move Rook
A6 and after Rook A1 you actually might
lose the bishop the queen could also
slide to A2 I'm on this is the worst
case scenario exactly and guess what new
Hall did he's like I don't want any
anything to do with that he went back to
E8 he needs to connect the Rooks I was
gonna say like if you guys are trying to
understand Grand Master chess it's it's
this right here white played Rook to B1
Dania as soon as B5 happened went Rook
back to A1 and blacks oh you're
undeveloping a rook I'm gonna undevelop
as well
yeah exactly wow C4 by white you
mentioned that B5 was played against C4
I agreed with that he says I'm playing
this anyway in your face
C5 by black and a massive explosion in
the center right now I think C5 is is a
Nakamura Wesley so match enemy yes get
rid of the center as quickly Mass
liquidation but I feel like there's
still a little bit more life in this
position also what stands out to me is
that you know you mentioned the move C6
if you don't want to make a committal
decision you could also just further
support the b-pawn which is what C4 is
playing against yeah you definitely
could and there's a lot to think about
here because as soon as the center
starts transforming these are path of no
return kinds of moves so you need to put
in a lot of thought about how you handle
the situation in the center yeah C5
definitely a move that Wesley so would
play I think and you might very well see
Mass liquidation and a draw because the
structure on the king side is totally
symmetrical right I said the word
symmetrical that means we need to switch
to our other game which very well might
be symmetrical Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so deadlocked at three points a
piece they have drawn all of their games
not for lack of trying but when you're
playing somebody as solid as Wesley so
I'm on he literally is just the epitome
of solidity 29 years old no weaknesses
in his game none it doesn't it doesn't
appear that way and you know what that
is what you know this match is reminding
people of that it might seem like oh
it's deadlocked there's draws every game
it's not exciting it's the opposite this
is actually chess played at the highest
level Daniel that's what it looks like
yeah and you got to decide what you want
do you want a lot of mistakes that you
want back and forth blunders or do you
want you know incredibly high level
chess as you said I usually prefer the
latter that's what we have gotten and
excitement is guaranteed this match
cannot end in a tie there will be that's
right a winner and will there be a
winner in regular time or will they have
to go to Irma
sound excited whoa whoa whoa whoa a four
nights defensive mods Hikaru needs to
chill down he has to simmer down he's
taking way too many risks here he's gone
totally out of his mind with it four
nights yeah this is it's too much right
this this is too much Sriracha but
Knight D4 I like it you know Knight D4
it invites this move I was gonna say
Knight takes E5 and that can happen at
many moments this is something that goes
down a very theoretical path Danny it
looks you know to to me and and probably
people watching like hey I just
pickpocketed the center Pawn in the
middle of the board shouldn't that be
great for me but you can see that
evaluation bar hovering right around
equal because we're about to go down you
know explore territory we we are I think
the main move is actually D5 striking at
the center while white has still not
castled looking at this position you
might say wait a second couldn't white
have grabbed the pawn in F7 the problem
is that if you take it with the bishop
this is an important point to make yeah
White's pieces are not going to get out
of the center after King f8 you can
defend your knight but black just pushes
the pawn out to D6 and you've got to
choose which piece you're going to lose
so that's not good knight takes F7 opens
up the e-file in uh the worst kind of
way and I think the move D5 leads to an
incredibly strong attack kind of a
Traxler style exactly A variation so
Hikaru doesn't want anything having to
do with that he drops his Knight back to
F3 D5 is played and Knight takes D5
continuing to pocket the center pawns
I'm on yeah I feel like this is going
down that path where you know the only
explanation is that this is a
theoretical discussion at the moment
because some of these moves are actually
pretty crazy to explain you know Black's
giving up the e-pawn and the Deep on in
the center of the board and what are we
on move eight here Dania yep you know
Wesley doesn't look concerned at all no
no he and this is only and neither does
hicaro for that record for the record
that that must mean that they are deep
within their preparation within their
opening files and this is a famous this
opening that's existed now for
definitely over half a century Queen
takes E4 check yeah
I guess there is an alternative you
could start by playing Knight takes D5
and you might say well doesn't the
bishop take and defend the pawn but
again black could chase that Bishop away
with C6 and then play Queen takes E4
check these actually lead to
fundamentally different types of
positions of mine because if you take
immediately on e4 the drawback of that
move is that the Knight can and will
cover the check reserving keeping
White's castling rights alive for the
time being and that also defends the
bishop which is important to note
there's no we take C4 93 Knight takes F3
trick because the Knight on E3 is
actually you know doing uh two functions
stopping the check and guarding the
bishop so we will see that line on the
board Queen takes E4 Knight E3 and uh
Bishop to G4 Daniel
this reminds me of that Hikaru do the
game where they're blitzing out moves in
a crazy position yeah exactly this looks
like I will say this looks like fun for
black because you've got what is kind of
a dream position where you've got full
compensation in my opinion for the pawn
you're down upon but what you can do is
every chess player's dream this is what
you teach you know beginner chess
players hey bring the Rooks to the
middle of the board you get a long
Castle here as black Dania and then play
Rook H to E8 and you've got two Rooks
going right up the center of the board
it's beautiful yeah if you had to you
know have a Pictionary definition of
compensation it would probably be this
position like all of your pieces are
ideally placed Rooks on d8 and E8 yeah I
would not resist the temptation to
Castle queenside here I don't think you
should resist that Temptation now you
might see Bishop takes F3 as a
possibility but there's no hurry I mean
now you can play Bishop takes F3 because
if we pull up an analysis board real
quick D takes E4 doesn't solve White's
problems it fixes the structure but
black wins back the pawn and obviously
only black can be better in this end
game if white plays GF then the Queens
are still on the board and queen takes
F3 leads to an end game where Black's
pieces are so nicely placed but a
different course taken by Mr so I love
it he plays Queen back to E7 keeping all
of the pieces alive and now Oman I would
say that Knight takes G4 is a lot more
tempting than it was on the previous
move but maybe in the end game black
preserves his initiative and you know
the scary thing about this type of
compensation is you know a lot of times
what a strong player will do is if
they're in a tough spot they'll look to
give that material back they'll say okay
let me find a way to give you a pawn
back it'll be even material but
structurally maybe positionally I'll be
better I don't think you can do that
here Danny I think that if it goes back
to even material black will actually
have the edge so something like you you
mentioned Knight takes G4 I think after
a queen trade Knight captures back on G4
with you know the Rook coming to E8 and
the F2 Pawn loose you know Bishop E3 is
not that easy to achieve I think this
could be dangerous yeah this very well
could be you could try the move Bishop
B3 black plays Rook E8 and to piggy
about piggyback off of your grade point
Black's gonna collect the pawn on E3
he's not just gonna trade his initiative
and here here I'll be kind and give you
my no no
black is still going to be much more
active maybe white could play Rook 81
and hide the king away on D2 when the
time is right yeah but he this is not
what Hikaru envisioned with the white
piece is a slightly worse end game in
the penultimate game so he needs to
invest a good amount of time here to
make sure that he doesn't walk into a
position that's played for two results
and he tries to do that with the modest
move Bishop D2 but he has to develop his
Bishop at some point so he doesn't
procrastinate is this is the limit yeah
though this this does make a lot of
sense and I love the point you brought
up the penultimate game because going
into the last round you hand the white
pieces to Wesley so and if the match is
tied it feels like obviously
Grandmasters with the white pieces
they're already kind of playing for two
results so you don't want to hand that
opportunity to Wesley yeah no you you
definitely don't and Bishop D2 is on the
board Wesley contemplating whether he
should bring his Rook into the game Rook
he8 is the tempting move but you could
also consider dropping the bishop back
to H5 maybe Paving the way for the Jeep
on to I like that idea yeah yeah I like
Bishop H5 you know you eliminate all
these Knight takes G4 possibilities
maintain the bishop pair Rooks coming to
E8 and you're almost daring that white
king to make that decision which side
are you castling because I feel like as
soon as you let me know I'm like you
know a dog that the leash has just been
uh released and you know running running
wild I can finally play G5 as you
mentioned if you short castle Yeah
Black's got arrangements made no matter
where white skin goes this is going to
be a fascinating middle game and we will
keep a close eye on it but we have
another game that we need to update you
on because the middle game in nihal
sarens game against Geary has reached
the peak of complexity let's go to the
two board view I love this view you have
anisha's game on the right side of your
screen both players locked in
concentration what a rich position of
man Center tension tension on really all
sides of the board don't just think oh
this is symmetrical it's gonna be a drug
no Lots going on here exactly and and
pay attention to the you mentioned the
pawn tension right so we don't have have
just you know e45 and nothing going on
we have a Pawn on B5 that's attacked a
lot so much can happen here and the
players are you know currently holding
tight Daniel not committing anything
which means this is going to explode at
some point you were right by the way C5
is a Wesley move C6 is a knee-haw move
he loves these kinds of tense position
positions that's where he thrives but
I'm looking at the clock for the first
time he's five minutes down I thought
that might be what you were starting to
say yeah yeah no just a Time
disadvantage exactly Dania wow such such
an interesting position if only we had
another qualified chess player to
analyze this position horrified wait a
second as we dig into the game I see
someone in the we are thrilled to have
Mr Wrench jumping into the booth with us
to call these game sevens Danny welcome
aboard it's great to see you in the
commentator Booth thanks for having me I
I'm not sure I'm qualified I heard him
on hesitation I heard I heard that uh
hesitation in your voice yesterday you
and Levy were talking about mayonnaise
on sandwiches and things like that so I
figured that the level of commentary had
dropped to me so uh I was just gonna
jump in for a few minutes with you guys
it sounds sounds great we have the
expert on mayonnaise here with us thank
you Danny and the expert on many other
subjects you guys are crushing it though
no this is this is high level stuff I
love your point I'm on about C6 being a
nihow move and I think the tension
favors him if we get into mutual time
pressure but this much of a Time
disadvantage has me a little worried for
sarin yeah the thing about the C6 move
is when I say A Move Like C5 is a Wesley
move it's like the opposite of a slight
against Wesley it actually means it's
probably the best the best move yeah
that's what really what I'm saying and
C6 just seems like a more flexible move
like you know nihal is just that younger
player he doesn't want to just get rid
of all the possibilities in the position
I feel like he is always ambitious that
he can win any position and doesn't just
want to make a draw yeah go ahead I
wanted to make a point though that nihal
chose to play E5 in this game remember
game three yesterday after he won he
went for something kind of off beat
again and got pretty good chances as
black against the niche so when he
played E5 was that surprising for you
guys I actually feel like a niche is in
a much better spot here than he was in
the third game yesterday yeah it's it's
an interesting choice I pointed out to
Amman earlier that I'm not surprised he
didn't repeat the perk but I mean nihal
has so many different openings in his
repertoire E5 is I think a clear signal
that he wants just a fundamentally
healthy position out of the opening he's
tired of these crazy positions with his
King being weak he wants to offload the
tension onto the middle game and he's
gotten what he's asked for his position
is strategically healthy but he's
cramped and with his last move D3 D4
Anish signifies that hey you want
tension you're going to get it and
you're going to get a lot of it yeah I
mean what's going on here guys are we
gonna see white with a better position
and pushing for a win in every single
game in this match because it feels like
we've got more of the same first of all
as you're highlighting have a look at
that guys you don't see A4 B4 C4 D4 E4
pawns like that and it not be like a
meme position so this is actually a
legitimate move d4 breaking open the
center uh Danny a fan of White's
position are we I love it in fact I
think that the time is also reflective
of how comfortable the players are right
I mean that's telling us a little bit of
uncomfortableness for nihal but also the
fact that Anish is playing quickly means
he's confident right and at this point
white is uh I learned from Robert and
Daniel all the time if whoever's in
control of the pawn breaks usually in a
little bit more of control of the story
on the board and I feel like black
doesn't want to take D4 black doesn't
want to take C4 black doesn't want to
take A4 every one of those moves seems
to concede something so it makes it hard
for me to come up with the right
approach for Nihao I'm on you think I'm
crazy on that uh no this is like exactly
why I'm happy to be in the commentary
Booth yeah there's times like this Danny
because it's so hard to you know pick
the right Pawn break but also you've got
your time less than four minutes ticking
down and as white you have the luxury of
choosing whatever you want but it's
black one wrong move like that and you
could just have a worse position is the
idea here to remove the queen from
guarding E4 in some spots so that then
you take D4 and E4 is weaker but I look
at this move down you and A6 is weak the
moment white takes C4 so what what gives
I think the idea is to lure the queen to
C4 uh and then perhaps Counter-Strike
with D5 again the reason I'm here and
not there I don't want to calculate this
I'm going to let Anisha and nihal
calculate this white can just grab the
pawn on A6 we have the pawn cube in the
center I'm sure Chad is loving that but
the problem is that if you just sort of
blindly grab at the center oh let me
take this one and let me take that pawn
if you take that pawn then White's gonna
take on F6 and When the Smoke finally
clears just look at the structure that
passed Apon a huge asset in any future
end game white can do something as
simple as moving the queen back to D3
and I think White's got a clear
Advantage so it the idea might might be
largely intuitive nehal might say hey
I'm actually feeling pretty desperate
I've got 350 on the clock I'm worse I
need to change the nature of the game so
I'm curious if he wants to go D5 or
Danny if if he wants your idea with
something a little bit more calm he
takes D4 I don't think we should
overstate the case here I don't think
black is losing or anything of the sort
but he needs to be accurate the next
like five or six moves I'm on this
situation reminds me of something you
said when you were on the chair with me
which I'm going to get back to that soon
but you said now likes time scrambles
but that doesn't mean you want to get
yourself under time pressure right and
usually you play moves like B takes C4
in a position where you're like I can't
keep playing this amount of tension and
take three more minutes off the clock so
I have to do something but the more I
look at this I feel like we're not going
to see the storyline we had on day one
and we're more likely to get a decisive
result here yeah and when you look at a
position like I was supposed to say I
wondered if he was going to play D takes
E5 first because that looked like if you
could lure Black's d-pawn to recapture
then everything you just said Daniel
that whole great analysis like
everything you just put off your windows
out the window gone we don't have to
worry about it and uh you know to your
point Dan you want to minimize the
amount of variations and caveats that
you know are available in a certain
position when you have that time ticking
down oh yes we can be seven smarter to
keep the tension than if you're Geary
but Nihao quickly plays Queen B7
okay now Anish is back in the in the
driver's seat right he can play a build
up move right strengthen the space put a
rook on D1 or C1 or you can look to go
for something more concrete but my
intuition would say if you had to play
the bullet move you'd like you play Rook
C1 here you play Rook D1 right don't
give your opponent any help when they're
the one about to get under three minutes
obviously like the big elephant in the
room is d65 because that is a clear Pro
and the pros that it clarifies the
center as Amon indicated that the
negative is that it reopens Black's
bishop and they're most certainly are
some dangerous tactics with Bishop takes
F2 check and maybe they're real coming
to D2 if the Knight leaves F3 you know
this tactical potential becomes more
serious of a problem the lower on time
you get so yeah I would try to keep at
least a two minute time Advantage if
you're a niche but yeah he's deciding
between all these Canada moves and then
he's got the separate decision of
whether or not and when to take on E5
and you mentioned the word tactical I
feel like that nihal's ear is just
perked up yeah what yeah give them to me
yeah you know like if if I could turn
this e45 position where Nihao and Geary
both understand why it's probably
slightly better and if this could become
a tactical Skirmish as time gets lower I
mean nihal is is just uh you know
chomping at the bit we have I thought
maybe he perked up just because Donya
was using all the different colors there
you're so good with your fingers I get
trapped in just red and orange but
you're yeah I stay I could I stick with
the basics Danny bringing the board to
life over there hey I'm I Channel my
inner Picasso as I told Levy yesterday
yeah I'm developing my alternate career
as we speak Danny I love it I'm I'm
doing that with random random questions
on the street preparing for where I'm
going to be next um all right well what
do we think what do we think Gary does
here just Rook C1 man I'm a d takes E5
person I I'm very much in the like
strategically right if we play D takes
E5 unless there's a concrete follow-up
we're opening the bishop on A7 right
we're opening the default for blacks
Rook so I'm with you but I'm like that's
the move I I would not play as the lowly
I am here I would not play that move
unless I had a follow-up I would I would
be building on it so help me I'm on well
I was thinking that D5 from black is it
just gets into a total mess okay so
you're more trying to prevent
I'm against that I would add the D5 is
now a much more real it would go so far
as to say it's nearly a threat because
A6 is now protected by that was the
actual point of Queen B7 yes it was to
aim at the B4 Pawn but it was also to
protect A6 I second them on if you were
levium on I disagree just for the sake
of disagreement I'm Gonna Be Kind to you
as a fellow GM
on IM action and yeah at some point
you're outnumbered this is why we bring
Danny on here so we have someone to
disagree with and we can agree with each
other we have three people gets the
short end of the stick so I'll take it
what an interesting position the time
Advantage has drifted all the way down
to 60 seconds now and each continues to
ponder this critical scenario Danny
thing's getting more tensed by the
second we're gonna be in for another
time scramble this makes me happier if
I'm a knee-how fan right every second
off the clock for Gary because even if
I'm worse as long as I get that Mutual
time scramble that I do so well and
maybe only Hikaru in this field is
favored over nihal and that type of
scramble yeah I mean now that it's like
four minutes to three minutes I I think
he definitely made the right choice to
take because if black gets that D5 move
in everything's gonna explode and all of
a sudden you know Nihao certainly
favorite as things get into time
pressure but he did your move right this
looks actually pretty good and gear did
it with confidence it wasn't just
Illustrated once took with the bishop
immediately puts the Rook on C1 here
comes that Knight to F5 exactly how how
is nihal gonna defend because now he's
just clearly structurally worse yeah
he's got these two weaknesses the
Queen's doing a good job of supervising
them but he needs another piece which
pieces are going to be it's probably
going to be the Rook The Rook is
actually the only piece hypothetically
capable of Defending C6 but it can do it
from three different places two
different Rooks can defend the pawn I'm
predicting Rook E6 I think Rook D6 walks
right into Knight F5 I don't see the
Rhyme or Reason behind that one you
could also consider not defending the C6
Pawn the problem is Queen takes C6 Queen
takes before the queen captures on A6
the last thing you want is to give white
that extra ape on because then you're
playing for a draw until the end of
Eternity there's also some nice ideas
where if the knight's on F5 and those
types of exchanges happen in the end you
have this little Knight takes H6 shot
the F6 Knight is a little tender so
there's actually suddenly those looming
tactics where like the Knight comes to
F5 there's there's more for black to
worry about than first meets the eye
most certainly and let's go to our two
board view because the other game is
also heating up our eyes darting from
one side of the screen to the other
Hikaru Nakamura has the white pieces the
match deadlocked at three a piece and we
saw Wesley a very exciting response to
hikaru's four nights sacrificing a pawn
he still has the bishop pair Hikaru has
decided to Castle queenside and by
contrast there's a lot more time on both
of these players clock it's a completely
different type of position and we see
Hikaru taking that other Knight off of
the board I'm on help me make sense of
this such a complicated position on the
right side there yeah indeed and you
know what has to be noted is that in
that last little flurry of exchanges we
now actually have the the real two
Bishops against two knights on the board
but that one extra Pawn on D3 Dania that
is what Hikaru is gonna try to you know
milk into a larger Advantage right now
it's an extra Pawn but a lot of
compensation but the more pieces that
get traded the Bishops aren't going to
mean that much in just a pure end game
down a pawn but in a middle game where
the king can be targeted Queen A4 comes
to mind you know A2 I think if if the
Rook trade was proposed by Hikaru here
Wesley might play something like rook d8
and say nope I actually want pieces on
the board I'm glad we got to touch on
this one before I bounce and let you
guys finish because this is by far the
richest game that I think these two have
given us over here we've got Bishop here
versus Knights the extra Pawn Dynamic
and everything that you just highlighted
about on with the light score Bishop on
F7 spying at the white king this is this
might be the game I think this is a coin
flip game despite what that eval Bar
says it can be a little evil and
misguiding at times yes White's better
because of the pawn but from a practical
perspective especially if this game
reaches Mutual time pressure the tactics
are just are just nutty here for black
yeah the bishop pair I mean it's
inherently an asset but it's especially
an asset and a position that's this open
the center is open yeah Queen D5 I
pointed out is a big threat which means
that Knight takes G7 is not possible I
think Queen D5 hits the pawn that's a
mate threat because the bishop covers
the king's Escape Route most importantly
the other night is also loose in a
position like this with two Bishops
against a rook those are the worst two
minor pieces yeah uh to play against if
you're the side with the Rook so Hikaru
has a threat that he needs to address he
sees it there's a lot of ways that he
can address it and he does so by chasing
the bishop out of B4 he kicks the can
down the road guys I think The Bishop's
coming back to f8 I think Wesley just
wants to eliminate the headache of the G
seven fun even if it's not an immediate
threat that's the bullet move just
played Michigan Right exact bullet I'm
on it right he's taking his time because
you have to calculate Queen D5 just to
make sure there's nothing else to that
but I I agree Bishop of Fate seems
simple renew that double attack of Queen
D5 hitting the pony in the A2 square but
I don't know it feels good doesn't it
like yeah like you just feel like you're
a strong player when you get to play a
move like Bishop to f8 you know covering
uh G7 uh getting the bishop out of
danger so uh that game as we see is
actually the most imbalanced as you
pointed out Danny so we'll definitely
keep an eye on that but Daniel we've got
uh some actions some things developing
in the other game look at the clock
nehals out at 28 seconds so you're right
I'm on the Hikaru game is unbalanced on
the board this game is the most
unbalanced on the clock but look at how
nehal has fixed this position the queen
side pawns visited the orthodontist yeah
he somehow exchanged the C Pawn for the
B Pawn yeah it got some Invisalign that
Queen up to A6 pinning The Rook on B5 E6
E5 is defended so is this worth it
Daniel would you say that getting rid of
those you know positional uh let's say
weaknesses weaknesses yeah I'm looking
for a much nicer word
you know I think Daniel's orthodontist
have had me going down the wrong path
but would you say that you know being at
20 seconds but not having the weaknesses
is that worth it because the time is a
major factor for and Danny for anyone
but yes I was just going to complete
that we complete each other's sandwiches
we did I was I was literally gonna
answer them on the same way I would say
for a lot of other players maybe not
because you are weighing time is not
material but there is some mathematical
evaluation to the value of time in Rapid
Blitz and bullet especially but yeah for
nihal he will take a Scramble with
increment against anybody in this in
this field and if you've made your
position better he'll take 20 seconds on
the clock given that he gets two seconds
added per move everybody so that's not a
pure 20 seconds yeah Gary has bungled
this and the mathematical consideration
I think for Newhall it's reverse like
with less time he actually starts
playing better he goes Rook B6 so he
offers Gary trade Queen takes it but
that's not a draw for after Queen A5
Rook B5 black still holds the upper hand
look at that battery against the F2 Pawn
I think Anish should take on A5 I think
he should hunker down bring the queen
back to A2 and I think his chances of
holding this are very very high given
the Halls clock but he's got a couple
more accurate moves to make but my
prediction is that this game is going to
end peacefully but it's a good point
that he doesn't need to trade Queens if
you're if you're nihow despite what
other people might see when they look at
this it's 50 50. I've got 20 seconds I
think nihau smells blood in the water
right he's a great white shark when it
comes to these moments because he's one
Gary offer to draw oh Gary that shows
you who wants to get out of this game
more right Gary's like ah why don't we
call this he might take it dude he's got
10 seconds yeah he's got 10 seconds okay
he does all right as Danny was saying a
great white shark sniffing out that draw
offer yeah well he smelled blood but I
think a niche that was the right time to
offer the job because even though they
took it let's remember there's a reason
Anisha offered it yeah right so even
though ultimately I believe nihal had
the edge if he kept playing yeah yeah
all right well that takes them to a
three and a half tie score once again
but it's just like yesterday they start
with wins respectively as white they
draw their third game of the day is
anybody gonna make a break through I
might have to go give Anish a hug uh if
it means he's gonna break through I
think you most certainly will they are
down to their last game and the way
nehal has played with the white pieces
my goodness does Anish have his work cut
out for him as we see the players
intensity concentration on their faces
and butterflies in their stomach as they
get ready for the next game but we have
one more game still going
hikaranakamuran Wesley so are still in
the middle of their wildly exciting
seventh game yeah what's Happening Here
H5 I'm on that's the kind of move you
make when you have the bishop here
because the more weaknesses you create
on both sides of the board the higher
the chance of tactics right so sometimes
you play a move like H5 not just to
undermine the Knight but to maybe poke a
G4 because you get these positions in
time scrambles where if you can attack
two things at once Something's Gonna
Fall yeah complicated position Bishop
moves to E6 but with Geary and siren
complete Danny I'm afraid we're gonna
have to send you back to those booths I
blacked out for a second I was like
where am I I'm gonna be here right when
it is getting comfortable yeah he was
just getting settled in Danny it's so
fun to have you on set you're awesome
thank you thank you guys the the talent
here is overwhelming so I appreciate you
playing along with me and letting me sit
in for a minute I'm going to get back in
touch here all right Danny thanks again
we're gonna keep watching this seventh
game in the semi-finals both matches
currently tied Anisha nihal making a
draw is this game also going to end
peacefully Iman Danny made a great Point
wait I can still say that with Danny in
the room I think so there's any
compliments though
exactly this is the most unbalanced the
position has ever been in their first
seven games yeah but still it's not like
going to be decisive necessarily no it's
not like oh there's an imbalance uh I
guess we're having a victory no not at
all you have to remember that like this
this imbalance is well it's called an
imbalance for a reason it's it's a night
uh and you know at that extra Pawn but
the Bishops are so lethal I mean black
can win this game just as much as
whitecamp this isn't white with an extra
pawn and you know playing for a draw or
a win Daniel not at all but you
mentioned lethal I think the Knight on
D4 is as lethal as it gets if black
plays the move Bishop D6 right now white
can play Rook F3 because the bishop
blocks the queen but Rook F3 runs into
Bishop takes A3 yeah there's those
lethal Bishops again but instead I think
Hikaru has cooked up the devilish Queen
G2 wow exploiting the weakness of C6 and
if Bishop F4 Knight C6 oh you're in huge
trouble yeah this could be really mad
nasty here are we getting night I was
gonna say Knight A7 you can always start
with right you can start with it you
also have to move 95. that's what I was
looking at this looks like oh this is
cooked right this is done this is done
because if the queen moves the Knight
serves the Queen's purpose and Queenie
it is still check me the Knight controls
D7 what an idea and we instead have hg4
and queen G2 is still blade yeah I was
gonna say you sounded disappointed with
hd4 and then
possible Queen G2 is an amazing idea but
he's decided to meet it with Bishop E8
so definitely a more passive approach
for Wesley but he's trying to say look
this is temporary I'm stopping your idea
eventually I'll boot This Night Out D6
Bishop E5 and then I can move my Bishop
from E8 but now Hikaru is saying this is
temporary his Knight is booted he can
move back to E2 but then he's gonna be
threatening F4 and move the Knight right
back to D4 so we've got a lot of back
and forth Wesley is saying that that's
temporary because after the night goes
back Bishop goes to G6 and hits the rook
and you can't go f but then white saying
that's ever because F5 and put the
bishop back up
all day night the other night moves to
E2 so C5 C5 is a tempting move it kicks
the Knight out of D4 but it weakens the
king side even further I think well the
side in which the king is on I think we
should avoids in King's side queenside
technically that's the queen side but
I'm On One sort of dream scenario for
Wesley is to move this light squared
Bishop to C6 even if white doesn't keep
uh the queen on The Rook on this
diagonal that's a great spot where the
bishop controls a lot of squares kicks
The Rook out of the center and protects
the king I think that's what he should
be aiming for here yep and the issue is
that you know to stop a move like F4 you
have to play a committal move like G5
but the structure starts to become one
that favors the knights more clothes
right you see that F5 Square it's a
perfect anchor Square for the net on D4
to go to and if this ever gets to an end
game you wish that you didn't play G5
but in this middle game and with all the
tactics that we've been highlighting you
kind of have to you have to because the
position is so Dynamic that you can't
even really think about long-term stuff
you need to think about the short-term
threats yeah G5 is on the board Hikaru
is up a minute on the clock for car
that's a big deal that's a big time
Advantage I don't think Wesley should
allow his clock to drop really below a
minute as long as they're still in the
middle game so the ball any car was
scored the move that comes to my mind is
94 to F3 yeah you move the Knight away
from the center but again you boot the
bishop out of the B5 so it's always this
balance like do I keep my pieces in the
center or do I use my pieces to kick
yours out of the center yeah and I think
it's really going to revolve around
whether black can get that Bishop to C6
you mentioned how important that square
was and Hikaru Nakamura is you know deep
in thought here he's looking for the
moves the interesting thing that I'm
noticing about some of the variations
we're calculating Dania is they they
never seem to be trouble for Hikaru it's
just whether or not he can create
something yeah because he has no
weaknesses the Bishops have no targets
to attack the Bishops are good in this
position Wesley trying to find some
targets to attack that's right the only
targets are White's pieces there's no
pawns to attack you actually have to try
to use the Bishops to pin the knights to
hold them in place Bishop F7 is an
awesome awesome move by Wesley he just
finds an alternate airport to fly
through
D5 like we were talking about C6 but
really in essence we just wanted the
diagonal I mean all of a sudden Bishop
F7 Bishop D5 and he's got it he's got it
I think he's gonna play it right now
yeah Hikaru could pick up the D6 Bishop
if Wesley does that but I think if
Wesley were to preserve one of his
Bishops there's no question in my mind
that he wants to keep the light squared
Bishop yeah the bishop on F7 is like the
actual artifact and the bishop on D6 is
the replica yeah where it's the the
frame that the artifact is contained in
yeah the Mona Lisa you want to keep not
the frame that it's any he wants to keep
them to keep the frame if he wants to
keep the frame but she's gotta have a
nice frame for the Mona Lisa you most
certainly do you can't have anything
else I like Bishop C5 yeah Wesley's
playing for a win here I think that's
what that move signifies to me yeah and
it it also signifies you know not just
Bishop C5 I'm playing for the win
because of Bishop C5 no it could be any
move Bishop f8 even I think he just
wants to keep the pieces and you know
Bishop pair I always say Daniel that's
like a long-term investment just having
it just holding it is where it actually
becomes valuable that's very very true I
should point out that C4 is always out
of the question look at that D3 Pawn you
cannot afford for that pawn to be taken
and the bishop another twist Bishop
comes back to G6 because D5 was defended
by the Knight and again Wesley showing
just a categorical unwillingness to give
his dark squid Bishop up even if it
means allowing his other Bishop to reach
the long Diagon we also could get some
sort of a repetition here like bishop
and I think he caught would be happier
at this moment at this point yeah I
think that it's it's changed enough that
now that Rook Daniel is in front of the
pieces we always say that Brook's gonna
operate best from the back because a
long range piece right The Rook can
exert pressure on E8 from E1 or E4 and
he goes for a sacrifice and I think that
speaks to the fact he was not enjoying
his position as does like his body
language this isn't a sacrifice like
yeah I'm sacrificing an extreme and
getting all these squares the knights
are fully capable of handling themselves
in this position I don't think black is
winning especially given the queen Side
Pawn structure but now Wesley can read
the sigh of relief yeah he can play this
position out for a while I really don't
see a scenario where Wesley gets in any
kind of trouble here so the the only
point I'll make against that is we
remember it was almost Hikaru playing
for a win
yeah against two Rooks in this exact
match and it was Wesley who suddenly had
to bail out so I will say I can
absolutely see hikar winning this if
this was like a bullet game and guess
what we're down to a minute each I I
would say Hikaru is definitely playing
for a win you're just agreeing with me I
thought we made a deal Danny's not in
the boothy I'll give you a slide for
that you forgot that without getting me
out yeah my bad we forgot now I let's go
back to our old friend I still think
this bishop belongs in the long diagonal
and so does Wesley so yeah Bishop to C8
on the board he's gonna swing his Bishop
over to B7 what is the point of that you
might look at this and say well I don't
see any squares on this diagonal worth
occupying it's more that you're
restricting the knights you're stopping
Knight D5 and you're keeping your king
safe for the long run which means that
Black's Queen can now swing over to the
king side and start attacking the F
Dupont which is exactly what he does
Wesley's making progress here he is and
he's playing it really really well what
was scary to me was a knight getting to
E4 Dania then it would hit the F6 Pawn
hit the C5 Pawn instead Bishop to B7
covers that and white snakes are nowhere
near the E4 square instead they're on
great squares but they're not able to
attack anything he's also just forced to
Queen trade what a move by Wesley Queen
H1 that's right yeah he's got the check
that's another benefit of the bishop on
B7 I mentioned there aren't any
important squares in the diagonal now
there are Quinn H1 is basically a
pre-move yep and once the Queens are
traded then the knights will have a
really hard time without that leader
without the queen to bind them together
will they be able to handle both sides
of the board against Black's
bloodthirsty rook and I think the fact
that black can sort of establish a
bishop on F3 means a lot for this
position you might see Rook h8 Rook to
H4 Rook D4 you can even jump the gun and
do that straight away and he does and if
he loses that pawn we might see a hikara
headshake here because oh man can he
hold this position together after Rook
F4 and Bishop takes G4 how do you keep
this I actually think it's crucial to
start with Rook F4 which he does look at
it precisely yeah because if he had
taken on G4 first the Knight would have
jumped out to your Square cutting off
the rook and actually winning the the F6
Pawn that's a great point now you're
taking on G4 or White's got to trade off
one more night and we know that when
you're up in exchange every single minor
piece rate favors The Rook side that's
right and you know it's all about the
the king side pawns here Daniel those
Queen side pawns for black they're going
nowhere right they're just on the board
merely to you know satisfy material
equality or something like that because
it's all about winning that g-pawn maybe
the F Pawn and black creating a pass
Pawn supported by his Rook which he now
is guaranteed to do to add insult to
injury if you take the bishop
blackstroke takes back attacks F2 and if
the Knight drops Back The Rook moves
back to F4 yep and the Knight can't
guard F2 and G4 at the same time you are
desperately trying to create counter
play on The Queen side but all he's done
is fixed Black's pawns further that's
right although it was a very interesting
move actually he was daring black to
take on B4 and then he would cut the
Rook off but instead Wesley stayed
focused he said look the most important
Pawn to win is on the king side he's
done just that loses another Pawn but
then he picks up F2 he picks up F2 now
he's got a passer on F5 this is on the
cusp of being winning the game not over
yet but he covered down to 10 seconds
and Wesley has kept himself with 40
seconds on the clock to convert this
advantage and it's push time that's
right he needs a dark Square block eight
he needs a knight on F2 if he can get
the Knight on D5 to the F2 Square that's
gonna be it yeah he needs to travel all
the way back I like to move Bishop F3
here that actually forces the trade of
knights but Wesley goes C6 obviously if
Hikaru wins this password that's the
worst case scenario for Wesley Knight
two knights and three pawns against Rook
bishop and two will be a draw that's not
enough if the pawns are on the same side
wow Rook G1 the patience to play that
move he doesn't want to advance that
pawn Daniel because then the king might
get to E3 you have to be very careful
don't let white control the dark squares
in this position yeah it's not a race it
usually is a race with a pass Pawn here
you want to push the pawn under the
right condition see car is going to try
to get his King to D4 again the point is
to meet F3 yeah with King E3 now his
strategy Wesley could adopt is to shove
The Rook to B2 at the right moment to
distract White's king that's right but
King C3 right now comes with Tempo
Hikaru is holding on he's doing what
Hikaru always does amazing resilience
good defense oh my God
one
um night back to F3 has Rook G4 but he's
got Bishop G4 oh
but is that resulting position to draw
it is I think it might be a draft or
Bishop takes F3 Bishop F3 takes date oh
Rook F2 is unbelievable oh and now he
goes 95 and he's gonna win the bishop
King E3 he's gonna be temporary down a
rook but Wesley's gonna win the B4 upon
rook f8 and Rook V8 or Rick f400 could
be one yep and I don't know how to
evaluate this position he's gonna have a
pass day pawn this has to be winning
yeah my instinct say this has got to be
winning he's got a pass Pawn that the
king cannot touch right the Knight has
to bring itself to the B file and act as
a shield so that King can walk over so
the king can walk over it also can I
don't think he's got time to do I think
he's got to use the Knight now to stop
the pawn but how is he gonna do that and
he resigns and Wesley wins with the
presentation and I mean this is probably
dead in the water but that was still an
early resignation with me we know how
resilient 94. actually I think igoro
missed that he could go 94. we're gonna
wait and watch the reactions on camera
yeah I think Hikaru could have continued
the fight there I absolutely do but you
know in the end he made his decision he
did resign that game and now the lead
with only one game to play is 4-3 for
Wesley so this is the last thing we
expected for black to win a game Wesley
is up 4-3 Hikaru with a must win game in
game eight you can see a dejected Hikaru
there the opening experiment I'm on it
just didn't work out and Wesley met him
at the top with that pawn sacrifice yeah
and just to take that position and
understand look you're down upon but the
compensation is Raging you've got the
bishop pair and he kept pieces on the
board Queens Rooks and that was
ultimately what led to him converting
that game yeah that was incredible we're
gonna check in on both of our match
scores the Anish Gary match is still
tied everything is going to be decided
either by the last game or if it is
drawn by the Armageddon and Wesley so
jumping out to a one-point lead Amman
This Is A Feast for the eyes A Feast for
anyone who likes chess what an awesome
game eight we're gonna have in both
matches indeed and you know what I've
noticed Dania that we've never had the
same result in both games concurrently
so we we've had draws in Wesley Hikaru
and then all of a sudden we get a win in
that match and of course you know as the
universe would have it it is a draw on
the other match as well so it's always
back and forth with these matches and of
course we're gonna see game eight in
both of them just a testament to how
close these semi-finals are yeah they're
gonna be wildly close and the Hikaru
Wesley game was close all throughout
we're gonna hit on a couple of important
moments so Amanda you had this very
interesting imbalance with two Bishops
against two knights you don't have that
every day Hikaru has a pawn uh in in
return for Wesley's Bishop pair and the
real the trouble started when you
pointed it out hikaru's Rook went ahead
of the minor pieces right if the Rook
was on E1 in this position we'd be
singing a completely different tune but
with Bishop G6 that Rook starts feeling
really uncomfortable and I think Hikaru
kind of panicked in this situation he
could have come back to E4 but I'm on
right he sacks on C5 thinking that
Wesley's ruined Pawn structure will give
him long-term play on the king didn't
work out that way no and I think you
said it best when it happened this
wasn't a Hikaru Nakamura confident
sacrifice this wasn't like I've
sacrificed and now I'm playing for a win
no this was an uncomfortable and a
decision he didn't want to make so he
could have gone back but he obviously
didn't want to draw there must have been
something Daniel that he wanted to play
for more so he was being a little bit
ambitious with this as well I think he
made a concrete mistake I think he
missed or underestimated this move
Bishop C8 and once the bishop gets to
this long diagonal Black's King is now
safe and Wesley was able to trade Queens
on H1 Hikaru defended valiantly and at
the very end let's go to the final
position for a second just look at that
I think Hikaru could have played Knight
E4 and what I think he missed is that A4
Knight C5 threatens a fork on A6 I think
Wesley's still winning after rookie
eight but he would have had to work hard
for it after A3 Knight A6 black does not
promote his Pawn White's King is just in
time to stop it here actually white is
winning but he must have missed that
there was a way for him to play Knight
C5 Dania and actually get that Rook off
the B file because if you look at it the
B file cuts the king off that's too much
I think he he just missed that otherwise
we know Hikaru Nakamura he would have
kept playing he absolutely would have an
uncharacteristic early resigned but the
fact remains Wesley so wins game seven
in improbable fashion what a game what
Precision by Wesley so all throughout
but folks let's get it back to Danny and
the gang in the gameplay haul to break
down these two fascinating games as we
get into the final game Danny take it
away
OMG sir snaps guys we do have drama not
maybe the kind we were expecting thank
you for being with us reminder of who we
are now joined by Grand Master Robert
Hess fide Master James Canty U.S
Champion Grand Master Fabiano caruana
I'm Danny wrench guys let's dive into
the scores quickly set up where we are
for those who might just be joining us
we have a deadlocked tie again between
Gary and Sauron but we now for the first
time time have a decisive game in the
match between Wesley so and Hikaru
Nakamura it is Wesley so striking with
the black pieces no less okay guys uh
quickly I want to get to you fobby and
get your reaction on that moment the
critical one where Hikaru Nakamura chose
to play Rook take C5 rather than accept
the repetition right wants a decisive
result but did he lose his patience a
little bit I think so the thing is the
entire game he was directing the action
yeah he chose the opening he surprised
Wesley a bit he got a good outcome in
the opening of a pawn for compensation
but still some sort of Advantage free
Karu and then once Wesley had equalized
and it was time for a repetition he
wasn't able to adjust he still wanted to
be ambitious and he played too riskly
Rook takes C5 it might not be a terrible
move but it's just too risky under
circumstances and things just spiraled
out of control for him after that Wesley
played a brilliant move Bishop C8 and
that was pretty much the deciding move
of the game after that Hikaru was in a
desperate situation quickly Robert over
to you so you think Hikaru was getting
frustrated with all the draws himself do
you think he misevaluated something
concrete as Donya is suggesting with
Bishop C what do you think happened
there I think he's frustrated that
Wesley's the man who will not be moved
yeah I mean Hikaru is used to bullying
people James used that term throughout
the last few days Hikaru he enforced his
will on his opponents but Wesley so is
somebody who more than maybe anybody out
there he is stoic he will just play the
position and he showed that when hitkar
goes for speculative sacrifice he will
punish it as much as we like the script
reference we can definitely say this is
not scripted right what do you say
Hikaru Nakamura has to do now to win
with black and send it to Armageddon
well he gonna have to play uh if his D4
we play in King's Indian and if it's E4
we're playing some type of Cecilia
something's sharp we need to get in here
we need to swing of course and he did
break a little bit there obviously I
mean it was the patience trying to have
some patience with every single game
being a draw you just bumping your head
I'm always winning not every game's a
draw I'm tired of this and then he took
too much of a risk there this last game
got it with oh man well we're going to
see if he can do it as some of you may
know our friend James Canty with that
hot take has also been hanging out with
our with our players he has a pretty
good sense of humor and can be a little
bit of a prankster isn't that right
James Ah that's true that's true check
out this uh this earlier time this week
I discovered that you can't rip a
Canadian dollar bill did you know that
did you guys know that did not maybe you
keep working out
[Music]
this is a Canadian ten dollar bill right
so I want you to touch it here you see
the trophy you see this yes if you you
can walk away with it if you can tear
that bill
all right there you go yeah go ahead try
it oh this is some kind of joke yeah rip
it go ahead try to rip it go ahead try
it come on world okay what is the trick
to this champ now he broke the king so
this was he might be able to rip this
you know what I'm saying look at that
look at him look at that look at that I
can see already do that right here on
this side smells like syrup and Duda
come on Wesley come on actually don't
dare me okay wait okay okay
you can rip it
that's a strong man look at the straight
you see it he tried he couldn't do it
but can I like it
some kind of magic trick or something
yeah interesting it's uh it's
indestructible but it has not always
been like that yeah I've definitely I've
definitely ripped a couple of the drinks
she can't rip it and I'm gonna take that
back really appreciate it thank you
thanks thanks Wesley yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh-huh
yeah yeah we'll be here we'll be here
okay I ain't got to watch one you know
that okay we're back after the
commercial today
that was hilarious that was a that was a
fire take there and apparently you also
can't set them on fire is that true uh
in fact I didn't know that so we're
gonna try that in fact don't try that at
home but we are going to try that but
how much fun was that watching those
guys I love that I love the effort the
dude was putting on and then Sam told my
Samuel you're a big boy you know just a
little Bill and you're a big boy let's
rip it come on he couldn't rip it he was
trying and I'm like yeah yeah try again
do some push-ups real quick come on we
can do it apparently being as strong as
you isn't helping so I fear for those
players they're gonna keep going after
days and days yeah but apparently it
wasn't always like that I don't know if
that's true or not have you ever tried
to rip a no but have you seen this thing
where like David Blaine rips an entire
phone book in half no yeah there's like
that technique if you bend it a certain
way I don't know if that's not gonna
work with the bill but with a phone book
you can you can rip an entire phone book
in half yeah great great analogy there I
I've seen anything where you can rip an
apple in half but um
all right before we take a break another
quick reminder from our sponsor Brave
means private browsing and so much more
by default Brave blocks ads and trackers
on every page and video visits even on
YouTube no ads means up to three times
faster page loads you know the drill
it's faster streaming and faster
playback it also means 35 longer battery
life while saving on mobile data and
internet bandwidth for Android iOS and
desktop get the best browser for gamer
streamers and creators all you got to do
go to brave.com chess it takes 60
seconds to switch
all right guys as Donya would say oh my
lands we are headed to game eight in
both matches perhaps in the balance a
spot to the cgc championship match
twitch subscribers we have plenty of
exclusive content so stick around during
the break we will bring it to you you
don't want to miss it and we will be
right back
[Music]
thank you
thank you
are you ready for the trivia questions
no but let's do it anyway who is the
current prime minister of Canada the
current prime minister is of course
Justin Trudeau perfect I didn't have to
run through the
system okay
okay so if it's not Trudeau anymore then
I'm done which of these is Toronto's
hockey team or if you already know you
can just let us it's I mean of course
it's the Maple Leafs thank you okay I
think because there are two Maple things
I'm going to go with the maple one
that's how I passed my final School exam
as well Maple Leaves correct who is
Canada's top rated chess player
Alexander
well unfortunately I played him last
week so I know the answer it's of course
of getting bereave I'm not sure about
but everything to be honest so no one is
getting younger and oh okay
okay I also he's not as good as he as he
used to be so
um but um I guess that didn't happen
which of these celebrities is not
Canadian so I knew the first two are
Canadian so it must be danger but you
see a celebrity though
oh why well I would like choose between
dragons and then you guys like I can't
see any of them being Canadian to be
honest and then maybe they're both Drake
is actually like the icon of Toronto
this is the trick question I'll go ever
living
obviously it's uh Danny Ryan but I think
his singing skills are someone behind
the other contestants
the strongest play if you ask me is
gonna it's gonna be bishop and Kevin
I've got Queen Jew now let me get my own
gal let me get my own let me get my own
girl
it's mine you know some of the things
that he see I don't understand how he
see it but his mind just kind of works
on another level
but I've been I've been introduced to
this game since I was six or seven years
old and I'm 58 now [ __ ] sit right there
man there's so many different locations
they play the game at
the third one is the heartbeat of the
game that's the heartbeat of the game
and I that's how I kind of try to view
it
didn't let the whole world know that
this is happening in Houston it's well
overdue
that's that's something that's been
really my dream since I started chat so
I'm you know that's my purpose that it
ain't so much to win I love winning
though I ain't gonna lie in the game
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to Toronto and our coverage
of the cgc semi-finals we are heading
into game a the final game of each of
our semi-final matches we will begin
with Anish giri and nihal sarin in just
a moment but first here is where we sit
let's review the scores through seven
games it's all deadlocked in anisha's
match against D Hall but Wesley so with
a shocking Victory with the black pieces
has jumped out with a one point lead he
leads four to three and Hikaru in a must
win situation it's been a pleasure
commentating the cgc thus far I am here
alongside Grand Master Amman Hamilton
Amman
I have no words do you have any words I
also have none all right honestly Danny
what can we say we're getting into a
game eight but a very different one for
both matches one of them could decide
the entire match and the other one is a
big comeback that's necessary for me
karnakamura or we're not going to see
any Armageddon we aren't and we
certainly hope to see some argument
against we see Anish giri and nihal
sarin some Inception uh action there on
the screen in front of us Anish speaking
of Anish he's got a tall order he needs
to survive with the black pieces but
he's got the pedigree and the experience
level to do that we see his path to the
cgc finals he has so many tournament
victories 2021 Titus steal arguably his
most impressive performance of mine if
anybody can do it it's Anish giri yeah
you said it best Dania but although he
has so much experience he's such a young
chess player in essence so I mean he's
got this experience but you know I don't
feel like we don't give him enough
credit for being at the top for so long
no he's perennially underrated but he's
struggled with the black pieces and I'm
so excited to see what we're gonna get
it's been such a mixed bag in the
opening unlike our other match from the
Berlin so we got in one night F3 by any
Halls art and Geary starting early he's
already thinking he responds with D5 D4
and we're gonna see a London here yeah
we kind of are this is like a modern
version of the London I'm on if only we
had a London specialist here who could
explain these first few moves Bishop B3
if a London specialist uh shows up
Danielle I'll definitely let you know
okay um but for the moment you know
what's interesting to me is that Nihao
Saran is bringing out so many versions
of the London it's not just a trademark
D4 Bishop F4 you know he had that very
interesting win that he pulled off
against Geary where it started as a
London but it just got weird with C4 and
now he's even played Bishop E3 this is
like what you tell London players not to
do yeah this is the mouse lip London
system and of course the idea is to
fiend Kettle the other Bishop you can't
bring it out to this diagonal E3 is
illegal and Anish immediately trying to
exploit the drawback of the move Bishop
B3 he sends his Knight to G4 for but the
bishop calmly drops back to D2 and Amman
when you have this structure you almost
always see the kind of action where
black plays A5 and sometimes white plays
A3 there's stuff going down the a phone
the question really is number one does
black get to win the pawn back but
sometimes black doesn't even try to win
it back and black tries to get
positional compensation on the queen
side it's a dangerous path though
because you can often end up just down
upon for nothing exactly and I think
when you play these positions with the
black pieces you have to go into it with
a willingness to play down upon and not
everyone has that some people do this
thinking oh I'll get my Pawn back then
all of a sudden white just clings on for
dear life and Black's uncomfortable
because they're like wait I'm not
getting this back you're not always
supposed to and B6 is a perfect
illustration Daniel because I mean Pawn
takes on B6 is already a consideration
and yes that's a full extra Pawn it's a
full healthy extra product and he's just
not trying to win a pack but just as a
sample after CB which I don't think
nihal is going to play that eagerly
Queen A4 there is an interesting
alternative but after takes takes let's
say like castles again no way that black
is winning the B4 upon back but black
can play A5 anyway and after B takes A5
I don't know what Black's gonna
recapture with let's say the Knight look
at White's pawns they're in a terrible
State Black's threatening Knight B3 and
Knight C4 Queen B2 I mean White's entire
Queen side is in shambles which is
ironic because that's where White's
extra Pawn is we see that it doesn't
tell the whole story finally black
center very very healthy that pawn chain
in the center another reason that black
often has at the very least full
compensation practically speaking for
the pawn a month so I think anisha's or
neho is going to have to handle this
with a little bit more finesse that's
right and you know what he would love to
do after the move B6 is you know he
would love to consider move maybe B5 you
know B5 and the Knight has to move is
being attacked and then follow up with
the move C6 oh because then you know
you've got your protected pass Pawn I
know it's early in the game but
protected pass Pawn on C6 and this is a
long-term thing that you're just trying
to hang on to and say look if we get to
any sort of end game Dania I'm gonna be
winning everything
but I think the problem is that black as
this bishop takes the five move
punishing white for not castling BC and
after Bishop takes F2 King F1 I think
black can just play this down a piece
just drop the bishop back to C5 and just
look at the state of White's pieces the
state is pathetic the Knight is coming
to F2 the other Bishop's coming out to
A6 again it's not that black is
checkmating white on the next move but
the compensation is long-term this is
the last thing you want in an ultimate
deciding game where you're not having
any fun okay nihal sends the Knight away
and then does take on B6 it's kind of a
yeah smarter move order I thought maybe
he might send the Knight away and then
consider B5 oh because then that kind of
gets the best of both worlds but instead
he decides to take maintain that extra
Pawn but the movie A5 is happening so
the question is do you want to play a
move like maybe A4 preemptively so that
after A5 you can play Pawn to B5 another
protected pass Pawn I mean this is just
the theme I'm over here trying to get a
protected pass pawn and hang on to it
for dear life they're like protected
that was all yesterday uh that that's
you know call me maybe as people were
listening to that and having keep Tahoe
Blue stickers on their laptop but I
think white is another way of preserving
the pawn on B4 and that's what the move
Bishop E3 the queen moves back you get
the Knight out to D2 and all of a sudden
after A5 you play a move that you can
almost never play in these positions A3
is always supposed to be bad because
after a b The Rook is hanging right
guess what it's no longer hanging now
the queen is linked up with The Rook so
I think this is an option I'm on I love
your idea to push A4 preemptively to
meet A5 with B5 again I gotta mention
the protected pass Pawn yeah apparently
that's not what the cool kids do I I
like I like the way nehal has handled
this I I don't know if I'm seeing full
compensation here due to the inclusion
of this move H3 right but the one thing
that we are seeing is the time
difference right he's really in the
think tank here because you know you and
I are looking at the position but he's
also looking at it without knowing hey
did Anish prepare something devilish for
me and the last thing you want in a mod
it up match three and a half three and a
half is to go into someone's preparation
in fact we've already seen what happens
when nihal does this in this very match
yeah this this mattress featured some of
the most creative opening choices really
by both players and some of the most
impressive preparation and the nature of
the preparation has been different for
Anisha spin he's going to principled
lines and he's punishing trying to
punish knee-hal knee Hall's going into
dubious variations and and he's just
offered a draw wow and nehal declined it
did so did he decline it with them it's
always important with the move did he
decline it with the move or did he say
no decline no thank you no he played
Bishop E3 like a step back would you
Governor I prefer to continue
I'm not sure if if he did but it looks
like he used the move so that's the more
professional I remember when I when I
offered to draw in one of my first ever
tournaments I don't know why I have this
vivid memory of my memory for you he
said no way he didn't just say no thank
you I'd like to continue he's in no way
and he did proceed to beat me to his
credit
um there's no way that man grew up to be
Danny wrench that's exactly no actually
I'm on Hamilton little did you know
Queen to B8 it's always an interesting
you know you play Queen B8 and I think
it looks awkward in a way because you're
putting the queen in the middle of your
books right it seems like at some point
you're gonna have to move that again but
Black's position is flexible enough that
I think what he wants to do is play A5
Daniel but he wants to control B5
because of drum roll protected passport
possibilities doesn't want to allow Pawn
to B5 yeah no that's exactly right and
again this is the moment where Neil has
to make the decision between A4 and
Knight bd2 and that's why we see him
thinking I am impressed that he declined
the draw but I am not surprised nehal is
a fighter he has that Killer Instinct
and right now he's saying hey I am up a
pawn I don't really see the compensation
outside of yeah you have slightly better
Center control I don't really care about
that because that pawn on C3 serves two
purposes it protects B4 and it also
controls the D4 Square which takes a lot
of the sting out of the move E5 which we
might say in Niche play anyway yeah but
it's not quite as concerning so Knight
bd2 or A4 is is on the docket and I
think the the result of the opening is
flat out a success for Newhall indeed uh
you know he's got that extra pun and
he's somehow found a way to get his
Bishop to E3 and it's not going to be
harassed by anything until we see E5 D4
that's many moves away White's gonna be
castled and as soon as Knight D2 Knight
B to D2 happens that's when I feel that
white has sort of reached that opening
success because as you mentioned earlier
then The Rook is protected so all of a
sudden you have A3 to defend against A5
and then you really feel like you've
gotten an extra Pawn Yeah already a draw
for declined a solid Advantage for nehal
sarin as we enter the middle game in
this game but we're about to start
another game Hikaru Nakamura is in a
must-win territory against Wesley so
Wesley leads four to three a draw does
not satisfy Hikaru and speaking of
Hikaru let's review his game card the 34
year old Juggernaut has built up such an
impressive career Amman right now he's
got his back against the wall for maybe
the first time in like the last decade
yeah exactly that's a great way to put
it and that speaks to his success both
recently and in this competition this is
the first time in this event Dania that
Hikaru has actually felt trailing like
that feeling for him it just hasn't
occurred he's actually behind in this
match and needs to win which means that
this match is what we expected it to be
it's gonna explode now yep it's like a
basketball team who won the championship
and now stands three and seven the game
is underway Hikaru not only with a
must-win game but also with the black
pieces and we have the societally
prescribed method of playing for a win
of the black which is of course the move
one to G6 it's the only way it's really
the only way we saw we saw Sam Sevin
doing it against nihal we saw nihal
doing it against the niche although it
wasn't really a must-win game but he had
a one point deficit and now we see
Hikaru we're gonna see a transposition
to a king's Indian here for Mr Nakamura
and just to expand on your point a
little bit and sort of clarify to
everyone watching you know what do you
mean when you say why is you know G6 the
way to play for win it just doesn't
commit anything into the center and
allows a lot of flexibility there's so
many setups Black can go for G6 a very
reserved approach you can couple it with
D6 Knight on C6 Pawn on C6 Pawn E5 Pawn
C5 it's up to you how you want to
continue and you can shape your game
based on how your opponent plays and of
course the other you know main reason is
that it does avoid a lot of theory and
you know if it does go that King's
Indian Direction Hikaru Nakamura is you
know a specialist in his own right there
he is and a lot of people might forget
that Hikaru was the leading King's
Indian specialist in the early 2010s he
actually defeated Wesley in a very
famous brilliancy and I think the reason
Hikaru started the way he did you might
ask well why didn't he just start with
the king's Indian move order he wants to
avoid the exchange variation that's why
he's bringing his night out to D7 first
so that when he plays E5 of course
Wesley could still capture on E5 but
that won't lead to a queen trade winning
an exchange variation against Wesley is
harder than I don't know a name
impossible tasks certain possible task
here yeah um completely agree and that's
why you know you you see these strong
players why do they get to a normal
position in the you know the most tricky
way possible with detours the most move
order is imaginable and that is because
they want to avoid something there's
maybe a good line against it a queen
trade that you uh mentioned Dania they
want to avoid that in this case
obviously with hikarnakamura having to
win on demand he needs his Queen on the
board he absolutely does and that's why
he's brought the night out to t7 now he
circumvents the main lines of the king's
Indian where the Knight goes out to C6
so he does commit himself in that regard
and I think what Wesley is thinking
about there's actually two things I know
that you can try to punish Knight bd7 by
pushing E5 early this is a move and if I
remember correctly the line goes
something like takes takes I'm going
from old King's Indian analysis back
when I used to study openings and now I
can play this very thematic move E6
you're sacking the pawn but you're
ruining black structure and you often
follow up with Knight G5 that's a double
attack against the knight in the pun but
black can defend all three things at the
same time I say three because there's
also a fourth possibility on F7 would
move Knight D to E5 and you might say
hey now I've got a queen train draw but
this isn't quite the same end game this
is an imbalanced end game and I think
Hikaru is more or less fine with that
but if I remember correctly White's
supposed to be better here as well and
guess what Wesley has just pushed D5
yeah and it's something like you know
there is a reason at the end of the day
why certain openings have their
prescribed move orders right no no no
you know like there's a reason those
best moves are there because they've
been tested and one of the reasons why
the Knight doesn't usually go to the D7
square is while you're kind of looking
at it right here Pawn to E5 and pawn E6
that wouldn't be possible if that Knight
was back on B8 the bishop would be
covering the E6 square and certainly
after Pawn takes on E5 the queen from d8
would hit the queen on D1 so this is
something that white has you know
available only because of the way
hikarnak armor has played that's why
Wesley just took a pause and said wait a
minute you're not gonna you know you're
not gonna have your cake and eat it too
you don't get to avoid everything from
me without committing something in
return and well he's allowed you E5
that's precisely right you close certain
doors but other doors are inevitably
going to open and Wesley has just opened
one of those doors with the movie five
and I think he's showing the kind of
fighter that he is Wesley isn't just
going to kind of cower in a corner or
hope to trade all the pieces passively
he's actually going to take to Hikaru in
the best way we talk about this all the
time the best way to make a draw on
demand is to play for a win Right Wesley
isn't mine also winning this game it's
like winning doesn't win in the match
darn it I won so he's playing the way he
normally is in Hikaru we see him
refraining from The Exchange on E5
precisely because that led to that
unpleasant endgame Knight G4 straight
away but I'm on now Wesley could send
the Knight to Timber 2 with the move H3
I I think after H3 first of all this is
not what hikara wanted from no no no uh
he wanted to just get castled and avoid
that you know E5 Queen trade line
instead what's happened if Wesley has
sort of gone for the throat here he's
saying look I know exactly the reason
why what you played doesn't get played
more often and it's five so he's going
right at him I think we'll see H3 pretty
much immediately by Wesley he's probably
just double checking but H3 kicking the
Knight back to H6 that never feels good
especially Daniel with that fianchetto
situation because not only is the move
E6 maybe still available but look Knight
is getting permanently trapped on the
side of the board with G4 and that is
such a thematic that's just a nasty move
to face it covers the F5 square and to
make boundaries even worse if you think
they could be made worse they can be if
black Castle's in this position white is
a very simple plan this is like as old
as the hills white plays Bishop E3 let's
make a random move for illustration
purposes white plays Queen D2 and the
Knight is literally trapped because that
yarn King is covering the Escape Square
on G8 now you might say hey after Bishop
E3 you're blundering the pawn on E5 well
no I'm not because F50 E5 that Knight is
literally the bane of Black's existence
now you can't take twice because the
bishop has to babysit the Knight on H6
so I would almost argue that this
position is close to being borderline
lost for Hikaru that seems like a strong
statement but I do agree with you Dania
like people need to understand that when
they're watching this game G4 this is
not just a one move thing it's not just
stopping Knight F5 yeah it's it's
actually intending as you indicated to
play Bishop E3 Queen D2 and win the game
outright so all of a sudden the onus is
on Hikaru to deal with that and he's
dealt with it in you know the most
astounding way Knight back to G8 I I
can't even criticize the move to be
honest like he wants to play E6 bring
the Knight to E7 but Daniel he's going
to be playing off the back foot he most
certainly is and if there's one player
that I would Bank on being able to play
from the back foot as successfully as
possible it is indeed Hikaru Nakamura I
mean the amount of times we have seen
him pull out wins from the most
improbable of places from the worst
possible openings I mean he won an
entire title Tuesday playing one G4
there was another guy who did that who
she'll go unmentioned so Hikaru is used
to this he's used to operating for
maximum in these types of situations the
problem is that the worst kind of player
to do that against as well Wesley so
because he's not affected by these weird
moves he's just gonna keep playing like
a buzz thought that he is yeah he's just
gonna always look and find for the most
part the best move in the position
exactly you know usually when you mix
things up get this unorthodox position
Knight G8 you're behind it moves you
kind of want your opponent to also be
like oh what the hell are you doing man
H4 H5 E6 right and also try to play a
little loose but Wesley generally to his
credit doesn't play like it doesn't fall
into that trap of you know playing like
the opponent instead he just sticks to
his own game plan you've highlighted it
I think Bishop F4 is a great start
instead he goes Queen E2 but this kind
of indicates he might be looking to push
in the Center Way quicker than
anticipating no this is an incredibly
ugly position for hikar and it's getting
worse I think Knight G5 here might just
that threatens Queen F3 four king A8 and
epic and although Knight G5 is tempting
what about ese like what has he called
this is that makes E6 not desirable here
because Queen E2 I thought that was the
main idea I think Wesley is spoiled for
Choice I'm just gonna show this really
quickly we will get to the other game in
a moment guys but this is this is very
very consequential Knight G5 and E6 we
are getting word that nihal star and
offer to draw let's go to our two board
view if that's possible because both
games are rapidly unfolding right now
you can see on the right side of your
screen nihal sarin with the white pieces
accompanying the move Queen C4 with a
draw offer of his own you can see that
Anish has successfully among created
Counterpoint on the queen side is he
gonna take that draw honestly you know
you start to it's a bit of psychology
Daniel you have to remember that he
previously offered the draw so he wanted
that right he this is the result he
wanted and then ultimately he played
well enough to earn it and deserve it
nihal you know relinquished some of his
advantage and I think fairly satisfied
is giri on screen there is you know that
match is now going to be going to
Armageddon I might be overstating the
Casey Ricky kind of dodged an opening
bullet I mean yeehall kept that extra
Pawn if he managed to consolidate he
would have been just solidly better so
Anish you can literally see him
breathing a sigh of relief they're
taking a sip of water the the Arbiter
Judith coming over to warn the players
that Armageddon is about to happen and I
used Warren for a very good reason this
is going to be the ultimate Armageddon
with hundreds of thousands of dollars on
the line yep no the the match is now
knotted up and you know uh Anish giri
now has played not only the most but the
only armaged in the event he might be
the only guy look at that four to four
after what was you know back and forth
action wins with the white pieces wins
with the white piece I felt like every
game was a masterpiece and it ended with
two draws in the final two games Daniel
yeah that was a balance match but not
balancing the Hikaru sense where they
made a draw every game balance in the
sense that both players played so well
can't wait for the Armageddon but we'll
have to wait for the number again
because we have one more decisive game
that is in progress Wesley so is on the
cusp of moving on to the cgc finals
hicaro in total crisis desperation mode
he has undeveloped all of his pieces
just look at this position it's ugly
it's nasty is there any cons isolation
any chances for Hikaru to pull out not
only a draw Ammon that's maybe the most
depressing thing of all he needs to win
this position that's right and that's
just what's so incredible here because I
think you know in all fairness Hikaru
dodged a bullet over the last couple of
months I thought that moved Knight G5
and E6 that was winning to the point
where the the eval bar was creeping very
close to the top of the screen that's a
serious Advantage we barely had moved 10
Dania instead he's got a position where
yes he's much worse and yes he needs to
actually win it however he's still in
this game and I couldn't think of
someone else on planet Earth that I
actually would want in my corner to
possibly win a game from a position that
honestly looks Dead from the opening
we're looking at plus three Daniel yeah
and plus three for by all intents and
purposes a massive massive evaluation at
this level but this is a rapid game
Wesley is human as weird as that sounds
he's gonna be getting nervous he's down
two minutes on the clock so if you could
construct an improbable narrative for
Hikaru to win this game I think it would
definitely involve Wesley's clock taking
down as Wesley tries to find that killer
blow right maybe he fails he gets into
time pressure we know how tricky Hikaru
is even when he's literally operating
from his two back ranks he doesn't have
a single piece past the second rank it's
move 13. Wesley's controlling space and
he's controlling both sides of the board
that really matter look at the D file
and look at the king side Wesley could
send this h-man up the board the moment
Black's gang Dives onto the king side
yeah and the only Square that's really
available for Hikaru to place his pieces
maybe C5 but you really have to earn
that square you have to move your queen
you probably have to support it first
with A5 so you don't just get booted and
evicted out of that C5 Square straight
away and I mean that's like two to three
moves just for Knight C5 yeah what about
like the rest of your pieces oh black is
fine yeah all right not at all you got
your knight to C5 I'd also point out the
F6 Square which could be a very juicy
Outpost either for white tonight or for
White's Bishop the most obvious path to
me and involves doubling on the D file
the move Rook D2 here has to be
seriously considered I'm sure Wesley is
considering it yeah after Rook D2 black
must move the queen away white doubles
on the D file and if black plays this
move Knight C5 you pointed this out hey
you signed a 12 monthly no you did
before evicted get out of there and once
you move to A6 this is deja vu we saw
the other night on H6 now we see this
night on Asics are we gonna have to do
the same thing on the other side of the
board yeah Knight C5 and you just get
booted out immediately it feels like
you're at the catch register trying to
play and your card is declined and of
course they say it as loud as possible
yeah I'm sorry sir you're gonna have to
leave and you have to go back to A6 you
mentioned it we just saw this on the
other side of the board how many moves
can he car on a camera waste and still
be in this game you can't develop the
knights out to their normal squares then
bring this to the side of the board then
back to the starting square and out
again that that's just not how you play
chess listen chess has changed in the
last few years but there's a reason that
principles exist and development is
necessary you mentioned move order being
necessary there's a reason that you
can't play a game of chess with all of
your pieces on their initial squares on
move 15 yeah and Wesley has played Rook
D2 he still has eight and a half minutes
on his clock I think we're gonna see
that line unfold yeah he might actually
go I was gonna say Knight B8 is that
crazy oh no he might as well get rid of
it now why do the whole like you know
jump in circles thing okay Bishop C6 is
his choice he defends the Knight on D7
B4 still looks Mighty appealing here
that threatens B5 evicting the bishop
now from C6 and that Knight's gonna be
captured immediately and is the only
reaction to the move B4 Knight B8 like
how how do you deal with B5 because I
agree with you looks so strong I think
there is a tiny Silver Lining after B4
Hikaru could play the move A6 and if you
rush B5 then after trade black actually
puts the bishop on E5 and this changes
the landscape completely once you get
this Square White's entire D file plate
dissipates and White's King is weakened
so this is a big No-No for Wesley
instead I think you can play the simple
move A4 that's right to recapture with
the a pawn maybe Hikaru can Castle here
open up the a file and try to get some
desperate counter play I don't really
see it happening neither is Wesley he's
played before and you might might play
A6 but after A4 the other thing is
Wesley is by no means committed to B5
now you can play King B2 H4 you know
just about any move that comes to mind
so there's no rush if you're white and
that's I think that is what is the
underlying issue with the position it's
that Hikaru can sometimes react to the
immediate threats and deal with them but
he can't deal with the long-term fact
that Daniel what is he gonna do past his
own sixth Rank and let me ask you
another question after Asics white plays
Bishop G5 how is he gonna castle where
is he gonna put this Knight how is he
going to defend he's gonna bring the
bishop back to f8 yeah I mean at some
point he's just gonna get strangled in
the center I like to move Bishop G5 also
because once you trade the bishop for
the 997 that old friend B5 once again
becomes possible because black loses
control over the D5 Square after Bishop
D5 with the Knight gone from E7 white
can just capture twice and reopen the D
file with devastating effect okay so
Daniel it's it's clear that this is a
disaster position but the fact remains
that Hikaru Nakamura needs a point right
he needs a full point from this position
so I'm gonna flip it on you Yuri Karnak
were in this position how do you even
dream of staying in the game here
because he's up on time about two
minutes now and if you take that down to
let's say 30 seconds to two and a half
minutes all of a sudden you give
yourself a real chance what does he need
to do here well you follow the famous
advice shared by Magnus Carlson after he
beat Hikaru many years ago from a lost
position he said a phrase that sounds
like a cliche said you just try to
survive one more move and I think the
reason that's so valuable is because of
how true it is the moment you take the
bird's eye view and you're like well
what do I think the evaluation here is
right you just become depressed I mean
the evolution is plus four but if you
focus on staying alive and keeping all
your pieces together one move at a time
then you increase the likelihood that
your opponent gets frustrated the
problem is that Wesley is playing like
an engine right now yeah this strategy
and this advice all of it falls apart
under the condition that your opponent
plays perfect moves you can't fight an
evaluation like to that degree if
opponent plays The Right Move guess what
the evaluation is going to say the same
or it's going to increase and here what
I was just looking at was isn't he
threatening Bishop takes easy exactly
and B5 E5 and your idea Bishop D5 which
was so strong a move ago that's not the
case anymore at all I can just rip that
piece off Knight takes D5 and I mean
Danny is in that position just winning I
would say that that's as close as to
game over as we have been I'm a little
bit concerned that Wesley's taking as
long as he is it might be the case that
he's just double triple checking maybe
he thinks this is too good to be true
the one thing you want to avoid at all
costs is dropping the bishop back to H4
this gives black a new lease on life
lets Hikaru pushes Pawn to G5 then move
his Knight out to G6 and if you're
Hikaru all you need is the tiniest bit
of real estate on one side of the board
you start untangling he's up three
minutes on the clock so Wesley needs to
keep his foot on the gas pedal literally
Bishop takes E7 you could also start
with B5 if you want to be fancy but one
way or the other that Knight has to has
to be gone right now and he didn't play
Bishop G5 to bring it back to age four
it's not like some big idea that he's
concoct oh my Bishop's better on H4 and
G3 no he's following up the way he
intended B5 comes in and the thing is he
car Nakamura such a strong player he
obviously knows this is coming but as
you said you can't fight the evaluation
hikaro hasn't blundered further this is
just this best thing too and you need to
win this let me remind people Hikaru
cannot draw this reality that actually
might be what makes this comeback least
likely if he had to draw this we've seen
any cars saves these save these kinds of
positions yeah oh oh my God look at this
Rook takes D5 and the Knights coming
into C6 and I think that might be the
death now once that Knight reaches C6
and The Rook comes into d8
we saw Hikaru resign a little bit
prematurely in the last game he's
obviously not going to resign here
there's just nothing to lose he leaves
Toronto if he loses this game he's
trying his best he's tucking his King
back to f8 so he hasn't gotten
checkmated just yet and he's got the a
file now as perhaps the first legitimate
source of counter play he's had all
games so he's still going to be kicking
exactly do not whoa whoa Rook to D.A oh
my God what a move what a move I don't
know how good that is but I'll tell you
I love the look of it Daniel that is
just a flashy move it is but it's not
good it is but it's not good he wins the
queen that was the idea to follow up
with Knight C6 he could have also
started with Knight C6 would have been
the same exact thing he's won the queen
but but but Hikaru has a rook and a
knight he's gotten the Knight onto C5
and he's entrenched it on that square
it's a great night I think what Wesley
is saying is hey I don't need to win
this game he believes that his losing
chances in this position are close to
zero I disagree with that I actually
think that black now has the best
winning chances he's had all game if
this bishop wins the E5 Pawn if this
Knight gets around to D4 Wesley needs to
be careful in this position I get what
he's doing yeah but he needs a little
bit more Precision you agree with me I
just cut a look that Hikaru gave
basically the webcam and remember these
guys are facing each other he kind of
looked up as you would in over the board
game and said like whoa all right you
know you wanna you wanna do this let's
go and Hikaru is now playing with a new
lease on life as you said total
confidence because Hikaru understands
his chances have never been as good as
they are right now I'm rarely one to
criticize harshly I'm the commentator
again there's a very good reason the
players are there I'm here that was a
really really bad decision by Wesley
even if he saves this game there's no
reason to do that he could just play F4
yeah and I'm not just saying that
because of a plus four evaluation I mean
that's just a totally dominant position
I think Wesley jumped the gun here and
now he's beginning to realize that this
isn't just a flat out draw no Hikaru
plays G5 we mentioned that move earlier
in the context of chasing the bishop
away now it's played in the context of
preventing F4 and I think Rook team five
and for the first time we're talking
about just a double edged position yeah
and and Wesley hasn't messed this up no
no no no but the thing is it is trending
and remember chess is also a momentum
game there's a game on the board and a
game off the board these guys are also
trying to get in each other's heads he
call right now he was head bobbing a
little bit there he knows he's got
chances the imbalance material as well
Dania these top players they don't play
queen against you know Knight and Rook
with Bishops on the board of obstacle
they don't play that all the time so
they're less familiar with how to
convert that advantage or even how to
maintain it yeah Hikaru is up three
minutes again let me be very clear I
still think there is a very high
probability that Wesley doesn't lose
this game yeah I think he might have
overlooked the move Bishop takes E5 it
doesn't have to be The Rook that capture
captures on E5 in fact if it is The Rook
Wesley is hanging his hat on Queen F3
threatening Checkmate if the Knight is
forced back to E6 he is taking that
faster than I accepted the draw for that
would lead to my third norm and now I
think black's winning chances are
greatly limited he car not gonna wear
doesn't miss chances when you give him
more than one of them Bishop takes C5 is
on the board if you take the Rook you're
in a worse end game that's right so you
know at this point after Bishop E5 it's
interesting you might think Bishop takes
Rook Bishop F4 Daniel is you think of
this line it's Bishop against Knight and
yes it's all even pawns but that's
actually an end game where first of all
I think there's gonna be a lot of people
that are ready to help play you but yeah
Nakamura is first in line yeah I mean
this actually might be the most
practical decision now that I look at it
a little bit more carefully after King
D2 Bishop E3 it's not entirely clear
what you take with King E3 King E7 I
would definitely take black here the
Knight is such a nice piece but it might
just be the case that white builds a
fortress I mean these pawns are very
well defended the king can reach D4 is
this the Wesley decision not really this
is kind of manka s i mean you've got
three minutes and 20 seconds you
mentioned the trend this is like the
first time in the game where you
actually have to utter the word defense
Right Wesley would prefer to keep his
extra Queen but how does he do that does
he move his King up to C2 and allow the
bishop to move to F4 three it's now on
the clock to hikaru's almost eight right
this is getting concerning it is and I
think this is going to be an incredibly
exciting finish this isn't just you know
up a queen and can draw at will oh
Bishop F4 he pre-moved that by the way
he did that was it that was awesome he
pre-moved Bishop F4 he's gonna do it no
matter what guess what this Rook can
come in Rook D4 oh my gosh I am very
scared if I'm Wesley so because the
black king does not appear to be in any
serious danger and when you have the
queen you have to be able to hit
something whether it's the king or some
puns you need targets no Rook d8 was
Wesley going to a restaurant just
choosing the first item on the menu I
mean that sounds good you have to review
all of the items in playoff four he's
regretting it just about now with every
ticking second all of these threats of
forks on D2 and checkmating patterns
your enemies grow larger by the second
the bishop is attacked you can see the
evil of our dropping all the way down to
even I haven't liked a single decision
Wesley's made in the last like 20 moves
and the thing about even is that it's
far from you know
0-0 means that Black's better as you
just said because remember White's up
material so if it's even according to
the engine that means black has enough
compensation and I think what we're
going to see in the next couple of moves
as I as I expect is that might even go
lower and lower and More in Black's
favor yeah Knight E4 it looks really
good here threatening the fork on D2 but
also setting up as I pointed out earlier
a lot of these mating patterns after 94
white could play the move King let's say
up to B2 the funny thing is if you move
up to the C2 Square black as Rook D2
check and one pattern you always see in
these positions is that the Rook has
access to a whole set of scores it
doesn't normally have access to because
of the power of the Knight right rookie
two a great example of that you take you
get fourth you don't take it you get
forked The Queen Is Almost strangled the
bishop could drop back to E5 yeah I
think people get the point you don't
have to look at the concrete ideas to
just get the sense the blacks pieces are
so well coordinated here and it's so
easy to play a position where every
piece you have is anchored Knight on C5
Bishop F4 Rook D4 yeah the dark squares
are blacks for the taking and that's
because of the presence of opposite
color Bishops so as we get a position
Daniel that gets lower and lower on time
Wesley is going to be I think he's going
to be making mistakes eventually this is
absolutely unbelievable if Hikaru pulls
this off I know I say this a lot but
this is actually the most actual the
insane comeback of all time obviously
he'll have to win the arm again let's be
very clear if he car wins this game he
doesn't win the match we'll just have a
second Armageddon but this will be the
most improbable Armageddon of all time
Rook D2 check and rookie two I think
puts black squarely in front for the
first time in this game yeah how the
eval bar is beginning to reflect that
and he might have looked more at Rook D2
check Daniel King B1 Rook D1 but
actually that move does not work as well
because white has a bailout option of
taking with the bishop yep and and
that's opposite Bishops that's not what
you need you can't draw the game we've
been through that so Hikaru right now
he's going to use that time of it he's
got six minutes to two if this gets any
lower on time for Wesley I mean it's so
difficult to keep up with all these
pieces and all these threats and since
icaro has this much time I want to take
advantage of that and show your line
that's a really cool idea Rook do you
want a clearance sacrifice and a
deflection rolled up in one if the queen
takes there's a fork on C3 if the bishop
takes there's a fork on D2 but Hikaru is
fighting two enemies at once this is
what you're saying one enemy is Wesley
so that's already enough for most people
he's also fighting the anti-draw enemy
where he can't just make an objective
move he has to make the move that keeps
winning chances alive that's why we see
him investing this much time he knows he
can't allow the transition into an
opposite called bishop and Gammon I
think you nailed it all right he carved
down to five minutes yep be tricky
though he's trying to generate not just
a move as we mentioned a lot but an idea
series of moves something that's going
to throw him off instead he goes back
Knight to C5 is it finally time to you
know get this queen involved because I
feel like the queen on F3 blocked by the
bishop on F4 that's just you've got your
best piece doing nothing but on the
other hand it's blocked by the bishop
it's also blocking the bishop because
the bishop stands between the queen and
Checkmate on F7 you're right though
Queen C3 played now he can go back to F3
at some point Wesley's gonna have to
accelerate his face he is bleeding time
and now he's under two minutes so hikara
might be taking the approach of hey
Wesley's nervous he's spending a lot
longer than he normally would agreed
that's not up for dispute let me just
try to milk his clock down let's say to
a minute and then I'll raise the
possibility that a curveball is actually
going to lead to a blunder he's got to
win a three-time repetition though he's
got to be careful about that is he not
gonna I think he wants Bishop D4 and
Rook F4 this is like a great
construction The Rook F4 covers the F7
Pawn oh my God the bishop on D4 covers
the checks on the long diagonal to a
King on G7 I think he's achieved the
perfect setup almost but Wesley has the
move F3 hanging by a thread there Bishop
D4 F3 and that pawn is really really
safe he goes back to E4 Yeah you
mentioned got to be careful with those
repetitions you can lose track in your
mind about how easily because you can
get to the same position by different
moves yeah especially when like your
pieces are mostly toggling between the
same set of two or three scores we've
both done that and you jump out of your
truck wait what yeah hey why'd you stop
the match bro exactly so Rook F4 I think
might actually lead to a repetition and
now a third enemy has entered Icarus
might he's got to avoid the repetition I
thought he should have gone rookie two
check when he had the chance he might be
regretting that right about now yeah
Rook D2 rookie two was nice but he made
the decision to bring the Knight back to
C5 and as you said just sort of milk the
clock a little bit let's get this same
position
two minutes down the road yeah let's not
get the same position three times in a
row exactly let's get it you know less
than three uh two minutes yeah this is
like a math equation exactly and wow
Hikaru well the math of the match is
that he has to win this game to force
Armageddon he really he might be
counting the moves actually can I play
Rook F4 here because that's the move he
wants to make right I don't know if
there's an alternative The Rook that's
already what he decided and if you try
to rewind the other way with Bishop F4
that might also lead to a record between
C3 and you know all of a sudden you'll
have to also be careful that that h8
square isn't available to White Queen h8
Queen F6 these sorts of moves all of a
sudden the bishop on B3 is going to take
and remember Knight takes B3 at any
moment that will almost always help out
Wesley yeah you know it most certainly
will because that that is basically
resignation in the match you can't win
this with just a rook and a bishop let's
not forget that white is up with Queen
right that's that's like the elephant in
the room yeah we've been talking about
how great these pieces coordinate but
the end of the day the queen is worth
more than these pieces and she's right
there on the board yeah that's a
narrative of this game like there's a
reason that certain things are the way
that they are in chess there's a reason
you have to develop there's a reason the
move order exists there's a reason that
the queen is such a powerful piece as
we're talking Hikaru drops now to three
minutes his time Advantage has
diminished greatly yeah here's waiting
for that pop-up like that is the worst
pop-up of all time right now that's why
he puts his Bishop on F6 he knows he has
never been on that square before ever
actually he's never had a bishop on F6
please and gentlemen F3 by Wesley yeah I
think that move just had to happen at
some point pawns on light scores it
doesn't look very nice you're giving up
a lot of dark squares but with the
presence of opposite Bishops Dania
that's just has to happen at some point
it definitely does Hikaru again trying
to reshuffle Reger out he's trying to
find the arrangement of pieces that's
going to lead to the most amount of
tactical tricks obviously the one
constant is that the Knight is not going
to move away from C5 like ever like that
Knight is there so good there for life
but it's stuck there it is just there on
C5 so if it ever moves to E6 for example
Bishop takes me E6 immediately yeah
there should be three
questions either Wesley said come at me
I've got my ideal defensive Arrangement
show me what you got I think we might
see Hikaru moving his Bishop back to F4
he's put his King on G7 again as an
anti-repetition measure again he knows
that's a safe Square he hasn't been
there before wow F4 though that's I mean
a committal move it's maybe not a bad
move but what it is from Wesley is it's
it's changing the position I think he
was probably happy to see this but now
that the landscape has changed he can
take the bishop and then take the pawn
on B5 and you actually can't recapture
on C7 due to the fork on C5 I'm positive
that that'sikaru's best chance I think
we're gonna see Knight takes B3 here
because if you don't do it you're gonna
lose that opportunity and it's not going
to be there in the future no Wesley can
move his Bishop back to C4 I mean A4 I
would be more skeptical about because
then the bishop is loose rookie two
becomes a problem but the reason Wesley
traded these puns is that now the bishop
is totally paralyzed and yet another
enemy has entered the room for the first
time Black's King is now flat out unsafe
yeah and you need pieces to babysit it
okay night p7 I thought about that your
car were rerouting to another Outpost
not really an outpost but a safe Square
on D6 I think and he finally has a
square
where F7 is protected yep that will free
up the Bishop from F6 so what he wants
to do is probably some Knight D6 Rook C5
check and Bishop G5 finally the pieces
start to get to more you know
well-defended squares and yeah it's
actually going to be well careful of
King the B3 yeah Knight A5 checked so
easy to miss Westwood down to amenity
Cara has done what he wanted to do
exactly Wesley's claw continues to
dwindle he's frittering away his time
Bishop back to D3 Goes West he's trying
to limit the Knight as much as possible
but he not letting him breathe easy he's
making threats on every move he is and
well I have to credit hikaru's play I
will also say that I think Wesley has
done a great job here not only has he
found Queen C1 but Bishop on D3 covering
that Knights every single move
beautifully done that's an unbelievable
move reminiscent of Geary's Queen G4 to
D1 against niho he's attacking C7 and
this is the only weak spot in Blacks
entire campaign that's right the night
used to be on C5 Daniel where it was
never an issue but you bring it to D6
well and in life there's a give and a
take there is a given a take and the
pawn on C7 is going to be taken and once
it's taken it's the pulsing a heart of
Black's position you might lose B6 on
top of it exasperation there yeah he
missed that retreating move he knows
he's missed something and it frustrates
him he's got to play 98 that is not the
move you signed up for Queen C6 Rook to
d8 or King f8 are needed and now the
bishop can slide back to C4 and pressure
the pawn and F7 Wesley should pull this
out at this point the only way I see him
losing this is either on the clock or by
missing a fork or by getting overly
nervous he plays Bishop F5 maybe The
Rook should slide over to A4 and harass
the A2 Pawn that's right but these are
one-way threats I'm on at this point
Hikaru is basically resorting to making
one move threats and just hoping for a
blunder not a bad strategy by any means
and 62 000 people are here with us
Daniel we welcome all of you if you're
just joining but hopefully you've been
here the whole time because this is an
insane finish that we're seeing a must
win game for Hikaru Nakamura as so many
things going on in this position Daniel
this is as hype as it gets there's money
there is pride there is everything on
the line Queen on A8 by Wesley he is
keeping his composure him on and he's
doing an amazing job of it Hikaru was
made backward problem progress in the
last 10 moves the only thing you could
argue is that he's brought Wesley's
clock to 30 seconds but that increment
is going to save Wesley's life here it
is but Hikaru Nakamura still has to be
content that he's getting something in
his Direction the time getting lower
will only increase the chances however
the trickiest piece in his position is
the Knight on E8 and he can't move it
and the second trickiest pieces are his
pawns if all the pawns disappear then
it's an easy draw he tries to win the G5
Pawn Wesley could just Chuck the pawn
and say hey I'm weakening your king
permanently I think you should play G6
here
he goes Queen H1 instead and that pawn
can be taken and look if you're he
covered Nakamura you don't have time to
look at all the repercussions of what
will happen if I take well if I don't
lose a piece here I want to take that
pawn no you have to take that pawn I
think that added onus of of having your
past pawn and F7 is going to contribute
to the stress of defending this if
you're Wesley but his Queen is as active
as it's ever been yeah and be careful of
Rook to E6 you don't want to play a move
like well it covers things but yeah
you're you're just uh just in time
Bishop C6 is where he wants to place
that piece and I think the Rook is going
to move to E6 but then the king can
slide over to D3 defending and unpinning
at the same time Queen G8 as well is
gonna hit that F7 Pawn in such a weird
way right Rook to E7 defending it it
just doesn't feel comfortable The Way
Wesley has used his Queen to attack your
car response has been so impressive I'd
also point to the move Bishop D5 yeah
that could combine with quench again
it's just win the game outright that's
right Bishop C6 Queen G8 also might tie
black down the the defense of that
Knight on E8 so much that you just can't
move in order to win yeah and Bishop B5
Hikaru again he's trying to find that
Arrangement where he's defending
everything and you know exerting
pressure on Wesley's position but that's
such a tall order I feel like you can do
one or the other but can he find a way
to do both moves are going to be coming
in Rapid Fire here as this is the mark
of a strong player can you coordinate
three pieces that are often hanging all
at once and they are hanging Wesley
brings his Bishop back to D3 his King
all the way back to D1 Hikaru keeps
drawing I think he's making some
progress now the Knight moves to D5 Iman
there's so many Forks here get the queen
and king get it out of there in like a
six seconds yeah get them far away from
each other we need a long-term release
two seconds Bishop E4 he's gotta move oh
my God Queen down to C8 or something
what's going on here Knight F4 I'm so
scared of a fork here and with four
seconds this is the worst case scenario
by Wesleyan it's coincided with a peak
of activity of hikaru's pieces Bishop F6
this is exactly where he wants the game
in a Time scramble four seconds for
Wesley and he's got 20. he's got enough
time to figure out a tactic or a fork 20
seconds for Hikaru is 5 hours for
somebody else the King's zigzagging and
Meandering its way between box pieces
and chasing the Knight away from C3
that's right if it goes back to D5 we
might see maybe bishop C4 it takes the
pawn
because now the Queen's gonna go to C6
and if you lose the C7 Pawn you
basically lose your winning chances
that's right we could see Bishop to G6
you want to be far away from a night
check so diagonal is great now Queen C6
runs into Rook C5 so maybe Slide the
queen all the way to over to eight and
he does Queen G8 is a you know kind of a
backdoor move instead he backdoors it to
C6 the Knight moves back to D7 again
Rook C5 is a huge problem Wesley might
have to move his King though this is
getting very good for hikar he might
even try Bishop to E5 to defend C7 he
card just keeping the tension and
keeping the tension he's got 50 moves
before the 50 movable comes into effect
that's what he wants but he's lost the
F7 Pawn that was not as planned Bishop
no this might signify the end of
hikaru's winning chances Knight to E5 is
he not getting mated there and the King
sliding back to be one look how expertly
how deftly Wesley sidesteps all the
forks and now the night as passive as
it's ever been and be careful not to
lose your Rook to a fork oh Bishop C6 is
coming now Wesley might flat out be
playing for a win yep that's right but
he doesn't even need to win trust me if
there's a draw on the table his hand is
grabbing that yeah one second now for
Hikaru he's just trying to prevent them
for The Rook
The Rook has been hung by Hikaru and
he's up and he is out of the playing
Hall oh my God what a finale oh my
goodness that was the end of his chances
there he needed that Rook but so hard to
keep it Daniel with the queen having
checks all over the open board Hikaru
did everything within his power and
everything not within his powers the
fact that he got this to a Time scramble
as the incredulous smile of relief by
Wesley so Wesley knows that he dodged a
bullet there Dania as that was surely it
went out of the opening for Wesley so
and the improbable done by Hikaru is he
made that one of the closest games of
the match Wesley had lost that bat Rook
d8 would have been one of his biggest
regrets but he wins the match with a
score of 5-3 but the important thing is
that he survives the last game Amman
that white might have been one of the
most entertaining three minutes I've
ever seen and one of the most stressful
for both of these players for both of
these players exactly that can't be
understated although Hikaru was doing
everything in his power to keep this
match you know ongoing it has to be said
that Wesley was just as impressive
although we don't agree with his
decision to get into that spot with the
queen against the minor pieces and The
Rook Dania he handled himself there and
it looked like improbable tasks four
seconds two seconds there was there were
a zillion Forks all the pieces in close
proximity he somehow pulled it off he
made it happen and he won a car's rook
in the end we have the bracket for you
it'll be Wesley so in the finals but
Geary and nihal sarin are about to play
the Armageddon game to determine who is
going to be through to the finals but
Wesley so right now Oman he is our only
finalist we see him appearing on that
coveted Championship spot first
what a performance by Wesley what a
performance yep absolutely that was an
insane conclusion to just an epic match
I think we all were previewing this and
we were calling it the coin flip that it
was Dania these guys are so strong and I
think it's fitting that we saw all eight
games played in this match and that the
only thing between them was you know
that one win with a big imbalance
Bishops and knights in game seven and
then finally what a conclusion we nearly
saw an Armageddon but Wesley just you
know hung on the nerves at the end none
of us knew how this match was going to
go but all of us knew that it was going
to be ridiculously close and it was it
certainly did not disappoint Hikaru with
a must win essaying the king's Indian
aversion a souped-up version of the
king's Indian trying to avoid Queen
trades it backfired really early
down it was bad Wesley played E5 he
sends hikaru's Knight all the way back
around to G8 right little Ring Around
the Rosie it's like Wesley's making
moves and Hikaru is just undeveloping
his Pieces by the time we reached like
move 15 I'm on we were administering the
last rights for Hikaru yeah I I the
thing is I can never count out Hikaru
but I swear if this was any other player
I'd say no there's no chance but he Kara
Nakamura is just known throughout his
entire career online and over the world
for being so resilient so resourceful
and Daniel it's amazing a Houdini act
that he made it out of this position
with uh any kind of fighting chance and
for a while Wesley was playing perfectly
he takes on his 70 he presses all the
right buttons in all the right orders
but at this point he gets too excited
about a really cool tactic it's a
beautiful move Rook 58. it's it's
stunning it's gorgeous it's lovely he
wins the queen and he kind of stopped
calculating here but it turns out that
he cars three pieces are ridiculously
active the Knight on C5 is entrenched on
an outpost and then things got even
worse for Wesley he loses his E5 Pawn
the bishop gets active and at this point
I'm on it's basically a free-for-all The
Way Wesley defended here from this point
onward is just amazing it is and from
here it's we can't dive into specific
moves because there's no you know way to
win this or way to draw this this is
just you know what we were looking for
as chess fans this is two players at the
top of their game and with much
different tasks at hand they had
different pieces queen versus rook and a
knight and obviously Wesley needed the
draw and he car was playing for his life
in the tournament so a really exciting
finish just Kudos hat proverbial hats
being tipped to both players here just
taking off Governor that was amazing
what an incredible hour we had oh my
lands and Wesley so is through to the
cgc championship but but Anish giri and
nihal star and have some unfinished
business they need to play the
Armageddon when we come back to decide
the remaining spot in the championship
so do not go anywhere because we will be
right back with cgc Armageddon action
between nihal sarin and Anish Geary
we'll see you soon
foreign
foreign
foreign
welcome to Toronto welcome to the cgc
all right your 10 seconds is up
Bishop D2 is that correct
it is not Bishop D2 so it's obviously F2
and then uh Queen G2 Knight H3 and Rook
F1
[Music]
there's also Rook up takes you to the
same thing are you ready for the second
one yeah
unfortunately Bishop D2 doesn't work
because of Rook to G3 oh G3 so Queen F3
first yes okay Queen of the reverse okay
I would stay with queen of three in the
first move and after him
support for them and align and the
Beautiful One yeah yeah you're you're
nailing this one are you ready for the
last one
six
ah
rookie eight check we have take V8 Queen
G6 yeah yeah finally yeah I got one
correct well I want more like ten more
okay I need to redeem myself
[Music]
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
[Music]
hey guys welcome to the Madison meets
every Wednesday we call it the Maddie
great place for just like a hangout I
love the atmosphere casual you can like
grab a beer have some fries Crush some
noobs and chests and right now they're
running a blitz tournament but it's a
great place to hang out every Wednesday
they host it right here at the Madison
and as you can see behind me we're in
full session here it's a great place a
lot of people have dropped into this
very location including Grandmaster
Hikaru Nakamura as recently as I believe
it was last week or a week before and
then guys like me also come once in a
while so it's a fun place to hang out
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Hall in this beautiful city as we are
getting ready for Armageddon the players
have put their bids into the Arbiters
and we are getting close to deciding who
will face Wesley so in the cgc final
this is gonna be so hype but first we
need to dive into our Armageddon format
in Armageddon the players bid on time
the player who bids the lowest has the
black pieces the player with the higher
bid starts with the white pieces and
with 15 minutes on their clock
regardless of their bid if the game is
drawn and this is why Armageddon is so
fun black wins the game the time the
side with the Lower Side wins so
Armageddon guaranteed to decide the
match it's been a pleasure such a
pleasure covering the second day of the
semis with Grandmaster Amman Hamilton by
my side I'm on we don't need any more
excitement our hearts are beating out of
our chests but we're about to get some
more excitement it and we don't need it
but we're gonna get it okay and that's
what the cgc is all about I'm so excited
for this Armageddon it's a tied up
deadlocked match here four to four Dania
But ultimately that's why we have
Armageddon to decide things once and for
all indeed they have gone back and forth
Canty put it best uppercuts here they
have just delivered punch after punch
but they made a couple of draws to
finish off the match it's been
topsy-turvy It's featured amazing
opening preparation and now the match is
finally going to be decided in
Armageddon I can't wait for this to get
underway I'm sure the players can wait
for this to get underway I'm on yeah
this you can see the players there it's
the nerves as well Daniel going to this
Armageddon ultimately these are decided
by who can handle themselves best under
pressure and Anish he's hydrating he's
doing everything possible you can see
nihal in the foreground there with his
arms back just preparing he's gonna need
all of the arm power he can get to move
the mouse and the bids have been
revealed and we are about to reveal them
to you these bids are so so important
okay first in line we are going to get
nihal sarin's bid Here We Go drum roll
please he's waiting with baited
breathamon exactly and his bid is 14
minutes and 15 seconds a month that's a
high bid he wants white yeah that's a
high bit that says look I pretty much
want the white pieces no matter what but
if you're gonna get me black I'm gonna
have tons of time yeah exactly that's
exactly what he says and Anish bids bids
Geary
it is going to be revealed next he's
bobbing his head there and his bid is 12
minutes and 57 seconds what an
interesting bid there in each kind of
agnostic he's like I'm fine playing with
both colors that's right but if you're
giving me black I want a reasonable
amount of time on and you know what's
interesting about this is I feel like in
some weird way both players are happy we
don't have that in chess ever yeah but
but Geary gets almost 13 minutes with
the black pieces isn't that what he
wants I think both players have gotten
what they wanted and these players are
similar in both in more ways than one
they are similar in terms of their
accuracy it's really not a surprise that
this match is as deadlocked as it is
average accuracy 92.2 percent on the
nose for both of them Neil a little bit
more experience what I find really
interesting I'm on a lot more of his
games go into the uh he actually
succeeds a lot more in the end game
these are some really interesting stats
going into the arm again and especially
because you have to remember the
Armageddon means that the guy with the
black pieces can draw the a game and
we've seen that in the last couple games
we've seen these draw offers by Geary at
this point I feel like if he snuck in a
draw stopper stop with disrespect stop
associating and he's Geary withdraw as a
mine I know what you're doing there Gary
this is the happiest you will ever be
after making a draw we remind you as the
arm again gets underway that a draw
benefits the side playing Black Anish
giri advances with a drawn we have
another London system by nehal He Is
repeating the opening from the previous
game month to the letter and I think
that is a risky decision because what is
the most likely thing that your opponent
has just checked after you've played it
well that very opening especially
because Anish didn't take a rocket
scientist to see it wasn't going well
for him at the start yeah and it makes
sense nihal has repeated openings in the
past he repeated the perk that didn't go
well this is obviously a safer choice
and right now niho is continuing to
repeat their previous game the Knight is
on G4 he's played the move B6 there's H3
and I think the biggest Improvement is
to put the Knight on E5 here I think
this is where Anish can get a better
better position and he does and guess
great work this is why I was cautioning
at the beginning you know do you want to
just go right back into a line because
Nihao looks like he's expecting this to
go the same way and Geary is saying oh
I'm ready to Tango because guess what
I've double checked this in the break
before the Armageddon and now 95 is so
much better and I think the reason it's
better has to do with the C4 square look
at the control the black exerts over
that C4 score making it very difficult
for white to untangle his pieces then I
don't be once still not developed and I
want to remind everybody that there's no
increment in this Armageddon game so
flagging very much on the table and
that's why both players will have to
really accelerate their Pace especially
niho he can't be taking those like seven
minute things anymore but as he is I
mean he it takes time to make moves it
does and I think one interesting point
is not just Knight E5 but also a takes
B6 Daniel that's a difference from the
last game he wants to open up his Rook
there's not going to be any a5s in the
position like previous but instead
immediate pressure on the a file and you
mention it the C4 Foursquare so he's
gone for a different approach
centralized pieces pressure down the A
and the C files yeah this is really
interesting I love the way that Anish he
stuck to his overall strategy but he's
made these small changes in the position
looking completely different this is his
second Armageddon that's right Timor
Roger he's a veteran of arm again ncgc
he was on the black side there as well
he has great time management he seems
composed and right now this opening has
only favored one player it's clear that
on yishi probably has the upper hand on
the board indeed he can bring his other
Knight into E5 now hitting the bishop on
F3 which you never want to lose that
fianchetto Bishop the C4 square is his
and guess what that Knight on B1 it
can't even join the action right now not
only can it not join the action it was
actually hurting the coordination of the
Rooks Knight takes before was a massive
threat there that's right necessitating
the move Queen B3 but I'm on the same
page I'm on I think you're gonna see
Knight E5 at some point the Bishop from
Seagate also has A6 notice how every
piece has its nice parking spot it goes
Bishop D7 oh little bit more modest but
again and again the discussion goes back
to this night on B1 can nehal find a way
to move the bishop out of D2 and play
Knight D2 in time if he plays Bishop E3
too soon the Knight C4 might come in
Bishop A4 very nasty move the queen is
almost trapped oh my gosh and you know
what's impressive to me and you know
this is standard fare for these top
Grand Masters but it's clear that Anish
didn't just say oh Knight ge5 that's the
Improvement okay good you know that's it
let's play it he said Knight G5 and he
clearly looked further than that he said
no a takes B6 that's part of the plan
here Bishop F6 and I guarantee he's
probably even looked at how to place all
of his pieces so this bishop D7 idea to
control A4 I bet he's looked at this as
well I'm positive he's looked at it he's
he's carrying these moves out with so
much confidence and nihal for the first
time is taking a deep think maybe he
should have taken that thing earlier
maybe even on move one but right now
it's so obvious that he's regretting his
opening choice now in terms of what he
actually does to get out of this the
movie A4 comes to my mind I mean that is
a very weak Pawn A4 could be met with
the move Queen E8 and that's really
really bad news because you might say oh
I just go B5 an old friend pays us to
visit Bishop takes B5 and again the fact
that he doesn't get this night out in
time is hurting him in every single
variation I'm on yeah no the queen E8 is
so easy to miss as well just adding more
pressure there so he starts with Knight
A3 but while Knight A3 I'd love because
it finally gets that piece joining the
action but the issue with Knight A3 is
you know where's the future for that
night B5 off limits C4 off limits that
Knight has to go C2 maybe D4 but as soon
as you play Knight C2 you give up the C4
yeah that's the problem with having a
position with as many square weaknesses
as niho has he basically has to keep his
pieces in place but just to like cover
these squares and I think Anish
shouldn't even rush her I don't think he
has any sense of urgency just play Queen
C7 Rook C8 keep improving and keep
making nehal nervous I mean this
position isn't going to win itself nihal
has to produce some piece to piece
contact and I have no idea how he's
going to do that when he basically has
to stay passive for the foreseeable
future exactly that's a great point he
has to be passive that's just part of
the you know innate you know values in
his position like he can't go forward
here he has the extra Pawn you don't get
the extra pawn and the push that's a
little bit too much I think we're going
to see very easy moves from Geary Queen
D7 Queen C8 to A6 Rook to C8 uh you know
he has a time to make H6 G6 on the king
side I think that Geary has found
himself a nice easy playable position
where he doesn't have many weaknesses
it's more about the long-term extra Pawn
I don't like Queen D7 though and I was
about to say that the one silver lining
for nehal as I've indicated is to bring
this bishop to D4 and it always starts
with one favorable trade you do that you
can test the bishop on F6 you
threatening the move F4 dislodging the
knight from E5 and you can see the
puzzle pieces start to fall off so I
think nihal should grab the opportunity
and he does that's why I thought Queen
C7 was so much more precise I'm on
that's great now Anish actually does
have to defend the pawn on B6 you could
be down one Pawn here but if you allow a
three on nothing on the queen side well
that's gonna start being a small problem
yeah agreed if you lose the B6 Pawn I
mean you regret everything at that point
but life decisions yeah exactly at this
point is it crazy Dania to do that thing
which is so hard to do and admit you
made a mistake and play Queen C7 I think
you gotta do it I mean you have to
defend this Pawn you're not exactly
gonna go Rook FBA because you're too
proud to move the queen again the move
B5 yeah speak for yourself B5 might be
attempting move for some people but it
locks the bishop on A4 it makes the
structure on the queen side more rigid
makes it harder for black to make inner
road so I think this is a big Turning
Point Queen D7 I'm gonna go so far as to
say him on maybe the evil bird doesn't
reflect that I think it was a serious
mistake also look at how much clock it's
forced on each to bleed down exactly and
that's where nihal is going to thrive if
he can get this position lower and lower
on time another thing is once that
Bishop moves let's say Bishop D4 by
white he's going to be looking to in the
future play you know Rook E1 and maybe a
move like E4 wants to open up and pry
that Bishop open that Bishop on G2 right
now it's not singing a very nice song
but after E4 Dania it's gonna come alive
and compare it to the bishop on A4 it's
going to be singing the h1a8 song it's
gonna be controlling that you know great
Melody oh yeah the famous uh everybody
should get that reference and Rook FCA
bionish he does sacrifice the pawn on B6
what a big decision right there is he
considering some crazy tactics with a
knight check on F3 and then like Bishop
takes C3 it has to be the Knight first
right there's no Rook takes no three
because Knight I'll show that one you
could just grab that pick up everything
okay definitely I won't show actually
Rook C4 is not a bad move you can't
taste I made a great move it's like
classic Daniel Brilliant throw the piece
up and it lands on the right it's great
here oh I'm winning the queen no you're
not the queen moves away from the attack
and takes the knight at the same time so
what we're saying is that Knight F3
check is the proper way to start but
okay you take on C through
congratulations you feel properly
congratulated I do queen B1 Bishop A1
Queen E1 you look up why does two pieces
and a pawn for The Rook what have you
gotten for all of your Tactical
Brilliance that's not how that tactic
usually works you don't normally start
by giving away a full run and then
somehow get it back with you know great
compounding interest no this is this is
probably not the idea if that's not the
idea it's probably a little bit more
amorphous amorphously is just trying to
increase the pressure on C3 but when I
hear the term increase the pressure I
start thinking Bluff I think nihal
should grab that pawn and throw the ball
right back at anisha's court and say hey
what have you got what are you going to
do critical decision we just saw
knee-hale on screen there he was
grabbing his forehead he knows this is a
very tense spot because this might shape
the rest of the game and he's grabbed it
in Bishop D4 we actually saw Knight to
C4 not your Great Mouse slip Rook C4 no
he puts the Knight on C4 he trades the
knights that's a big plus for for a deal
he hasn't had to move his 993 that
Knight got offered an Escape Route it
just got traded but now the C3 Pawn is
under Fire it's under very serious fire
and the obvious move Bishop D4 allows a
rook infiltration to C2 after The Rook
trade this is where I remind everybody
all that a niche needs is a draw so his
strategy changes fundamentally I still
think he's got great chances to hold
this and I was concerned about Rook F to
C1 which was the move played because I
thought maybe Rook to B8 or potentially
Queen B5 but I wanted to evaluate maybe
taking on B4 with the Rook I thought
that was a great idea especially if the
bishop dropped back to E3 or D4 instead
he does the same thing with the queen
but right he doesn't do the same thing
nihal could actually move the bishop
back to E3 kind of looks awkward and
weird but Rook takes B4 is no longer a
possibility is what you're saying white
takes back with the queen if there was a
rook on B8 The Rook would have captured
the queen so Bishop D4 and Bishop E3
both I think are very viable options
another big decision but different
exactly uh Queen B5 yeah it looks like
Bishop D4 and you know if you go that
Bishop D4 route you might lose your
b-pawn but you could still tell yourself
self as Nihao okay I have that a pawn
and sometimes that's what you know these
top players do is they give back
something to maybe liquidate trade more
pieces favorably but here I think the
best decision is these strange looking
Bishop E3 it's hard to arrive at that
conclusion you want to hear something
crazy provoking Rook AC and I'm gonna
make these moves real fast could
actually be a good thing for white you
can drive the bishop up to D4 by now and
after the bishop trade this is very
computer-ish I will admit I wouldn't
find this in a classical game but now
you can't take on B4 because you're real
Kings or your back rankings either way
if you start with Bishop D4 then after
the trade black and very safely take on
B4 I think this is what Anisha is
deciding between this kind of end game
obviously white is the only one playing
for when you pointed it out he's got the
A2 Pawn right but Black's got a pretty
ideal defensive Arrangement he's
blockading the pawn Amman do you think
nihal will weigh his winning chances
highly in this end game or is he looking
for something more something more dude
keep it blunt I think this is not enough
especially given that you know there's
an element of you know is this good
enough for me me but also the other
thing you have to think about is what
does my opponent want what's the best
case for them and I think you're looking
at it if you're on each in this spot
right here I think you snap on D4 take
on B4 and say look I'm down upon but
guess what that's why Armageddon is so
beautiful as black you have the draw
odds so while Nihao is playing for two
results one of those results is
unacceptable no I agree with you he took
a lot of time on Bishop D4 so I don't
think he's thrilled to get this ending
normally in a classical game he would
have him up a pawn against a niche
nothing to lose here a draw is
tantamount to a loss so he does have
something to lose okay I think now the
conversation shifts quite drastically to
the clock we get an end game like that
that could last 60 moves that's right in
some cases if Anish gets down to a
minute it won't even matter what the
material count is nihal Will flag him in
a rook in four versus rook and four I've
seen a lot of Grandmasters kind of
forget that they get down to 30 seconds
oh but I've got a drawing there's no
increment it's throwing why not give
draw but they're just getting it gonna
get flagged correct fact and and Nihao
you know is it's got to be the most
likely to do that absolutely
firsthand uh and you know it's nothing
against him that's what you should do
yeah I mean you think I'm supposed to
win the game he thinks about the kind of
money that's on the line at the cgc
Daniel I would happily flag you I would
like I would make 50 moves in Rook
versus Rook position and everybody
should that's what the winning spirit is
you know all about yeah but I'm
surprised that we're not seeing that
Bishop take it because considering E5 it
has to be the only other move that's
going through Anish giri's mind right
now do I want to play E5 coupled with
the idea of a quick D4 right but you
know you play that you open the bishop
it just gets you know too tactical and
in all the wrong ways yeah there were
too many drawbacks to that move and you
would still be down two pawns that's
right okay the second decision is what
he takes on B4 with you can take with
the Rook that common wisdom is you don't
want to trade when you're down but
obviously this is an exception because
his remaining pieces are very well
placed so we are going to get this end
game yep 6 and a half minutes varnish
that is a that is an eternity for a
Blitz game but nihal's goal is very
clear he wants to milk this out extend
this game for as long as humanly
possible that's right and you know
basically what do we do as black I mean
you can move that Bishop back and bring
a rook from B4 to A4 that looks like a
good start you know to just clamp down
on the A2 Pawn how is white gonna fight
against that kind of basic plan Daniel
yeah that piece Arrangement is ideal
Bishop on C4 Rook slides to A4 pile up
on the pawn Geary starts by playing this
very typical GM move you see this on g5s
okay controlling swish but G5 making
some left but while you're at it you're
controlling some squares making it
harder for white to do the same thing
and Anish trying to build up the perfect
Arrangement Bishop C4 and Rook A4 is a
huge threat right if he if nihal loses
the a pawn and Geary has anything over
three minutes yeah I think it's
basically a given that he holds it
exactly and The Bishop's coming to C4
Rook A4 so how do we even begin to try
to hold this I think he go rookies 7 and
you try to go Bishop H5 and you actually
try to exploit the fact that Anish
didn't play G6 and you would not you
would never even think of doing that
usually like G5 just looks Superior to
G6 but I love what you're pointing out
actually going for the throat there
saying G5 is actually over ambitious you
you often times when you're defending
you don't want to commit things that you
don't need to and G5 is a bit of an over
commitment yeah I mean Bishop F3 to H5
you don't say those words every day
that's a hard move to spot and I think
that's exactly what nihal is trying to
figure out is he try to defend his a
partner does he try to attack Black's
King side pawns and throw his a pawn to
the Wolves literally if he wants to take
the former option you could slide the
bishop back to D1 trying to meet Bishop
C4 with A4 but that's like walking on
hot calls I mean you got to be so
careful when you do that because you
might end up losing the pawn and then
having no activity at all yeah and
that's the worst case right if you go
down that path and you just can't see to
the end of the line that your Pawn gets
defended or that you can hold it you're
you're going down a path of uncertainty
whereas Rook C7 Bishop H5 you can see
the end of the path right there you're
hitting F7 and that's really hard to
defend and Nihao with pinpoint accuracy
finds what I think is a necessary move
and I love that he spent time there he
didn't panic and say oh my clock is
dwindling he knows that if he keeps like
a minute and a half on the clock that's
so much without increment he knows that
making the right decision is going to
pay off hundredfold Rook C7 is on the
board this is Crisis time for Anish gear
he's down to five and a half minutes he
can just feel sort of the air uh turning
in nehal's favor here Anish will have to
make a couple of very accurate decisions
here and you'll have to make them fast
and Iman if he plays Bishop C4 yeah the
kicker is that after Bishop H5 you can't
move the F Pawn because of Bishop F7
check you have to play the worst
possible move Rook Cafe you know what
that means boom goes the dynamite the
pawn advances to A5 and now Black's
gotten the worth of worse of Both Worlds
he's passive and he's let the Apon live
push him baby that's right Apon right
and I mean in this position I was very
surprised by Bishop E3 I was gonna say
that the defensive and offensive
construction that I liked was Rook b410
to A4 and dropping the Bishop from B5 to
E8 strangely enough but instead he's
gone Bishop D3 and well I see Rook C3
immediately I'm looking at Bishop C4
Daniel to lock that Rook out but then
the pawn goes to A3 and it's safe on a
dark Square yeah and that was the idea
of Rook C3 and each doubles back and
takes the opposite approach because he
can do so with Tempo he wants to play A3
and that's a safe checkpoint for the
pawn unfortunately that's not gonna win
the game the pawn promotes on the eighth
Rank and it's gonna have to cross a
bunch of War zones before it gets there
Anish feels that he benefits in the
event of a bishop trade we'll see I like
this Pawn on e4 it really this and the
pawn on G5 now seriously clamped down on
White's King side pawns now the decision
to trade Into The Rook end game I mean
Daniel we've all heard the expression
all broken games
is that really true here and you know
did he make the right decision because
I'm looking at Bishop takes E4 pieces
are flying off the board which generally
will favor Anish I'm also having a hard
time figuring out why nihal can't go
Rook C5 attack on and then swing The
Rook over to E5 exploiting the double
pawns because F5 protects one pawn and
loses the other now we should also keep
in mind that if if nihal wins the E4
Pawn for example and loses the A2 Pawn I
don't know who benefits in the event of
like a five on four I think it's niho I
think niho will be able to flag him in a
type of end game where you know he can
make a gazillion moves and that's
exactly what niho is thinking and giri
needs to rush he's a hurry it's kind of
like I can make 50 moves and then go
four on three and then three on two and
then three two one on zero and that's
zero on zero that's 50 times that's
working out but the problem is the
promise for now this is very easy to
defend I mean Gary's strategy is King F6
King G6 and yeah five minutes and four
seconds that's so much that you're gonna
have to melt down and this is gonna be a
three on four very quickly like right
once upon yeah there goes one Pawn um
it's gonna be a four on three already
and you know what this can be one on the
board but yeah without some help from
Anish giri he's got five minutes Daniel
I mean to to outplay him here or even
flag him both are gargantuan attacks and
he's a phenomenal end game player this
doesn't get talked enough like just like
some basketball players who are great
Shooters can also be great Defenders I
mean Anish is a great end game player he
should be able to hold this on the board
and you can see nehal he's the first
state just to make a million moves and
get Anish down to four minutes like you
gotta take this one step at a time
but the problem is oh he plays Z5 but
the thing is this basically that's like
sacrificing 50 moves
50 moves but these pawns are weak on the
surface but look at how the king can
defend both of them from F6 in a way
this is like an ideal Arrangement the
rules for Pawn structures and Rook end
games are totally different yeah yeah no
the sometimes you have the split pawns
and actually it means if you want to
make a pass Pawn you're gonna need to
trade more pawns than you'd like the
more pawns that get traded off the board
I mean the more it helps on each but
obviously you shouldn't trade
indiscriminately if you take on F4 here
white gets the connected pawns I think
that's a difficult one to defend if I
I'm Anish I'm keeping the tension
playing Rook C1 or Rook C5 he's correct
to invest this clock here Rook C1 is
played and you also have to watch a
mouse slip by the way he's investing
time but he's got four and a half
minutes plenty of time he does have a
lot of time and this end game Danny has
actually I
clarified way quicker than me or anyone
could have predicted because yeah we
were talking about 50 moves okay one
Pawn 50 moves one Pawn but instead we
have like 20 moves three pawns exactly
we have a three on two soon to be maybe
a two on one and we're barely 30 moves
in and we're even on the clock for now
that doesn't matter though I mean nihal
can make a million moves if he wants
really quickly you also have to be
careful about F5 there are threats you
can lose this on the board and Anish
does kind of bite the bullet and trade
the pawns nf4 now we have a two on one
that's right yeah that I thought that
would happen like 2025 it's happened
this year but the G Pawn is not on e4 so
it's not like a two on one where yeah
it's on G4 surprisingly the G Pawn is on
you on G4 but if it was on e4 the only
way for a pass Pawn would be to trade
you play F5 now at least you have G5
that's a pass Pawn already created so
better chances than usual for a
two-on-one yeah and it's actually very
easy to blunder the pawn here I won't
make any moves after this but just to
show everybody after G5 King F5 is a
terrible move it allows Rook F7 and and
then Rook F6 and once the pawn is lost
gnf against King is like you can niho
can win this with like five seconds and
he he has beaten me with like five
seconds even without increments so after
G5 you want to play King G6 whatever you
do the King has to stay firmly anchored
to the pawn that's right and notice how
The Rook is staying on the first rank as
soon as black plays moves like Rook E4
the king will come up to F3 attack the
rook and go from there instead he's
hanging around that first rank because
whenever the King goes up he gives a
check from behind and whenever the King
goes down you can attack the pawns so
it's so hard for Neil to actually make
any progress or pose any threats the one
trick that I've seen is to put the Rook
on A7 and try to push G5 at the right
moment dislodging the king from the pawn
it's hard to set that up though and
Anisha is defending this like a champ
but I'm on with every ticking second the
likelihood of a mouse slip increases
don't pre-move anything yeah watch where
your opponent puts the Rook if you're
Anish giri nihal is gonna exhaust every
resource from this and every resource of
different positions exactly there's
another position somewhere that's
exhaust tested looking at this game
because your idea is almost possible
right now G5 checked and really played
it E7 but then rookie won that's why
that's the third reason Anisha has kept
his Rook hanging around he's got two
squares on the e-file and he's got just
enough you can't cover both of them at
the same time but nihal he's going to
try he moves his Rook around to H6 maybe
and don't worry if you know nihal gets
lower on time because at this point it
doesn't really matter if he's got like a
minute two minute time Advantage if it's
a Time scramble at all Nihao likes his
chances yeah 30 seconds on 30 seconds
he'll probably win Rook vs rook and he
is going to try to flag roku's Rook at
the end of the day this is another
scenario for a niche not to be worried
about yeah he's cut off along the file
but you can't play G6 that's right you
can have one thing or the other thing
but not both it doesn't matter right off
as well okay White's got off as well and
man now I really don't see much of a way
to make progress them on in three
minutes let's take a moment to
appreciate how fast the niche has played
and how accurately he's playing this
like a bullet champ so far I mean this
can all change in one blunder yeah one
single move going wrong especially in an
end game like this one move could be the
difference and it likely will be the
difference between them so I agree with
you the fact that Anish has kept up on
the clock is exactly what he needs oh
he's Mr F6 and King G4 now the king's
going up the board oh my God the evil
bar is showing a win Rook H1 Rook H1 you
have to cut the king off but then I
think Rook won yeah and then Rook H6
apparently the winning move is F5 you
trade the pawns and then the king being
cut off is actually significant and if
you trade the Rooks in that position at
the end of the line you're losing
there's king f8 and you lose King God
apparently and you had to play a
well-timed E6 E5 stacking the pun
temporarily that was an impossible move
but does he have to find F5 I think he
does because if he plays Rook H6 to pave
the way for his king anishkins throw his
Rook on F1 I think that might hold F5 is
a winning move and in the hulkins sense
that that winning move is somewhere yeah
he's spending unbelievable insane he's
won the three on Two And he's not one
yet but he's completely winning he's is
getting his King to G7 and that's a
Lucina position you learned that in your
mother's womb if you're a nihal sarin
yep yep actually because the king is cut
off and we were saying the king's cut
off on E7 so what the white King's
coming now it matters now it's not yeah
anisha's gonna come up to me and said
hey you said it didn't matter yeah well
now what matters because White's King
has a clear pathway to the G7 Square
when he reaches G7 you can start pushing
the G upon and then the file I'm on
that's the last thing it it gets opened
so you can move the Rook down in order
to be able to push the pawn this is now
officially winning I don't see any way
for Anish to pull it off if he's down to
two minutes that he thinks the more
confident yeah of course because he
knows that he's just delivered a
Haymaker blow F5 if it gets taken the
king recaptures and hides behind that g
Pawn on G6 there are no checks to throw
it off and meanwhile the black king is a
non-participant and if Rook G1 check
trying to draw the king away it goes the
other way King H5 it goes through G6 one
way or the other either through F5 or
through H5 and finally I'm on if you
play E5 now it's way too late 8 because
white then goes Rook E6 and picks up the
pawn this is over one and a half minutes
I mean Anish can sense it we can all
feel it even if you don't know the rules
of Chess look at anisha's face look at
his time usage nihal he's taking a sip
of water you know what that means a
confidence sip right there he wouldn't
be sipping water if he felt any nerves
in his system this is I mean this is
going to take me some time to process
how did he do that yeah it was it was
his comfort level with being cut off on
E7 because it worked before but then
Nihao found a way to make it so that
that was not the case and Anish just
didn't notice the difference it was so
subtle it was subtle and it tells us how
difficult it actually is to draw these
end games three on two two on one you
know I did mention him on when Anish
traded on G4 h and f versus e might be
the most difficult two-on-one to
actually draw I think anise should have
tried to keep the tension make nehal be
the one to take on G5 I think
practically that would have been a lot
easier to draw and you can see the just
the I don't even know what the word is
Devastation
lot of money nihal sarin is into the
finals unbelievable turn of events as
Anish giri loses on the board a rook end
game and we do see that look of elation
from nihal tsar and I already congrats
to him but unfortunately that's the end
of the tournament for Grandmaster Anish
giri I think the key operative words
were on the board he the clock had
nothing to do okay it had something to
do but not much to do with that win so
there it is folks you see it on the
scoreboard in front of you five to four
knee Hall star and defeating Anish giri
playing from Belgrade and winning the
Armageddon soiling anisha's perfect
Armageddon run he defeated Timur ajabov
he was oh so close them on but
ultimately it wasn't meant to be the
Indian youngster he's a magician an
absolute magician yeah and he wanted
those white pieces he played to the best
of his ability he got that extra Pawn
Advantage I mean he did everything in
his power ultimately you can't change
the evaluation of the position but you
can play it out Daniel and that's
exactly what he did he exhausted every
resource available and to his credit he
made it tricky enough that one of the
best defenders one of the best end game
players in the world still messed up and
one thing we shouldn't lose sight of is
that Anish was very close to just
drawing that or at least or even winning
that outright out of the opening he had
the Improvement Knight G5 he was
definitely better was anishikiri but
playing a little bit sloppily in the
early middle game maybe he got a little
bit too comfortable and once he let
nehal get that pawn up end game from
that point on let's not exaggerate I
don't think I am exaggerating one of the
greatest performances of nihal saron's
career both financially in terms of
surviving the pressure no matter how you
look at it Iman yeah that was absolutely
incredible we're on the edge of our
seats here nihal sarin moves on Dania
just incredible action to end the day I
mean we could not have asked for a
better script they couldn't have
scripted this better in Hollywood and I
really mean it we had an Armageddon we
had a clutch performance by Wesley so a
game that also went down to the wire I
mean that was just a few East for the
eyes and A Feast for us and for the
sixty thousand plus chess fans who were
in on the edge of their seats watching
and four more people were on the edge of
their seats there they are our Danny and
the game so folks we will be back in a
bit for the brave move of the day don't
go anywhere but for now we're swinging
it back to Danny Fabby Robert James for
their thoughts back in the gameplay haul
Danny back to you
well thank you Dania this was this was
quite the right you're right we were on
the edge of our seats because the seats
were smaller out there uh but as you
said Danny here along with Robert James
and Fabi guys oh my gosh right you feel
this just sense of elation for the guys
moving through Wesley so nihal Soren you
also feel just a tremendous sense of
heartbreak you could feel just walking
by Hikaru and Anish in the hall how
badly they wanted it guys Bobby let's
let's talk first just the reaction of
being in the in the shoes of the guys
who aren't moving on to Championship
Sunday what's it like to be in that spot
and and how are they feeling right now I
think it's going to be heartbreaking for
both of them because Hikaru he had a
terrible opening and if it had just
ended there then he might have thought
okay just didn't go my way yeah but in
that final game he actually got very
good practical chances and we were
thinking like it's very likely that you
just blunder here yeah there's a night
low time Knight is hopping around it's
so easy to blunder a fork yeah a skewer
some sort of tactic but uh Wesley never
let it get back that even though he
didn't play in the absolutely optimal
way at all points some of his nerves
just held up he he held that super
important final game and for Anish I
mean it was a drone ending yeah but with
no time very difficult to defend yeah it
just absolutely absolutely heartbreaking
to see Anish uh and and Hikaru if you're
if you're rooting for them let's talk
about the uh the real quick Robert that
while it was a drawn ending you also got
to give Nihao credit for the type of way
he approached an Armageddon that was
never really a chance that he wasn't
squeezing throughout for sure I mean
y'all sorry knows when it comes to a
Time scramble he is going to be the
better player against anybody maybe
Hikaru a couple other people can stand a
chance but Anish giri as good as he is
and bullet wasn't going to happen and it
was a two-on-one he had an extra Pawn he
could make the break when he needed to
even if the position remained equal he
could reset the 50 move counter and keep
playing for the time so I think that
nihal had an excellent strategy he
played the same opening he did in the
previous time he had the white pieces in
game eight so it worked to Perfection
real quick thought from you kanty how
many times have we seen Hikaru played
those types of moments and Come Away
with the dub it was almost like everyone
was just surprised he thought he was
gonna win it's like oh my God he didn't
win they did come in bro and almost like
kicked the TV out there like just like
you know he watching football you're
like ah and you break the TV it was one
of those but yeah it was uh it was also
insane the accuracy from Wesley so
seeing the accuracy it was just
absolutely ridiculous there me Carl
always wins in those type of positions
and he wasn't able to the little risks
that happened in that one game it shows
you how important one game is because he
lost that one game and right now he's
losing in twos he did the same thing
with Duda lost twice lost one then lost
a second and then lost one and then
again lost the second stuff well we now
have a clear view of what's going to
happen on Sunday let's take a look at
the bracket everyone and dial in on our
chess.com first ever Global Championship
the final match will be Wesley so versus
nihal sarin one man playing from Toronto
another surviving from Belgrade he moves
on one more round
what is going to happen in this matchup
of course we're going to have a ton to
talk about as we see the games get
started tomorrow and ultimately move us
on to Championship Monday but all right
let's uh let's back up we're going to
talk about that guys we're going to do
previews continue to react what we saw
today but before we get into that Nemo
caught up with Wesley so not long after
his victory over Hikaru Nakamura and
let's take a look at that interview
congratulations Wesley on advancing to
the championship match of the finals
you played an absolutely crazy game
today and we were all sitting on the
edge of our seats what were your
thoughts in a Time scramble that ensued
after move 24 Rook d8 yes first of all
I'd like to of course thank the Lord
Jesus for This Magnificent win uh
that the game today are just you know
crazy intense I could have gone either
way
um like in the seventh game the third
game today uh I think kicker was better
and you know the games were just crazy
like I don't even know what to think
right now but I'm just very happy to win
obviously quality of the games were not
as high as it should be but uh with
little time it was it was very fun to
play but you know sometimes things don't
go your way but today it did go my way
uh but obviously I'm very happy I played
Hikaru many matches in my life I think
maybe I beat him two out of 10 times
like I have a win percentage of 20 so
going to the match I knew for sure that
it was the favorite also he's been
playing very well recently uh but you
know I figured it also helped me that I
just I came here just wanting to play my
best yes and not to think about their
faults at all obviously there's a lot of
money at stake but as I said before
determine thinking if money will just
make you play worth but it's uh it's fun
I obviously have some questions you know
about you know some of the moves that we
played and he goes much strategy in the
opening uh and uh he was basically the
entire match putting me put into time
pressure and trying to get me to beat me
in these scrambles and it probably would
have worked most of the time but
shockingly today didn't happen right and
I really wanted to ask you actually were
you feeling nervous during that last
game yeah yeah at the same time like I
just wanna play my game because this
happened to me many times before where I
needed a draw with white or with black
and the worst thing you want to do is to
play openly for a draw so actually in
the beginning of the game obviously I
knew he couldn't Place Normal openings
but in the beginning of the game I was
like playing for a win just trying to be
aggressive trying to play the best moves
and take advantage of his mistakes and
it very nearly
worked because
yeah I didn't think of their thought but
at some point during them during the
game I just couldn't control myself
and uh okay the opening I was probably
winning like he makes up his opening and
but I couldn't find a clear Victory and
obviously I made some slight narcosity
Center like Bishop G5 I have strong
doubts about that move and when you get
into the queen end game was very
exciting and I made some big mistakes
like I miss Bishop takes E5
the point being after Bishop D5 Bishop
F4 Queen F4 yeah fifth movement which is
crazy and yeah I very nearly lost it
actually like uh at some point my clock
kept taking down went from four minutes
to two minutes and then I had a few
seconds left
right so you know when you hear Wesley
talk in his interviews I feel like he
spends most of his time talking about
the fact that he's an underdog against
icaro maybe he's won two out of ten
matches according to his memory he
recounted all the mistakes he made in
the game and I wanna I wanna ask you
Bobby do you feel like Wesley's mindset
and just that approach he has where he
is constantly viewing himself as the
underdog helps him in some of those big
big moments I don't think he really
views himself as an underdog okay and
also
chess players tend to remember their
losses more than their wins I'm not sure
if Wesley actually would have a 20 score
against Hikaru I I don't know
against anyone right uh so he might be
like remembering the bad moments but
getting that that he's won some matches
too I remember in 2020 uh right after
the start of the pandemic there was uh
these online matches and Wesley won a
big one against Hikaru so yeah for sure
he's taking his share of losses but also
share of wins
um like we I said maybe he's a small
Underdog but it's very this match was
very close to 50 50 from the start it
was a very close one we knew that it
would go down to the wire
Wesley became the first ever Fisher
random World chess champion in 2019 now
he might be able to become the first
ever Global chess champion you think
tomorrow the uh the nerves are getting
to him a little bit Robert you know it's
interesting because I do see Wesley so
as the most like stoic player yeah
really feel like amongst all the top
players he keeps himself composed at all
times but in that last game it was clear
that he was nervous he even said in the
interview he's like you know I thought
it was just fine but then I probably was
thinking about the result a little bit
and how can you avoid that when you have
so much at stake so much on the line
playing Hikaru Nakamura you are going to
get a bit rattled but when all said and
done he's making his way through to the
championship matchup and he has to be
thrilled with his performance Canty your
thoughts as you see Wesley break down
his interview and the moments that he
felt were critical keeping himself
poised even when Hikaru was trying to
mount that comeback yeah that energy
came on him as a obviously I think is uh
they're kind of you know very uh alike
very very much so but um Hikaru actually
has a less record with uh with so so
axes Up In classical chess I actually
saw this in the percentage and that
shocked me I was like wow I didn't know
Wesley was up so I'm saying like oh you
know I'm this I'm like oh that's not
that good no but you know he's up like
that's the he's basically swindling
people in a way you know how people do
at the park right I'm like 1500 and they
really two thousand
I don't know how Wesley's uh playing
right now I think and and acting but as
a way he's doing great great chess and I
think he's going to do a good tomorrow
too yeah well regardless I guess as we
would say how sweet he is off the board
he is a he is a tiger on the board he
does indeed send hey Cara Nakamura home
uh from the chess.com Global
Championship but all right before we go
home we gotta send it over to Donya and
Amman they are eagerly awaiting to show
us the brave move of the day taken from
the Nihao Sauron victory over Anish giri
thanks Danny great discussion as usual
it is time for the brave move of the day
in which we highlight a key move or set
of moves that decided the outcome of one
of our matches today and today's Brave
of the day literally decided the outcome
of a match it comes from the Armageddon
game between nihal sarin who had white
and had to win and Anish Gary who was
defending a worse end game with the
black pieces Anish defended very
successfully it's a two-on-one rook end
game where it seems like white can make
no further progress in Amman this isn't
the brave move say yeah we need to
contextualize it the lead up to it was
also impressive yeah and it's really
important to focus on this moment right
here the white King on G2 Dania is cut
off by that Rook on B3 and this was key
this is the reason that it's not already
winning for white because if you bring
that King far up the board close to the
rook and pawns then this might be a
different story so right now he has this
defensive mechanism in the position
cutting the king off but it didn't last
for long it didn't because of this move
Rook to H3 that's a great move it forces
blackstruck off of the third rank using
the fact that a pawn end game is winning
for white so Anish he brought his Rook
back to B1 no problem or so it seems the
king inches up the board and King G6
such an innocuous looking move right
you're bringing the king up you're
preventing further progress of white
skin this is the decisive mistake that
draw would have been yielded in several
ways but the best way would have been to
just to shuffle The Rook on the first
rank but so natural is King G6 why is it
wrong well it starts with The Rook H6
check extending the king back to F7 King
fabric F6 is
Checkmate gang F7 you still give the
check on F6 the king is pushed to E7 now
G6 blunders The Rook but the problem is
that the path to the king side is now
clear you go King G4 that's right after
Rook H1 now it's time for the bright
move of the day it looks like the king
is still confined him on but lo and
behold lo and behold you actually play a
move that is not normal for these
positions and you liquidate further and
that's probably why this move was so
shocking to anishkiri that pawn to F5
our brave move of the day it actually
trades the remaining pawns on the board
but it leaves white with something that
he can create the Lucina position and a
winning Rook end game with this Pawn on
G5 incredible that's exactly right black
had to trade because E5 would have
simply dropped to the pawn and after
King takes F5 there are two problems the
first is that the king threatens to get
to G7 then you'll be able to push her
Pawn to G7 and get the theoretical
position Amon mentioned the second is
that the Rook trait miraculously ends up
being losing for black on account of
King f8 F7 you have the perfect
arrangement of Kings wow King E7 King G7
it's like it all works like a charm for
uh for knee Hall and he spent most of
his remaining time and realized that the
position is hopeless he resigned in this
position there's nothing to play for and
nihal sarin on the strength of this
brain boom of the day advances to the
finals what an incredible moment amazing
what an incredible match and remember
it's time to make your move from chrome
to Brave try it now at brave.com
chess what a day of action let us send
it back to our host in the playing Hall
Danny take it away once again
Tanya thanks so much another great
breakdown of the Brave move of the day
so many in those final moments and as we
get set here we are actually joined by a
super special guest from very far away
nihal sarin calling in from Belgrade
Serbia nihal can you hear me
we're here buddy if you got us
let me know if you got me man
I'll sing you a song
okay oh now you can hear okay
the uh
okay okay
well he's he's doing great by the way
everybody as you can see he's uh sitting
there as as a chess.com uh Global
Championship finalist let's dive into
tomorrow's schedule we'll react here as
we maybe get that set up or not guys
give our final thoughts but let's uh let
everyone know what their championship
match is it will be Wesley so versus
nihal sarin one man from Toronto one man
from Serbia where they're playing right
now uh respectively from the U.S and
India The Winner Takes home two hundred
thousand dollars cash money homie all
right guys uh
Robert I wanna I wanna throw it to you
first we uh we saw the incredible
breakdown of the final moments we
recognized how difficult it would be for
for Geary to hold that you know again
let's just give credit to the youngster
for making the choice he did I guess
strategically he knew he wanted white or
he wouldn't have bid that time he played
poised and had a vision throughout the
whole game and ultimately got it done in
the time script what can you say about
how difficult it might be for so to beat
this guy well nihal siren's The Comeback
Kid he lost game one of this match then
he won game two he lost game one of
today which was game five overall and
then won game six and not only that he
lost a seven and came back in that match
exactly well we did hey that was weird
that was weird
but anyway I seriously him losing in
that first game it almost like jolts him
into the form yeah and from games two to
four yesterday he was better throughout
almost all of that then today from games
five uh six through eight after losing
game five it felt like he just had the
upper hand so I don't know what it is
about him most of the times for younger
players they experience defeat then
they're rattled they're shaken they
can't come back from it but nihal sarin
he just plays the position and he has
the style this like Precision to his
game yeah that I think his you know
strength belies his ear like he's just
much stronger and much calmer than you
would think for a teenager Bobby are
there players you've played throughout
your career that have that same sort of
factor where if they lose it tends to
jolt them into playing their best chess
versus versus going the opposite way and
getting emotionally down yeah there are
players who definitely perform better
under pressure or in difficult
situations I actually want to push back
a bit on what you said Robert because I
think that young players are really good
at that they easily forget the bad games
and losses at least from my experience
I'm too young to know any better you
know yeah yeah I think that they just
they just have that internal optimism
like that fire inside you and nihal
obviously has that he's played ding he's
played Anish now he's playing Wesley
he doesn't seem intimidated by any of
these very well established top players
and he's able to to find wins against
them even when he's done in the match
kanty so many of these young players
from India and otherwise have grown up
playing the top players online that's
right I wonder if this format this
feeling is familiar enough that they're
not intimidated by Wesley so Hikaru
Nakamura probably on a carwana Magnus
Carlson these these Monsters of the
generation before them they're ready to
go and do battle they are in fact first
off it's in the water it's in the water
in the Indian water of course if you see
all these young Indian players they all
drink in the water they all getting good
so we need to go there and do the same
right but secondly there is how they're
training I mean they're all training
cram Nick's there as well I mean you had
a non they're helping the kids out there
and they're Fearless even kind of Magnus
says a lot about that too confidence or
if you have confidence I remember
watching YouTube video Magnus was like
uh you know there are players that are
just as good as me but their confidence
is what makes us different and like
that's different that's completely
different you know psychological thing
where nehal and Indian players actually
really have a lot of that as you can see
Fearless yeah yeah Fearless indeed we
are fearless here at the chess.com
Global Championship so we're going to
try one more time and bring in one of
the men of the day Nihao Sauron Nihao
can you hear me
yes yes we got you buddy hey there man
well uh I only have one question when
you started this whole thing did you
think you'd be playing on Championship
Sunday at the chess.com Global
championship
question
of course not okay well maybe a lot of
people thought you had more chances uh
than you did ultimately going into into
this match with Anish Geary what was
your overall strategy give us your quick
assessment starting from yesterday and
today were you looking for an Armageddon
battle in the end versus Geary
um
I did not have any particular strategy
against Anish I was mainly just trying
to
avoid his preparation
just trying to get the game
yeah
and the Armageddon and I did not
think about it
I wanted to try in the fun
it was not intentional to
yeah
we're having a few audio issues I think
we're gonna we're gonna like we're gonna
let you go anyhow thank you so much man
and again congratulations we will see
you tomorrow hopefully have an interview
uh but uh good luck and we will see you
on on Sunday or Monday regardless
thank you bye buddy
okay
okay well uh Robert what was the
question you were going to ask well let
that be a thought we'll dive into here
well he was the only player of the
remaining four who was not the top seed
in their bracket Right Wesley so
anishikiriakaranakamura all were the top
seed in order to be here Neil had to
beat dangly Ren and before that he beat
Vladimir kramnik he took down Sam Sabian
and then he beat Anish giri he has the
most impressive slate of Victories yeah
so I was just going to ask him about the
competition thus far because Wesley so
is a monster nobody's denying that he
just took down a car Nakamura yeah but
why should he be scared when he's
beating all of those big names that I
just mentioned I ain't scared father do
you think being battle tested plays a
huge part when you're ultimately down to
the championship in these types of
grueling Knockouts I think some people
once they they're coming off a big
victory it just gives them that extra
impetus to keep going but some players
tend to relax a bit they feel like I've
already completed a big goal and even
though that's true they're still an even
bigger goal to to be to be had so it
depends a lot on their personal
psychology
like for me coming off a big win against
Hikaru or against Anish I would really
need to try to forget the match and not
celebrate too early that would be an
important thing for me I would just try
to forget all the positive emotions even
it sounds weird to say that but you
don't want to get overly excited and
think I have this all wrapped up because
you still have a long way to go yeah
Kenny what can you buy with 200 Grand
that you can't get with a hundred grand
wow sue that's a good question I have to
think about that one I'll come back to
you on that well that might be the
motivation the players need I guess but
that's a great Point Bobby the different
mindsets of some players right some
people play better when they feel good
some people need to feel down in order
to focus you know or even not feel down
but just feel like yeah like they're
you're not there yet you know you've
completed part of the race but not the
whole thing I mean that sounds like
advice for Wesley though he just beat
Hikaru yeah everyone's top pick to win
it all yeah so now yes this tournament's
not over I still have a really tough
opponent in front of me well and there's
no world where most people probably
won't look at so as the favorite
tomorrow for good reason so we'll of
course make our picks when the time
comes but that's a good point Wesley's
got to keep himself focused so all right
let's give one more quick preview on
tomorrow's matchup if your knee house
coach can't even ask you to do it again
what's the pep talk for the time
flexley so versus wee ball nehal so we
got to see you know Niha we gonna go in
here fresh right I like how he just
sometimes he said like this yeah and be
like hmm very calm leans in a little bit
calculates I like the professionalism
from The Young fella so I'm gonna tell
him keep it up young big fella and let's
work and let's swing right get a good uh
rest and make sure we get some of that
Indian water and we good to go you say
Wesley needs to be calm even though he
beat Hikaru what does Nihao need to do
in order to have a have a good chance
against Wesley yeah I don't know nehal
as personally as I know Wesley for
Wesley I think it's really important
that he gets into a group of things
confidence is really important for him
if he's feeling down if his confidence
goes down his level can really drop
precipitously yeah nihal I just yeah I
haven't played him very much but he
seems like he he didn't seem like he was
overly excited he had just beaten Anish
but he's already beaten guys before who
are also top players it seems like he
takes it in stride which is very
important for him I wonder if we'll see
like a reset tomorrow they're just going
to try to get into the groove of things
they've both got into the final but they
don't want
to you know
to start off things too fast yeah they
just want to take it slow like we saw
also in the Hikaru against Wesley match
feeling feeling it out a bit and seeing
how the other guys also what their
preparation is I'm very curious to see
what nihal will prepare because we saw
him jumping around opening wise against
Anish trying to avoid preparation Wesley
is a more opening wise predictable
player than anisha's will he take a more
principled stand or will he also try to
jump around and feel Wesley out
as Bobby says Robert not as many people
know nihal as as no Wesley
how does nihal avoid the Trap of being
like man I did it I've already got 100
Grand how does he keep wanting it
knowing that he's never been here before
well Neil's been a superstar for a long
time right he was the kid then came
prognananda go cash Arjuna geisi so in
some ways he's kind of hiding amongst
the other teenagers Nordic abducator his
classical rating has not reached the
levels of his rapid his Blitz and
particularly his bullet so I feel like
you know he's used to being sledded Neil
is not he will have to do what Fabiano
just said over there he doesn't have to
avoid the theory he's going to avoid
that the types of positions that Wesley
likes because if he gets a Stranglehold
in the position you're not going to
survive against Wesley so so I feel like
playing this kind of dodgy opening stuff
is not also going to work he needs to
find his specific positions because
Wesley doesn't seem like the type of guy
is going to prep a 30 move variation to
beat him but just getting those Comfort
zones is where nihil Saran has to avoid
when you're thinking about it from
Wesley's perspective
I just remember great stuff last year
super close match in the speed test
Championship it was a semi-final match
to qualify for the final Wesleyan
snehall I was very very close I think it
was 13-15 in the end I don't remember
but yeah it was separated by one game
Wesley wanted that one barely but but
very close so I I suspect we might see
another very close match all right well
good call out there look at it nice you
played in the SEC I'm supposed to
remember those things
oh that's right we watched it during the
World Championship shout out to the cat
t-shirt you were wearing all right well
what a day everybody what an event that
we have had so far and what in the world
will we have ahead on championships
Sunday and Monday uh that's going to be
a wrap for us from the hotel one in
Toronto for today though everybody big
thanks to Robert Our Guest Fabiano
caruana there James Canty everybody and
all of our commentators for another
great day of live chess here at the cgc
finals we have our two finalists and we
are ready for our championship chess
make sure to join us tomorrow on Twitch
and YouTube as we begin day one of the
finals the chess starts at noon Eastern
9 A.M Pacific for now I'm Danny wrench
this has been a lot of fun and good
night from Toronto
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]